Die Fahrkarten bitte.
Das war der Ton, von dem ich dachte, dass ich mir vielleicht vorher noch mal irgendwie organisiere.
Sind wir schon drauf.
Um diese Sendung einzuleiten. Ja, wir sind total drauf.
Es ist 13.41.
Es ist viel zu spät und wir hätten auch wirklich, ja, schneller sein können.
Um 14 Uhr muss ich zu Hause sein.
14 Uhr schon. Sonst muss man immer erst um 20 Uhr zu Hause sein. Ja, willkommen bei mobileMacs Ausgabe Nummer 40. Und der ersten Ausgabe in 20.10. Mein Name ist Tim Friedloff und ich begrüße von links nach rechts das volle Programm. Deniz, Deniz Abels. Huckel. Und erst wieder vor noch Nachnamen, oder? Und Max, Max Winder.
In 2040.
Schön, dass wir uns alle in 2040.
In 2010.
In 2010, ja. Soweit sind wir jetzt auch noch nicht. Wir hätten dich nicht so früh auftauen sollen.
Immer noch kein Tablet.
Immer noch kein Tablet. Ja, wir haben so viele Themen jetzt, die so, also nicht wahr, also bei der Bearbeitung, Erarbeitung der Themenliste hier für diese Sendung ist eine ganze Menge alte Scheiße hochgekommen. Alle meinten so, das ist doch schon ewig her. Ja, weil unsere letzte Sendung schon ewig hier ist. Habt ihr denn überhaupt meine letzte Sendung, die ich versucht habe zu retten gehört?
Ich hab so mal rein gehört.
Und bist schnell wieder davon gelaufen.
Ja, nee, es war so zwischen zwei Dingen, wo ich nicht genau wusste, was ich tun sollte. Dann dachte ich vielleicht mal rein und dann hab ich so bestimmt so zehn Minuten zugehört und dann noch mal dein Resümee auf der Seite gelesen und dann war aber wieder was anderes wichtiger.
Die war länger als zehn Minuten?
Ja, ich hab eine anderthalb Stunde gehabt jetzt am Stück. Alena.
Ich fand es gut.
Ich hab schon mehr... Klingt schon ein bisschen so, als ob ich in eine Dose stecken würde.
Ja, das...
Wie Oscar der Mülltonne.
Ich kann das mal kurz ausschalten, dann ist es ein bisschen leise vielleicht noch. Wir experimentieren noch ein bisschen. Ich hab natürlich wie immer hier parallel an meinem Studio ein bisschen weiter ausgerüstet. Ich hätte jetzt hier noch einen anderen Mix in den Kopfhörer packen müssen. So ist es besser. Es ist ein bisschen zu viel Echo. Man kann das nicht hören. Ihr da draußen wisst jetzt überhaupt nicht, wovon wir reden. Das hat ja alles was mit technischen Sachen zu tun, aber damit euer Pegel irgendwie...
Davon haben unsere Zuhörer ja keine Ahnung.
Wird hier noch so ein bisschen nachgeriegelt. Ja, wer hat schon Ahnung? Bevor ich das wieder vergesse, möchte ich auch noch ein paar ein paar Dankes-Worte richten hier an Leute, die uns irgendwie mit Sachen beglückt haben. Unter anderem ist hier ein Kuchen aufgeschlagen von Andreas. Der hat wohl so verschiedene Podcasts bedacht. Er ist sehr hübsch irgendwie mit Kuchen und Fotos und unsere Abatare. Ach du, du hast dieses Cover noch gar nicht gesehen, ne? Genau, dann schaust du dir noch mal in Ruhe an. Das ist irgendwie so ein Kick zum Klicken. Letztes Mal gab es dann auch noch die ganzen Kekse, die ihr verpasst habt. Die hab ich dann mit meinem Sohn verfüttert. Die kamen von Ulrike und von Robert, der auch noch ein paar lustige Aufkleber mitgeschickt hat. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich die hinnehmen soll. Genau. Und auch danke dafür. Die waren übrigens ausgesprochen lecker. Die Kekse? Ja, also sowohl die einen als auch die anderen. Ganz hervorragend. Also wirklich so. Ich bin immer wieder erstaunt. Na ja, ihr seid ja nicht gekommen. Es stand hier alles irgendwie vorbereitet. Ich hatte Kerzen an. Der Baum stand in der Ecke.
Kleine Geschenke waren für alle vorbereitet.
Natürlich, klar, die hab ich mir alle selber geschenkt. Jetzt hab ich vier iPhones. Die hab ich dann wieder zurückgeschickt zu Steve. Tut mir leid, Steve, konnte ich nicht verteilen.
Wollte keiner haben.
Das war der Markttest für das Tablet, kam nicht an. Was, wie?
Verstehe.
Aber ich war wirklich krank. Ich lag wirklich todkrank im Bett, hatte Fieber und alles.
Ich mache euch auch keine Vorwürfe, also nicht jetzt. War auch mal ganz interessant zu sehen, wie es eigentlich so ist, wenn man so etwas alleine macht. Ich kann euch sagen, es ist anstrengend, weil man dann doch, gerade wenn man so ins Ranten kommt, da fehlt dann einfach so ein bisschen der Ausgleich. Ich wollte dann auch mal ein bisschen gebremst werden. Ich brauch auch mal ein bisschen Widerspruch.
Ja, der hat auch das Gefühl. Ich saß noch beim Hören daneben.
Du brauchst doch den Widerspruch nur, damit du dann noch mehr ranten kannst.
Deswegen war ich auch nur eine halbe Stunde geredet. Mit ein bisschen Widerspruch hätte ich noch zwei Stunden drauflegen können. Wie wir das sonst ja auch machen. Jetzt haben wir die Danksagung schon mal durch. Das ist super, denn das finde ich immer sehr doof. Und wenn man das vergisst, und jetzt hab ich es nicht vergessen, letztes Mal habe ich es nämlich vergessen, deswegen muss sich das jetzt noch nachreichen. Grundsätzlich kann ich sagen, wir sind immer wieder sehr angetan von unseren Hörern. Bitte? Du musst dich auch bedanken, dann mach mal.
Es gibt noch mal jemand, der mir einen Atmel-USB-Key geschenkt hat.
Ach.
Und weißt du, was der Sack gemacht hat? Ich hab das Ding, das ist halt so ein USB-Key, der erstmal so tut, als wenn er ein USB-Flash wäre, habe ich in meinen Rechner reingesteckt, kannst das so mountain, ist da so die Doku, habe ich reingeschickt und wo bin ich gelandet? Bei YouTube, bei Regroll. Der hat die Doku gegen das Regroll-Video ausgetauscht. Ich hab mich schon erwartet. Hat aber echt eine Weile gedauert.
Gut, dann können wir ja auch mal hier loslegen mit der tollen Sendung. Wir haben, es gibt ja hier immer diese Public-Wave und da haben wir jetzt mal hier unseren Exerpt rausgemacht, weil all das können wir sowieso nicht behandeln, deswegen wollen wir uns ein bisschen konzentrieren. Und wir haben gesagt, heute fangen wir mal ein bisschen an, erstmal mit den Sachen, über die wir so schon lange reden wollten. Jetzt kommen also erst mal alte Kamellen. Und eine der alten Kamellen, über die wir hier nie gesprochen haben, ist die Änderungen, die sich ergeben haben bei Pirate Bay. Ihr wisst, Pirate Bay, das war dieses Portal. Dennis, schon mal gehört?
Die Portal hatte ich ja nie irgendwas zu tun.
Nein, aber jetzt hast du deine Finger auch überhaupt nicht mehr, machst du gar nicht mehr schmutzig, aber die ja auch nicht. Ich meine, sehe ich das richtig, kann man das so zusammenfassen? Die hatten halt einerseits eine Menge Stress und auch irgendwie, glaube ich, so ein bisschen schnauzevoll und sahen sich konkret auch so in dieser Problematik, dass sie natürlich dadurch, dass sie auch noch den Trecker fahren, extrem angreifbar waren, weil das ja sozusagen die einzige verbliebene Argumentation war. Ihr tauscht ja da konkret Daten aus, die Teil des Falschairings sind und dann kann man natürlich lange darüber lamentieren, welchen rechtlichen Status das genießt. Tatsache ist, ohne diesen Torrens, bis zu dahin, lief es halt nicht. Also man kann schon sagen, dass sie da auch massiv daran beteiligt waren, die Infrastruktur bereitzustellen, um diesen Dateiaustausch zu ermöglichen. Das steht ja eigentlich auch technisch vollkommen außer Frage. Wie das juristisch bewertet wird und wie das kulturell politisch bewertet wird, ist natürlich noch mal eine ganz andere Geschichte. So, jetzt haben sie das aber sein lassen und das hat sich ja eigentlich auch schon lange abgezeichnet, weil sie ja im Prinzip, wenn ich das richtig deute, korrigiere mich, wenn du es anders siehst, diese Treckerinfrastruktur ausgelagert haben in openbittorrent.com.
Also sie haben es einfach abgegeben und das machen jetzt andere Leute, so kann man das sagen.
Ja, genau. Und die laufen da halt einfach als offene Trecker rum, das heißt, die kann man sich halt einfach eintragen, wenn man selber ein Torrent erstellt.
Anonyme Trecker, wo man sich nicht anmelden muss, genau.
Genau, aber das heißt, Pirate Bay selber existiert noch. Die Seite ist wieder da und macht jetzt keinen großen anderen Eindruck als sonst auch, bloß mit dem Unterschied, dass halt die Trecker nicht mehr da betrieben werden und dass jetzt auch massiv auf diese sogenannten Magnet-Links gesetzt werden. Oder anders ausgedrückt. Genau. Also es geht jetzt nämlich sozusagen um einen treckerlosen Betrieb. Und ich glaube, das ist das, was auch vielen Leuten so nicht so richtig klar geworden ist, was da eigentlich passiert ist hinter den Kulissen. Also einerseits sind die Trecker ausgelagert worden, andererseits hat man auch noch voll darauf gesetzt, auch ohne auszukommen. Und das geht dadurch, dass der Austausch der Informationen, die bisher nur in den Torrent-Falls selber drin waren, sprich die Checksum, der einzelnen Blöcke, der auszutauschenden Datei oder Dateien, dass man die sich jetzt auch aus dem Netz rausholen kann, ohne eben einen solchen Trecker zu bemühen.
Nee, ohne die Zeit zu bemühen, um das Torrent runterzuladen.
Ja, ja gut, also ohne ein Torrent zu haben, aber dann läuft es ja auch Treckerless.
Ja, ja, aber vorher musste man ja das Torrent runterladen und dann hat man sich zum Trecker verbunden.
Und der hat einen dann zu den anderen Piers verwiesen. Und jetzt lädt man sich gar nichts mehr runter, man kriegt eigentlich nur ein Magnet-Link, genau, ein URL mit sehr viel Zeichen da drin. Und was steht da genau drin? Ja, und was macht man dann damit?
Na, der connectet sich über das DHT, was es ja auch schon vorher gab. Der connectet sich zu irgendwelchen anderen Piers.
Also DHT Distributed Hashtable. Also eine im Netz verteilte Tabelle von Hashtables.
Und um überhaupt erstmal, weil ich dachte mir auch früher mal, wie soll denn das funktionieren? Aber es ist natürlich so, du musst, irgendwen musst du kennen, um erstmal in diesem Distributed Hashtable-Netz teilzunehmen. Das heißt, entweder hast du noch Peers, die du dir gemerkt hast, oder es gibt so Links oder ULTs in deinem BitTorrent-Client eingetragen, wo du dich erstmal hinconnecten kannst. Man könnte es schon so ein bisschen wieder so Super Peers oder Master Peers oder wie auch immer nennen, aber irgendwen brauchst du, wo du dich erstmal hinconnecten kannst. Also wenn du zum ersten Mal anfängst, musst du ja irgendwas haben. Später hast du dann zufällig welche eingesammelt.
Ja, aber woher, also das hab ich nicht verstanden, woher kriegt man diese ersten, an die man sich wendet?
Na irgendwie, da sind die in einem kleinen schon eingebaut, weil die selber so eine Art Mini-Infrastruktur fahren, um ihren eigenen kleinen mit DHT-Notes zu versorgen. Also ich glaub in Transmission, die haben sich da was eingetragen. Weil irgendwann, also wenn du zum ersten Mal irgendwie...
Ja, mit irgendwas muss man anfangen.
Mit irgendwas muss man anfangen, genau. Also ganz ohne geht's halt nicht. Irgendwen musst du halt kennen. Und das könnte man fast schon wieder, diese Mini-Notes, die von Transmission werden, die sowas eingerichtet haben, könnte man fast schon wieder so einen Mini-Tracker nennen. Aber den können die halt jederzeit tauschen. Im Programm können sogar mehrere eintragen. Also das ist einfach viel billiger. Und der wird halt auch nicht mit jedem Mal vollgeballert, sondern halt nur einmal, beim ersten Mal. Wenn du irgendwann dann PSP hast, kannst du den in so einem Cash-Market und kannst immer mal gucken, ob die noch da sind, kannst die Fragen und musst ja nur so lange rumprobieren, bis du einen gefunden hast. Und dann alles andere ergibt sich ja dann. Aber den initialen Contact, den brauchst du schon.
Aber ich meine, was speichern denn diese initialen, wie heißen die nochmal, diese Entitäten?
Ich hab die so genannt, die würden die Supernodes nennen oder Master Peer, ist das total egal, wie die genau heißen. Ich glaube, das gibt es keinen richtigen Namen.
Ja, aber welche Informationen geben die denn dann weiter? Ich meine, die müssen ja dann diese Hashes auch kennen, die müssen ja dann diese getreckten Files auch kennen.
Also so ist halt, wie das Distributed Hashtable funktioniert. Denen sagst du halt, was du haben willst, die connecten nicht weiter zu dem, der ist dann irgendwie weiß. Also bist dann sozusagen in so ein Netz drin und wirst durchgerutet.
Bis man einen Peer gefunden hat, der die volle Torrentinformation hat sozusagen.
Genau. So wurden früher über dieses Distributed Hashtable einem Peers gefunden. Und dann hat sich einer überlegt, wenn ich es jetzt richtig verstanden habe, ist ja alles ein bisschen komplex. Da hat sich einer überlegt, naja, man könnte ja nicht nur, dass die Peers so verteilt werden, sondern eigentlich könnte man da drüber ja auch gleich das Torrent-Pfeil selbst runterladen. Und so haben sie sich halt das Torrent-Pfeil gespart, haben das in Magnet umbenannt. Und jetzt kann man über das DHT sozusagen sich auch gleich das Torrent-Pfeil runterladen. Und deswegen können die bei Pirate Bay, deswegen hat hier auch der, wie heißt der, der Peter, wie heißt der, Broke P? Hat ja irgendwie getwittert, immer hier demnächst kommt alles irgendwie komplett neu und wir machen alles ganz anders und Tracker brauchen wir sowieso nicht mehr. Das ist genau das, was er meinte. Das sind Magnet-Links. Das heißt, bei Pirate Bay brauchen sie jetzt nichts weiter als ein Oll anbieten. Das Problem war auch nicht nur der Tracker, sondern, dass man halt dort dieses Torrenfeil runtergeladen hat. Also für die, ich sag jetzt mal wieder Justiz oder besser noch für die Musik- und Filmindustrie ist halt immer das Schlimme, wenn man da schon initial was runterladen kann. Dann ist das für die ja schon das Verbrechen. Also das Torrenfeil war wahrscheinlich für die schon das Verbrechen. Und das haben wir jetzt halt entsorgt, indem sie halt nur noch jetzt diesen Magnet-Link anbieten und sagen, wir wissen eigentlich überhaupt gar nichts. Und hier hast du eine Oll und da gibt's angeblich was, kannst ja mal gucken. Und dann nimmst du halt diese Magnet-Oll, legst da los, findest per DHT irgendwie den entsprechenden Pier, lädst von dem das passende Torrent runter und legst dann los. Und das war's dann schon. Und dann braucht man auch keine Tracker mehr, weil Pier's findest du auch über das DHT. Wenn der erst mal passt, dann gibt's ja noch zusätzlich dieses Packs, das ist ein Pier Exchange. Das heißt, wenn du einen Pier hast, kannst du den fragen, gib mir mal deine Pier's. Wenn der schon 50 hat, dann kann er dir die gleich geben. Also so ein bisschen sind Tracker gerade überflüssig. Deswegen sollte man eigentlich die Tracker so ein bisschen umschreiben, dass sie halt so eine DHT-Supernodes werden, falls man dem Netzwerk richtig gut helfen will.
Verstehe.
Das heißt, Open Tracker wird jetzt gar nicht mehr so dringend gebraucht.
Doch, da knallt es schon noch ordentlich, aber eigentlich auf lange Sicht nicht mehr.
Du meinst, dass es stabil genug ist, die Infrastruktur so ohne Tracker?
Wenn halt genug Supernodes da sind, wenn du keinen findest am Anfang, stehst du auch da.
Wobei, das Wissen um Supernodes, das lässt sich natürlich auch ganz gut im Internet streuen. Am Ende fängt man wieder an, in Newsnet-Gruppen zu posten oder so.
Oder suchst du halt irgendwie im Netz, kannst du auch immer mit Google suchen, ich brauche hier Supernodes oder wie auch immer es heißt. Ich weiß nicht, wie die die Dinger sind.
Ja, okay, wir lassen jetzt mal den Begriff aus und vor.
Suchst du irgendwie, dann sagt einer, er hat hier einen, der kann ja noch so klein sein, ist ja total egal, du connectest dahin, der connectet dich weiter und schwuppt bis zum Netz drin.
Gut, also wir halten fest, das funktioniert irgendwie immer noch mit dem Betorrent.
Ja, was natürlich ein bisschen schade ist noch, was ja weggefallen ist, die Leute haben es ja bestimmt gemerkt hier, Mininova musste irgendwie klein beigeben und hat den kompletten Content gelöscht, wo die Film- und Musikindustrie meint, dass es ihrer wäre. Das heißt, die gibt es sozusagen. Nur noch in klein. In Mini, ja. Wir sind jetzt ganz schön Mininova-mäßig.
Nano-Nova sozusagen.
Ist echt geschwumpft, der kleine Zwerg.
Aber ich meine, das ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt irgendwie weniger getauscht werden würde, oder? Kann ich nicht feststellen.
Ich würde mal behaupten, in der Zeit ging es schon doch ganz schön abwärts, kurzfristig. Also.
Und Isohand ist ja, ist jetzt noch die einzigen, oder sind noch die einzigen, oder?
Nee, es gibt immer noch, also wir sind ja echt noch ganz schön harmlose Jungs, also weil die richtigen sind die Netze, die richtigen schlimmen sind die, also wo man halt nicht reinkommt, diese Elite-Systeme mit Anmeldungen und Schnick Schnack. Und das sind auch die, die von der Polizei oder wem auch immer öfter mal ausgehebelt werden, weil das ist dann schon schwer kriminell. So mit richtig Geld bezahlen und mit irgendwie noch mehr bezahlen, wenn du mehr runterladen willst und so, diese Dinge. Und die gibt es ja bestimmt noch überall, aber davon, damit haben wir ja nichts zu tun. Ich finde, mehr ist so eine Sache, aber dafür bezahlen ist irgendwie der andere. Dann könnte ich mir auch gleich das Original kaufen. Also die drei Euro mehr, ist mir dann doch wert.
Ja, das ist dann doch irgendwie die Kultur-Flatrate in der Stelle. Nur, dass man halt irgendwelchen Mittelsmännern zahlt, dass man schon wieder passt für die Musikindustrie.
Kultur-Flatrate finde ich ja voll blöd.
Ja gut, das Thema wollte ich jetzt so auch nicht auf die Agenda setzen, aber wenn man das jetzt mal übersetzt, die Leute zahlen da sozusagen für den Zugang. Die machen sich so eine Rare-Splatrate für ihre Kultur halt. Nur, dass es dann wiederum nicht an die Künstler geht, sondern eben an irgendwelche russischen Garnobenbanden oder so. Keine Ahnung, wie das hier nicht die Russen alle beim Kamm scheren, aber ich glaube, Osteuropa ist ganz gut unterwegs bei dem Programm.
Aber ist doch auch immer noch so, oder, dass da viel im Usenet auch einfach umherfliegt und die das da rauspulen und ins Beton stellen dann.
Ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher, ob das wirklich so aktiv ist. Weil dem haben sie ja in letzter Zeit auch kräftig auf den Arsch gehauen.
Echt? Da haben wir zum Beispiel noch gar nichts mitbekommen.
Aber ich halte diese ganze Bewegung auch nicht bremsbar. Auf gar keinen Fall. Ja, nächstes Thema. Es wurde hier auch nochmal nachgefragt. Und seit der letzten Sendung wusste ich da auch noch nicht viel Neues zu berichten. Aber tata, ich habe jetzt endlich mal meinen Macintosh bekommen. Hat lange gedauert. Ich glaube, die sind immer noch sehr schwer zu kriegen.
Du sagst wieder Macintosh.
Stimmt, der ist auch neu.
Das ist ein Macintosh.
Das nennen die nicht nur noch Mac?
Die nennen immer nur noch Mac.
Aber Timme, der ist auch neu, oder?
Das stimmt, ich glaube, sie nennen sie wirklich. Ja, der ist neu. Das ist ein iMac 27 Zoll Quad-Core in der i7-Ausführung. Also das rechts unten Modell, genau. Vielleicht sollten wir noch mal kurz erklären, was wir mit rechts unten sagen wollen. Weil bei Bizzos so sagen, sind wir immer rechts oben.
Was?
Die sind nicht oldschool genug.
Ja, die kennen es nicht, weil es gibt nur noch eine Reihe.
Genau.
Und natürlich ist ihr Browser Fenster so groß, dass ihr so viel Platz habt, dass das nur ganz oben ist.
Die haben das nicht verstanden.
Tatsache ist, dass es mal diese Produktmatrix gab von Apple und immer das Vollausbau-Modell war halt einfach rechts unten in der Tabelle. Das war halt einfach so. Und das ist also das rechts unten Modell, auch bekannt als iMac 11,1. Und das Ding ist einfach mal schnell. Also es ist so schnell. Ich kann jetzt gar nicht so viele Performance-Beispielen geben und so. Es gibt verdammt wenig Software, mit dem man das Ding irgendwie ausreizen kann.
Handbrake.
Ja, da wollte ich eh gleich nochmal drauf zu kommen, mit der Ausnahme von Handbrake. Vier Chores, wobei jeder Chore halt nochmal virtuellen hat.
Also acht eigentlich.
Genau.
Hypersthreading.
Und dann den CPU-Meter zeigt dann acht oder dritt an.
Ja, hier oben, wenn man da oben guckt, habe ich tatsächlich irgendwie acht Teile, von denen aber meistens immer nur vier irgendwie rumzucken. Also das ist mir noch nicht so ganz klar.
Machst du mal bitte den CPU-Monitor an, hier diesen Activity-Monitor.
Na, hier habe ich einen Activity-Monitor, da kannst du es sehen und so. Genau, man braucht den großen Bildschirm allein schon um die CPU-Auslassung zu nehmen. Das stimmt, das ist jetzt der eigentliche Grund. Ich muss auch sagen, also dieses 27-Zoll-Format oder diese Auflösung von 2500, was ist das, 60 mal 1400 oder so, das ist jetzt auch wirklich ein Schritt.
Das ist die Auflösung von dem Super Cinema, von dem 30-Zoller, ne?
Fast, der hat ein bisschen mehr Y.
Stimmt, jetzt ist wieder 16 zu 9, der hat noch 16 zu 10, ne?
Genau. Und das ist, aber ich glaube nicht, dass es einen großen Unterschied macht. Erstmal finde ich, wirkt er einfach kleiner, als man es so erstmal erwarten würde.
Na ich hätte jetzt, sonst wäre es mir ja gleich entgegengefallen, als ich hier reingekommen bin.
Also es ist irgendwie alles noch so im Rahmen. Ich dachte ja auch so, oh Gott, jetzt kommt der iMac da wie so eine Wandtapete daher. Er ist schon groß und er hat eine Menge Platz, aber es ist irgendwie noch zu tolerieren. Und es ist einfach so super, mit so einem großen Bildschirm zu arbeiten, weil man einfach so bestimmte Dinge machen kann, die auf so einem Laptop vollkommen unmöglich sind. Ein gutes Beispiel ist so was wie Handbücher lesen. Also wenn man jetzt hier irgendwie so ein typisches PDF. Also nicht in dieser Form. Du hast halt einfach die gesamte Seite oder eben auch mal beide Seiten. Kannst du also hier wirklich sagen, two pages nebeneinander. Und das ist so groß, dass du halt auch noch mit ein, zwei Metern Abstand das lesen kannst.
Und siehst du jetzt schon, du hast irgendwie links voll viel Platz noch frei, obwohl schon zwei Seiten nebeneinander, hast du rechts noch voll viel Platz frei. Wenn du deinen Dock jetzt irgendwie rechts an den Rand machen würdest, hättest du dann unten noch mehr Platz da, wo du nämlich nicht genug hast und links und rechts hast ja genug. Aber du bist nicht so ein Fan von Dock an der Seite, oder?
Doch, ich hab meinen Dock eigentlich immer an der Seite. Ich hab das aber jetzt hier.
Gerade bei 16 zu 9 macht das total Sinn.
Das mag sein, aber ich hab hier ohnehin so viel Gewinn, dass ich jetzt einfach auch mal mit Dock unten leben wollte, zumal ich auch mal wirklich dieses Ding testen wollte, mit allen Programmen, die ich hier unter Umständen starte, sofort auch im Blick haben. Ja, das geht jetzt theoretisch auch an der Seite, aber wenn es links ist, dann blendet man es auch automatisch aus. Wie auch immer, ist ja auch egal. Die Tatsache ist, du hast einfach so viel Platz und du kannst einfach Handbücher ordentlich lesen, du kannst einfach alles sehen. Also das ist dann schon so ein bisschen wie Papier. Also das ist eigentlich der eigentliche E-Book-Rieder, das Teil. Nichts zu kleinen Fitzel-Teile, auf denen du auch noch mal rumscrollen musst und so weiter. So stelle ich mir Buch in der U-Bahn. Ich lese solche Handbücher nicht in der U-Bahn. Die Handbücher habe ich offen aufgeschlagen, während ich mit den Geräten arbeite. So, das könnte bisher halt nur Papier leisten. Und jetzt habe ich halt das Teil hier auf dem Bildschirm. Ist ja auch nur ein Beispiel. So, und dann überhaupt auch die Möglichkeit einfach großflächig da vertikale Sachen nebeneinander zu haben. Kannst da irgendwie ein Videofenster laufen lassen, da ist immer noch massig Platz. Also ich kann das auf jeden Fall nur empfehlen. Das Ding ist schon eine geile Nummer. Und vor allem, ich habe einfach überhaupt nichts auszusetzen an diesem Gerät.
Noch nicht, hast du es ja noch nicht lange.
Das kann sein, aber...
Tim, bist du krank?
Ich wüsste nicht, was.
Wer bist du und wo ist Tim?
Also, ich wüsste nicht, das ist für mich der perfekte Desktop-Computer. Das Ding ist einfach mal schnell, groß, günstig.
Kostet wie viel?
In der Konfiguration gibt es den immer noch unter 2000. Und der kommt mit 4GB RAM, der hat irgendwie den Krisse, das ist jetzt mit einer Terra-Platte, dann gibt es noch irgendwie die Möglichkeit auf zwei aufzurüsten.
Bei Apple will man nicht aufrüsten.
Ja.
Es sei denn, man weiß nicht wohin mit dem Geld.
Ich glaube so bei den heutigen Platten, also mir ist das schon, ich habe gar nichts dagegen, mir von meinem Hersteller die Platte aussuchen zu lassen, wenn man sich mal so anschaut, wie viel Unterschiede dem Detail dann doch immer wieder aufweisen, mit welchen Protokollen die dann, welche Kommandos die dann wirklich unterstützen und wie sie sich so einzeln unterscheiden. Wir hatten auch hier diesen ganzen Ärger mit irgendwie andere Platten drinnen und auf einmal geht erstmal nichts. Stimmt es, Max? Was hast du da als das Problem?
Ja, das ist ja nach wie vor nicht so hundertprozentig weg.
Er muss es schon richtig machen.
Ja, das kommt jetzt irgendwie wieder. Das war lange Zeit kein Thema. Früher war das auch so. Erinnerst du dich noch bei den allerersten Macs? Die SCSI Platten, das waren so richtig von Apple abgenommen Firmwares. Das heißt, die kamen mit einer anderen Firmware teilweise bzw. die das Betriebssystem hat dann richtig die sich die Firmware angeschüttet. Genau, da muss man nämlich, genau, da muss man noch so richtig andere Festplattentreiber installieren, um ordentlich, ja ja, früher, früher, als alles besser war. Und das ist halt so ein Thema. Naja, aber zum Thema Performance testen. Es kam ja vor einiger Zeit schon eine neue Version von Handbrake raus, von diesem großartigen Video-Encoder. Und ich fand das ganz geil, was sie da gemacht haben. Erstmal noch hier in Bezug auf den i7 iMac. Das ist das einzige Tool, was diese 8 Chores hier richtig ausnutzt. Also der berät dann alle 8 richtig bis zum Anschlag. Hier ist einfach das Ding glüht nur noch. Und sowas habe ich echt noch nicht gesehen. Du nimmst da irgendwie so ein Fullscreen-HD-Video und rechnest das einfach von irgendwie beklopptem AVI in ein ordentliches MPEG-4 um. Dann marschiert er da mit seinen 8 Chores da durch und macht irgendwie sowas wie 200 Frames pro Sekunde im Encoding. Also der encoded das irgendwie achtmal so schnell, wie er es abspielt danach.
So eine Space-Opera von 69.
Den mache ich dir mit links lang. Würde ich mir sogar noch trauen hier. Das Teil, das hat einfach so viel Wum. Das ist einfach das Schöne. Endlich mal wieder Wum.
Ist voll Blu-ray.
Bevor das Teil hier war, hab ich hier irgendwie eine Woche lang irgendwelche Videos encoded auf diesem Laptop.
Können wir ja nachher mal probieren.
Das war wirklich hardcore. Aber zum Thema Handbrake, wollte ich auch noch...
Ich hab das auch schon mal benutzt. Erstens gibt es jetzt eine 64-Bit-Version.
Genau, wobei es sehr schade ist, dass es so ein entweder-oder ist und sie nicht einfach da so ein 32-64-Bit... Oder, warte mal, wie verwechsel ich das gerade mit einer anderen Applikation?
Weiß ich jetzt gar nicht echt. Muss man da umschalten?
Es gibt eine 32-64-Bit-Geschichte und wenn du halt von DVDs lesen willst, dann musst du halt auch die entsprechende VLC-Version in 4-64-Bit... Genau, die mit VLC angeblich mitkommt und man soll sich doch die 64-Bit-Version runterladen und die gibt es aber gar nicht. Aber es ist halt so normal nicht zu holen, das ist irgendwie noch ein bisschen konfus. Also an der Stelle gibt es da noch echte Upgradeschmerzen. Ich hoffe, dass sie das bald in den Griff kriegen. Aber wenn du das Teil halt nur ganz normal als Film-Re-Encoder nimmst, also da kann ja jetzt seit der vorletzten Version auch normale Movies, Movie-Dateien nehmen. Genau, das ist jetzt eigentlich der beste Encoder, den es gibt. Und wir haben ja auch die ganzen Presets ordentlich aufgeräumt.
Und wir haben auch noch diesen Zwei-Pass-Modus, das haben sie entfernt. Sie machen jetzt nur noch irgendwie, dass du die Qualität direkt einstellen kannst. Wer macht nicht mehr hier so diese Annäherungsversuche und so?
Genau, Constant-Quality-Encoding. Das ist so geil und da muss man echt noch mal drauf hinweisen. Das haben, glaube ich, viele Leute noch nicht so gerafft. Also es gibt ja die verschiedensten Methoden, wie man das so macht. Bei Apple ist es immer so, du kannst gar nichts einstellen, du sagst halt einfach mach mal Apple TV und dann...
Fällt halt irgendeine Größe hinten bei raus?
Ja, naja, der haut da irgendwie mit 3.000, 3 Megabit irgendwie. Also die nutzen halt einfach alles, was da ist, weil Scheiß auf dem Platz Hauptsache die Qualität stimmt. Apple geht es nur darum, dass die Qualität am Ende so ist, dass die Leute nicht sagen, das sieht scheiße aus. Das ist ihre Philosophie.
Und richtig gut sind sie dabei aber auch nicht.
Genau, und dann gibt es die anderen, die sagen, ich will Platz sparen. Das ist so hier diese Avi-Mentalität, die man ja immer so im Internet findet. Hauptsache das Ding kann sich danach auf eine CD-ROM brennen lassen. Egal wie groß der Film ist, muss 650 MB groß sein am Schluss.
Jetzt muss man der Zuhörer dann noch erklären, was eine CD-ROM war. Das war früher, da gab es so Silberscheiben.
Genau, und das ist das andere. Und seit einiger Zeit, also es gibt es glaube ich seit drei, vier Versionen, ist das im Handbrake drin? Und das ist deshalb da drin, weil das in FFmpeg vor, ich glaube wir haben das auf dem Kongress das erste Mal, als das ganz frisch war, glaube ich so vor drei, vier Jahren eingesetzt. Das ist Constant Quality Encoding. Und Constant Quality Encoding macht einfach sozusagen, stellt sicher, dass so und so viel Prozentqualität, wie du einstellst, in jedem Frame erhalten bleibt. Das heißt, wenn viel Movement ist, geht die Bitrate dynamisch hoch, passiert kaum etwas, kannst du die Bitrate enorm runterlegen. Aber du kannst halt mit Constant Quality sagen, wie gut du es haben willst. Das heißt, du entscheidest einmal, wie viel Prozent das ist, mit dem du leben kannst. Das kann eben viel oder wenig sein. Und abhängig von Material werden die Dateien enorm klein. Wir haben das bei den Kongressvideos zum Beispiel gemacht. Und die Ergebnisse waren einfach absurd. Also du hattest wirklich 640 x 480 Video und kamst teilweise halt mit 150 Kilobit hin.
Klar, wenn sich der Typ am Rednerpult nicht bewegt da vorne.
Genau. Aber es war immer sehr schwierig zu greifen, weil wenn du nämlich wirklich mal zwischendurch einen Film hast und du hast halt nur auf Bitrate geschielt, dann kannst du eben in dem Moment nicht das machen. Und auch diese ganzen anderen VBR-Ansätze, die es immer schon gab, die sagen, na ja, im Prinzip diese Bitrate, plus minus 10 Prozent oder so, konnte das dann eben auch nicht abfangen. Und bei Handbrakes setzen sie halt jetzt voll darauf.
Aber eigentlich ist doch dieses Constant Quality das Erste, was es überhaupt gab für Encoding. Also das Ganze auf eine bestimmte Größe anpassen, das sind doch alles Features, die erst später kamen und die jetzt sozusagen wieder rauswerfen, weil es ja eigentlich Blödsinn ist.
Das war ja schon so, dass sie dann später diese Features eingebaut haben, dass du halt genau auf eine CD-ROM das runteroptimieren konntest mit zwei Passes und ewig raufweichen.
Ja, aber Breakups, Constant Quality kam erst später.
Ja klar, die kamen gleich mit den Features raus, aber ganz so als erstes früher ist so, dass du halt die Qualität einstellen kannst. Das ist doch diese Quarter, dieses Thousand Quality Slider, der sagt doch, das ist doch nicht ein Prozent, sondern der wird auch immer...
Geht es dir jetzt von Handbrake oder von Video-Encoding im Allgemeinen?
Beides.
Also ich beobachte das noch nicht so lange, dieses Constant Quality-Encoding, das gibt es noch nicht so lange. Also mir ist schon so, es gab Constant Rate.
Ne?
Die Bitrate konntest du immer schon einstellen.
Das ist genau nicht das einfachste. Du weißt ja vorher nicht, was da rausfällt, weil du das Bild nicht kennst.
Seit ich mit Video-Encoding arbeite, konnte ich schon immer die Bitrate einstellen, aber nichts anderes. Also okay, das lassen wir jetzt mal offen. Das ist vielleicht die Wahrnehmungsgeschichte, aber ich nehme CQR da als etwas wahr, was eigentlich erst seit ein paar Jahren so ist. Und jetzt hat Handbrake darauf umgestellt. Was ich aber auch noch geil fand, ist, was sie alles weggelassen haben in diesem Handbrake-Update. Ist euch das irgendwie überhaupt klar?
Also ich hab gesehen, dass wir irgendwie...
Also erstmal haben sie alle, sie haben AVI weggeschmissen.
Ja, wurde auch Zeit.
Wurde auch Zeit, finde ich nämlich auch. Es war einfach so dieses, wir brauchen es nicht mehr. Das heißt, es gibt jetzt nur noch MP4 und MKV als die Container-Formate, die halt alles können. Dann haben sie X-Wid weggeschmissen, was vielleicht auch so ein bisschen überraschend kommen mag, weil das ja immer noch weite Verbreitung hat.
Weil X-Wid eigentlich der coolste MP4-Encoder ist und Decoder für das alte MP4 ohne Extensions. Und weil das aber sowieso keiner mehr benutzt, weil es X264 gibt, haben sie gedacht, das lassen sie mal weg. Weil zur Not zum Decoden haben sie immer noch den, der in FF-MP4 drin ist, der ist vielleicht nicht ganz so cool wie X-Lit, aber reicht locker und sie brauchen dann nicht zwei... Libraries pflegen, weil es voll immer anstrengend und so. Das heißt, vielleicht ist die Entwicklung von Handbrake dadurch jetzt auch ein bisschen schneller, leichter und kommen schneller Updates und irgendwie so weiter. Also ich finde Handbrake auf jeden Fall auch ein super Tool. Und ich will nachher sehen, wie alle acht Zylinder auf deinem Ding da feuern, aber ordentlich.
Achso, ja, Ock und OGM ist auch weggefallen dann bei den Containern? Angstläufig? Naja, auch war halt drin.
Ist ja ein Mac-Tool.
Ich weiß nicht, ist das mit anderen Plattformen auch weggefallen? Echt alle?
Sobald ich weiß, gilt das generell für alle Plattformen.
Wie ist das denn mit der Handbrake überhaupt? Wird das noch vernünftig weiterentwickelt für was anderes als ein Mac?
Das ist auf allen Plattformen zu haben. Also wenn hier auf die Downloads klickst, dann gibt es das irgendwie auch für Windows und für Linux. Und ich sehe hier keine großen Unterscheidungen mit den Versionen. Alles 0.9.4 und gibt es als GUI und als Command Line.
Ist ja glatt um einen Versuch wert.
Und sie empfehlen hier auch für die neue i5 i7-Generation die 64-Bit-Version zum Einsatz zu bringen, weil das da eine Menge bringt. Und für die 32-Bit komischerweise nur die Duo- und Solo-Prozessoren. Das ist mir nicht so ganz klar, weil da müsste es ja eigentlich auch schneller sein. Also auch die Core Duo, also die Core 2 Duo zumindest.
Aber die Core 2 Duo sagen sie doch auch.
Entschuldigung, ne, ne, ne. Alles klar, ich hab mich verlesen. Ich rede Quatsch. Also Core Duo, Core Solo kann nur 32-Bit, von daher ist Quatsch. Aber sie sollten da halt einfach ein gemeinsames Beinriede draus machen. So ist es irgendwie alles.
Brauchen sie nur zusammenkleben eigentlich.
Genau, na gut, das können wir jetzt mal überspringen hier. Okay, wir wollten ja so ein bisschen mal anfangen hier mit unseren eigenen Erfahrungen, damit wir mal auch einen praktischen Mehrwert bringen, bevor wir uns hier in dieser News-Schleife festdenken.
Das machen wir doch die ganze Zeit schon.
Ja, machen wir schon die ganze Zeit. Jetzt geht's weiter. Und du hast gesagt, du hast mit IPv6 rumgespielt.
Ja, ich dachte mir jetzt ja, nachdem im Club, da probieren ja, also hier im CCC spielen ja eh schon alle Ewigkeiten mit IPv6 rum. Und hier auch der Dennis und so. Und dann dachte ich mir, jetzt ist doch auch echt langsamer Zeit, nachdem ich erfahren habe, dass es jetzt schon 10 Jahre sozusagen existiert. Wollte jetzt auch mal IPv6 haben. Und hab mich dann mal ein paar Tage hingesetzt und versucht rauszufinden, was jetzt der schnellste Weg ist, um mal schnell irgendwo IPv6 zu deployen. Und hab mich dann hier für 6to4 entschieden. Und es ging auch relativ gut. Also ich hab das in der Uni halt aufgesetzt und das ging auch relativ fix. Na ja, das ist halt so, du sagst halt deinem, also ich so sag dem FreeBSD, pass mal auf, mach mal v6 an und benutze mal als Default Router oder Knoten sozusagen, um v6 zu bekommen. So eine Anycast-Adresse. Und diese Anycast-Adresse endet am nächsten 6to4 Relay. Und in meinem Fall ist es das DFN sogar direkt. Das heißt, das DFN war halt ziemlich früh dabei mit v6 und die haben halt so ein Relay und wir kriegen Internet vom DFN. Von daher schalte ich auf dem FreeBSD einfach nur v6 an und sag hier auf diese Anycast-Adresse bitte. Und schwuppdiwupp habe ich dann so einen 2002-Prefix und dahinter dann meine v4-Adresse in Hex. Ja, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall hast du dann relativ schnell v6. So und als nächstes habe ich dann gemacht, alle die jetzt hinter mir sind, also hinter diesem Router, die kriegen halt Autoconv6. Das heißt, alle Macs, die da ihren, also alle Studenten, die ihren Mac aufklappen, haben dann auch spontan v6 hinter diesem 604-Prefix. Also das ging echt erstaunlich schmerzfrei. Also hier zum Beispiel die Apple Extreme Base Stations oder so, die machen ja das eben genauso. Die machen auch so ein 6to4-Tunnel auf so einer Anycast-Adresse, da ist eben auch nicht klar, wo du dann rauskommst, sondern du landest im Idealfall tatsächlich am nächsten Knoten und schwuppdiwupp hast du eben v6. So, hab ich halt ein bisschen rumgespielt und dachte mir, wow, cool. Jetzt kann ich sozusagen die Rechner auch via v6 erreichen. Dann hab ich irgendwie meine Schwester...
Du hast auch die Firewall gesagt, die soll v6 wegfiltern oder ist deine Uni jetzt komplett offen?
Meine Uni ist schon immer komplett offen.
Auch jeder Rechner so?
Es gibt v4-Adressen, echte aus dem DRCP.
Das heißt, so die Windows-Leute bei dir sind mal...
Es gibt da keine Windows-Leute, es ist eine Kunst-Uni. Nein, es gibt ein paar Windows-Leute und früher... Also Windows XP-Kisten hab ich da schon sterben sehen. Aber in letzter Zeit ist es ein bisschen ruhig geworden. Meistens rufen tatsächlich Leute vom DFN an und sagen, ja, pass mal auf, da ist ein Computer, der gerade hier Spam in die Welt verschickt. Und wenn du dann halt nachguckst, welcher das ist, ist es halt eine Windows-Kiste, die irgendein Trojaner drauf hat. Aber ansonsten ist da einigermaßen ruhig. Naja, auf jeden Fall habe ich dann noch als nächsten Schritt um die V6-Experimente weiterzuführen, meiner Schwester auch eine Apple Extreme Base Station zu Hause hingestellt, damit ich, wenn sie irgendwelche Probleme mit ihrem Mac Mini hat, mit Remote Desktop ohne Nutt usw. direkt auf die Kiste rauf kann. Und musste dann halt so langsam, je mehr ich das sozusagen dann auch benutzt habe, feststellen, dass dann halt so diverse Programme noch gar nicht so richtig... Das mögen... .V6-ready sind. Zum Beispiel eben Remote Desktop oder Screen Sharing. Irgendwie dachte ich so, okay, muss ja gehen, das ist ja hier Apple, alles V6 und sowieso, los geht's. Dann dachte ich erstmal Screen Sharing als erstes und dann konnte man schon mal gar nicht die Adresse reinpasten. Also ich hab die V6-Adresse reingepastet, auf Connect geklickt und dann kam dann irgendwie so so ein Salat in irgendeinem Dialogfenster und meinte so, was soll das? Okay, da hab ich erstmal ein bisschen im Apple Support Forum geblättert und dann stellte sich heraus, es geht doch, aber man muss die V6-Adresse in eckigen Klammern schreiben. Das gemacht, das ging dann tatsächlich auch irgendwie. Dann, das nächste war, okay, dachte ich mir Remote Desktop.
Das ist, glaube ich, weil die Methode, um so eine IPv6-Adresse in der OL anzugeben, ist in eckigen Klammern. Weil da kommt es sonst mit dem Doppelpunkt durcheinander, weil der Doppelpunkt ja eigentlich der Port ist. Deswegen macht man das in eckigen Klammern, dass irgendwie die Convention für OLs, da die aus dem Ding wahrscheinlich eine OL machen.
So, dann das nächste war halt, dachte ich mir, ok Remote Desktop, so Remote Desktop irgendwie auf Plus gedrückt, irgendwie V6-Adresse eingetippt, dann dachte ich auch eben mit eckigen Klammern, aber da geht es nicht mit eckigen Klammern, da musste die Adresse reintippen. Und ja, dann so hier und da an verschiedenen Stellen, einfach immer so kleine Stolperstellen, wo es noch nicht so ganz funktioniert hat. Und dann der ultimative Test, dachte ich mir, ok, ich habe jetzt hier V6, ich kann Trace routen.
Du weißt, was der Standard-Test ist, um IPv6 zu testen. Genau, die schwimmende Schildkröte als Animation.
Genau, das war auch so ein komisches Ding, weil ich habe mit Safari CameNet aufgemacht und da hat sich die Schildkröte nicht bewegt. Dann habe ich das von verschiedenen Rechnern probiert, ging nicht. Und wenn ich es mit Firefox gemacht habe, ging es aber. Ja, ein paar Tage später ging das auch mit Safari, aus welchen Gründen auch immer.
Vielleicht warst du irgendwann mal letztens drauf und dann hat er sich per DNS das gemerkt, was kame.net irgendwie aufgelöst ist.
Aber dann hat es ja Firefox auch nicht. Egal. Und dann war noch der ultimative Test, dachte ich mir, ok, jetzt mache ich V4 aus und benutze nur V6 und guck mal.
Das geht gar nicht. Das kannst du voll vergessen.
No chance in hell, ja. Da war ich schon ein bisschen desillusioniert, aber ich weiß ja nicht, hat das jemand mal, also geht das auf anderen OS, wenn ein FreeBSD nur V6 benutzt?
Das können ja alle nicht. Versuch mal Spiegel, können die Spiegel schon direkt, also die Google-Seite kommt mit V6.
Du kriegst nicht genug Infrastruktur zusammen, nur mit V6.
Na die wollen alle nicht umstehen, weil sind alle zu voll.
Aber angenommen, also angenommen, also ich hab ja versucht einfach eine V6-Adresse zu pingen und das ging schon nicht.
Na wenn die keinen V6 haben, haben sie keins, also meine.
Ja, aber ich hab ja natürlich einen V6-Host gepinkt.
Was kannst du anpingen, wenn du die Adressen kennst?
Also ich hab halt explizit V4 ausgemacht und nur V6-Adresse und dann ging es nicht. Wenn ich V4 wieder mit angemacht hab, dann konnte ich auch V6 pingen.
Hattest du vielleicht einen V4-DNS?
Ich hab die Adresse explizit gepinkt, nicht die Domain.
Wer macht denn aber trotzdem eine Resolution? Dann hängt der Prozess, du musst mit Minus N pingen.
Achso, er probiert ansonsten die...
Er muss ja wieder den Namen auflösen. Selbst wenn du nur eine Adresse nimmst, dann will er ja gucken, wie das Ding heißt. Dann fragt er das DNS. Deswegen hängt er, er sagt ja nicht, dass es nicht geht, sondern er hängt, weil er auf die Antwort vom DNS wartet. Und deswegen, Minus n ist your friend, geht alles viel schneller.
Und dann halt hier, das nächste, was dann auch nicht ging, war hier Apple Car im Finder drücken irgendwie. Da hat er sich irgendwie komisch benommen und halt lauter so kleine, kleine Fnauts. Du kannst auch keinen V6-Name-Server eintragen und so. Also in diesen Feldern im Network-Utility kannst du auch nicht so richtig...
Gibt es eigentlich von Google auch den 8888-DNS? Gibt es den auch als IPv6 eigentlich?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Google hier hört ja bestimmt auch zu, weil er muss ja sein.
Hat das mal jemand googelt?
Sollen wir mal antworten hier.
Ja, hat man auf jeden Fall nichts von gehört.
Die ganzen chinesischen Mitarbeiter, die haben ja gerade nichts zu tun, die hören wahrscheinlich jetzt alle mobileMacs. Was macht man im Urlaub mobileMacs?
Aber wenn wir schon mal hin sind, hier bei neuen IP-Technologien, ich will mal kurz auch noch zwei Minuten was erzählen, weil mir ist da gerade noch was eingefallen.
Sind wir noch bei IPv6? Warte mal kurz.
Passt nämlich genau rein.
Na dann lass uns nochmal kurz. Ich hab ja aber hier, weil ich stelle jetzt auch gerade fest, hier Carminet, das geht hier auch nicht.
Ja, weil IPv6 habe ich geguckt, geht nicht, ich habe keine Adresse.
Ich habe eine IP.
Du hast eine?
Ich habe auch eine Adresse. Adresse habe ich, das ist nicht so das Ding.
Ich bin ja in dem Public-Dings, ja? Meter Ebenen Public.
Ich habe auch keine V6.
Ich habe hier keine V6-Adresse. Ich habe hier nur den FE80, diesen Local Host.
Doch, hier auf Ethernet habe ich V6.
Achso, da habe ich ja nicht drin.
Achso, über WLAN gibt es keinen V6?
Sollte es aber eigentlich. Also das Mode, also die Base...
Das heißt, die Time Capsule macht V6 nur auf Ethernet?
Also eigentlich ist es so...
Nee, ich bin nicht bewusst, dass man das einschalten kann.
Eigentlich müssen die Basestations direkt am DSL-Modem hängen. Also die müssen das PPPoE machen. Dann machen sie nur das 624. Wenn die nur so im LAN hängen machen, die keinen 624.
Das ist ja hier der Fall. Also das Ding macht das.
Genau, und dann kannst du in den Airport-Settings auch einstellen, dass du 624 machen willst. Und dann kannst du auch noch den Mode einstellen, wie du 624 machen willst.
Also der Chat meint, bin IPv6 dann auch eigentlich auf allen Netzen. Und ich sehe auch da wenig Grund, warum das nicht so sein sollte. So richtig viel Information spucken diese Teile ja nicht aus. Aber ich habe IPv6 in diesem Tunnel-Modus. Und ich habe aber hier Block incoming IPv6-Connections. Das ist ein Fehler.
Ja, das ist halt, dem bin ich auch erst aufgesessen, weil ich wollte dann halt Remote Desktop zu meiner Schwester machen. Dann gab es aber keine Connection, nachdem ich den richtigen Syntax sozusagen rausgefunden hatte. Und dann festgestellt, dass die Airpods Stations das von sich aus erstmal direkt blocken incoming. Das habe ich dann erstmal ausgeschaltet und dann nach ein bisschen rumpfummen ging es dann aus.
Muss man denn dieses Teredo einschalten? Kennst du dich damit aus, Dennis? Ja, wir sind ein bisschen...
Endlich mal etwas zu spielen.
Wir wissen nicht weiter an dieser Stelle, oder? Ich glaube, ich muss das mal einschalten, aber mit Teredo kann man halt... Ich kriege das jedes Mal durch, deswegen fange ich jetzt gar nicht mehr...
Teredo hab ich noch gar nicht gehört, aber egal. Aber prinzipiell, also bei mir ging dann also das, was ich wollte, nämlich Remote Desktop ohne Nutt, also direkt hinter das DSL und hinter den Router und sonst was von meiner Schwester auf dem Rechner, das ging dann, nachdem ich noch dieses Blog Incoming V6 Connections ausgeschaltet habe, bei der Xtreme Base Station. Und ja, zumindest das, was ich mir davon erhofft hatte, was es mir bringt, am Nutt vorbei endlich, das ging dann tatsächlich auch. Aber ist trotzdem scheinbar immer noch viel zu tun, also.
Auf jeden Fall.
Ja Dennis, was hast du denn da noch?
Was in letzter Zeit mir noch, was ich so aufgeschnappt habe, selber hab ich es noch gar nicht benutzt, aber es ist auf jeden Fall interessant zu erzählen. Es gibt ja die beiden Protokolle UDP und TCP. Nochmal schnell Überblick, irgendwie UDP ist Connectionless, das heißt da werden Pakete geschickt. Ob die angekommen sind oder nicht, wird man nie erfahren. Und bei TCP ist es so, du schickst Pakete und wenn die nicht angekommen sind, dann wird versucht, die nochmal zu schicken. Wenn es nicht geklappt hat, dann bricht die TCP Connection auch ab. Das sind die beiden Methoden, die es gibt. Jetzt gibt es noch seit einer Weile was Neues und zwar heißt es SCTP. Abkürzung weiß ich jetzt gerade gar nicht. Stream Control Transport Protokoll oder sowas. Keine Ahnung. Jedenfalls ist eins der coolen Features daran ist, dass wenn du zwischen zwei Rechnern so eine SCTP Connection hast und sich auf einer Seite die Adresse wechselt, dann kann er mit der neuen Adresse sich zur anderen Seite wieder connecten und kann sagen, du, hallo, ich bin hier der von vorhin. Also da wird so eine Association irgendwie gehalten. Ich bin, hab jetzt aber eine neue Adresse und ich hätte jetzt gerne, wird die Connection jetzt hier weiterfahren.
Verstehe.
Da gibt es noch andere coole Features, aber ich würde mal sagen, das ist so das Hauptfeature, was ich irgendwie gerne hätte, weil wenn zum Beispiel auch wenn es mit IPv6 dieses Nattproblem irgendwann mal verschwindet wird, aber wir werden es wohl noch eine Weile haben, dass wenn du zu Hause einen 24-Stunden- Disconnect hast, ist halt deine Connection weg und du fliegst aus dem Chat raus, dein Download bricht ab und was weiß ich nicht alles und alles, was dann in der Zukunft SCTP spricht, kann dann einfach mit der neuen Adresse weitermachen. Oder auch wenn du Roaming machst mit WLAN, du rennst mit deinem iPhone irgendwie die Straße lang und hüpfst von einem WLAN zum nächsten. Gerade diese Mesh-Netze, die es da so gibt, ich weiß ja nicht, ob man da seine Adresse behält, habe ich jetzt gar keine Ahnung gerade, aber ist egal, jedenfalls, wenn sich die Adresse wechselt, ist alles kein Problem mehr, SETP macht einfach weiter.
Ja, aber das ist nicht wirklich die Pleute, und es ist auch nicht klar, ob das wirklich noch mal eine große Chance hat, oder?
Doch, das ist richtig offiziell RFC-Standard, also das ist richtig, die das nächste Weite passen zu TCP. Die entwickelt das auch schon seit ein paar Jahren. Und es geht jetzt langsam los, dass es wirklich benutzbar wird, und da gibt es schon einen Patch für SSH, dass du es mit SSH so machen kannst. Hat auch schon funktioniert, sie haben es nur nicht geschafft, dass sich die Adresse wechselt und das dann weiter läuft. Aber sie haben schon hier eine SSH-Connection per SCP benutzt.
Also im Prinzip geht es so ein bisschen um Next Generation TCP, ohne die Nachteile von TCP.
Und mit den Vorteilen von UDP noch dazu. Weil du kannst über SCP nämlich aussuchen, ob deine Pakete einfach nur durchgeschickt werden, oder ob sie definitiv ankommen müssen. Oder du kannst auch sagen, ich habe hier ein Paket, das sollte ankommen, probiere das mal 10 Sekunden lang. Wenn es aber nicht geklappt hat, dann ist es auch egal. Also du kannst sozusagen so aussuchen, was du haben musst. Und kannst auch wechseln während der Verbindung. Die Checksumme ist doppelt so groß. Dann haben sie wohl noch was gegen Synthetacks gemacht, die man bei TCP irgendwie fahren kann. Das ist ein bisschen technischer. Also das ist alles ein bisschen ein modernes TCP und UDP vereint in einem. Es sollte eigentlich nur wirklich für Streams sein, glaube ich. Und dann kamen irgendwelche Leute und sagten, naja, eigentlich ist es ja insgesamt auch ganz cool. Lass das mal gleich irgendwie richtig machen. Und das könnte was ganz Schickes werden. Und das geht gerade los. Und auf FreeBSD ist die Referenzimplementation. Das heißt, weil wir alle hier FreeBSD benutzen, dann sehen wir mal gleich, was da so abgeht gerade. Hab mich eh schon gewundert, warum einer mal so viel FCTP Zeug irgendwie committed in deren Code. Und jetzt wissen wir, warum.
Stimmt ja, AIX, Cisco, IOS, FreeBSD, Solaris.
Und selbst für MacOS gibt es eine Kernel-Extension und dann hast du auch STTP.
Guck an. Na ja, gut, aber ob das... Ich meine... Das bedeutet aber, dass du wirklich über die volle Strecke...
Die Strecke dazwischen ist egal.
Also du kannst ja auch deine Sachen in IPSEC einpacken. Das ist ja auch ein anderes Protokoll für TCP. Nein, das geht ja auch durch. Deine Gegenseite musst du es halt können.
Ich bin mir bloß nicht so sicher. Es mag eine Menge Firewalls geben, die einfach sagen...
Klar, aber es mag eine Menge Firewalls geben, die sagen TCP, blocken wir mal alles. Und schon kommst du mit STTP durch.
Ja, gut, aber ich glaube die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sie sagen, hier gibt es nur ICMP, UDP und TCP und alles andere ist evil.
Das kann schon sein, aber die Services natürlich, die mit diesem STTP anfangen, also die Gegenstelle muss es ja auch können. Das heißt, da werden die auch dementsprechend die Firewalls aufnehmen. Aber interessant ist es halt für einen selbst, wenn man mit SSH irgendwo hinconnecten will in seine eigene Infrastruktur, dann könnte man halt auch sowas umschalten. Und zwischendurch darf er eigentlich nichts filtern, also auf der Strecke.
Ja, ist recht. Wir werden das begleiten.
Wir werden es verfolgen, auf jeden Fall.
Vor allen Dingen, wenn dann eben auch mit IPv6 dann alle Windows-Kisten wieder nicht mehr hinter dem Natt sind und sich frei entfalten können.
Die werden sich ja ihre Firewall schön wieder einschalten, denn die werden ja nicht ohne fahren.
Ja, dann gab es hier noch so die Frage von Hörern, wie denn das so ist, ein Backup bei der Time Capsule zu machen. Tja, das ist so eine Sache, also das geht ja. Man kann da ja über USB einfach eine externe Platte anschließen. Laut Apple genau eine. Also schon mehrere Partitionen und so sind eigentlich nicht unterstützt, aber funktioniert doch schon auch irgendwie. Aber es ist wirklich ein bisschen beknackt, was du da machen kannst, du kannst da wirklich in diesem Admin-Interface kannst du sagen, ja, hier mach mal ein Backup. Und dann kopiert er halt alles von der internen Platte auf die externen Platte. Das ist soweit schon mal ganz gut. Also du kannst zumindest mal, zumindest einmal im Monat oder wenn du fleißig bist, einmal die Woche steckst du halt da eine Platte ran und sagst, kopier mal rüber. Allerdings kopiert er das dann in so ein nicht sichtbares Directory. Also es ist nicht so, dass du dann danach dieses Backup dann da siehst, sondern so lange diese Platte an der Time Capsule dran ist, kannst du da auf diese kopierten Dateien gar nicht so drauf schauen. Du siehst es natürlich, wenn du das an deinen Rechner ransteckst, also wenn das wirklich so eine removable Platte ist und fügt dann auch die Backups immer hinzu. Also meine, die Flexibilität, die Apple einem da bietet, die ist doch sehr eingeschränkt. Wie ist das, wofür ist das gedacht? Also ist das dafür gedacht, dass du halt von deiner intern fest eingebauten Platte einen Backup machen kannst?
Find ichs anders. In der Time Capsule eingebauten? Und wie restore ich dieses Backup im 2x12?
Das ist eine gute Frage, da hab ich noch gar nicht drüber nachgedacht. Du hast halt den kompletten Content, ich vermute mal, dass du sogar die Platten wieder so reinbauen könntest, wobei das ja nicht unbedingt der Weg ist.
Also was ich mir jetzt vorstellen könnte, dass das so wäre, wenn man dann die Platte in seinem Mac verliert, dass man dann die Platte direkt anschließen kann, auf die man das Backup draufgespielt hat, damit es nicht so lange dauert, wenn man das Backup einspielt.
Das ist eine gute Frage, das muss ich gleich mal hinterfragen. Aber man hat auf jeden Fall seine Daten, hat man irgendwie. Vielleicht man die dann wieder in einer ich mache so weiter wie ich aufgehört habe Version auf eine neue Time Capsule draufbringt, kann ich nicht sagen. Aber es ist mir alles ein bisschen zu featurearm. Aber immerhin, es geht und ich kann das auch nur raten, dass man das mal machen sollte. Andere Frage war nach diesem Mac Mini mit Snow Leopard Server. Huckel, du hast doch mit Snow Leopard Server schon gearbeitet, oder?
Ja, also als erste Anekdote kann ich noch berichten. Auf Arbeit irgendwie kam einer an und meinte, ja, ich habe jetzt hier so ein Mac Mini mit Snow Leopard Server und das für meinen Vater im Büro, aber ich hab den jetzt noch vier Wochen und es ist ja alles total toll und war nur am Schwärmen und wie schön und alles zum Klicken und ich meinte so zu ihm, ja, ist alles schön zum Klicken, aber wenn du mal irgendwas so spezieller machen willst und so, du wirst noch fluchen, dann wollte er mir aber überhaupt nicht glauben, meinte, nee, ach Quatsch, ist toll. Und gut, hab ich auch jetzt keine Energie weiter reingesteckt, zwei Wochen später lese ich im Twitter, scheiß Snowlapper oder Apple, GUI oder irgendwas, hat da dann rumgeranntet, und dann hab ich nur mal so ein Told you so hinterhergeschickt. Also ich hab jetzt schon echt seit 10.3 dieses MacOS Server sozusagen gesehen und kann auf jeden Fall sagen, dass es jetzt von Version zu Version immer große große Schritte in Richtung Benutzbarkeit macht und sieht auch immer schicker aus, aber es hat halt immer noch auch mit Snowlapper Server halt so dieses Problem, dass wenn man den Weg verlassen möchte, den Apple einem davor gibt und dann irgendwie doch mal eine eigene Variante, eine eigene Spielart von Web Server und so weiter da benutzen will, dass es dann einfach total schwierig und fricklich wird. Und die haben halt an allen Stellen immer so eine Sache, die man eigentlich immer haben will und die dann aber nicht funktioniert und die man auch nur mit irgendwie einen Konfix rumstricken und wirklich größten Energieaufwand dann hinkriegt. Und das beliebteste Beispiel ist da eigentlich in letzter Zeit dieser Kalender-Server, weil das ist eigentlich das, was alle haben wollen, so cool, so Groupware, Kalender zum Klicken, Apple macht das, alles toll und schick und so weiter. Ja, und dann geht es halt los mit 10.5 Server, da gab es so ganz komische Beschränkungen. Du konntest zwar irgendwie Gruppenkalender machen und du konntest deine eigenen Kalender machen, aber dann waren die nicht von außen für jeden subscribierbar. Du konntest bestimmte Kalender nicht publishen. Du musstest irgendwie ganz umständlich dafür sorgen, dass mehrere an einem Kalender editieren können. Du konntest keine geschaerten Kalender im iCal editieren, sondern nur im Web-Interface. Und lauter so eine Sache, wo man so sagt...
Also eigentlich genau der Grund, warum man es nicht, warum man es haben will, geht alles nicht.
Also das, was es geht, ist auch alles echt hübsch. Das Web-Interface von dem Kalender ist echt allererste Sahne, noch nie was besseres gesehen. iCal könnte ich auch super mit leben, aber einfach so diese zwei Welten, Desktop up und Web up und diese unsichtbaren Mauern zwischen veröffentlichten oder geteilten Kalendern, Gruppenkalendern und persönlichen Kalendern. Und da gibt es halt irgendwie verschiedene Spielarten von Kalendern, aber es ist irgendwie nie so richtig klar, welche Kalendermodus jetzt welche Features hat. Und wir haben das halt in der Firma sozusagen evaluiert als Ersatz für Oracle Groupware-Geschichten, um halt sowas zu machen. Also was da halt benutzt wird, ist halt der Klassiker so ein Meeting eintragen, gucken, wer ist verfügbar, irgendwie so gucken, wer hat wann Zeit und das dann so zusammenschieben und so weiter. Und das geht ja jetzt angeblich in 10-6 Server auch. Und ja, nach so vier Wochen rumgefricke, also am Anfang auch so, ja, ist ja ganz schön und viel schöner als bei Oracle und die GUIs und Toll und A. Und so nach vier Wochen, ja, aber dann müssten wir hier und dann, wenn dann Leute mit dem iPhone und dann die anderen aber wiederum nicht. Und wenn man die anderen aber auch, dann müsste man nochmal so ein extra Tool, was dann wieder die Kalender in ein anderes Format. Und ja, am Ende haben wir es dann sein lassen, das No-Lab-Experiment, also Server-Experiment. Und das ist halt auch meine Erfahrung seit Jahren. Also als Web-Server taugt das nicht, weil es scheitert schon so an ganz simplen Sachen, wie zum Beispiel, man will eine PHP-Seite hosten, was jetzt nun echt keine... Ja, du, das ist keine ungewöhnliche Anforderung, dass da jemand einen Wordpress oder sowas hosten will. Und dann geht es halt los, dass sie eine bestimmte PHP-Extension haben wollen. Und da ist halt kein wirklicher Weg vorgesehen, um jetzt eine zusätzliche PHP-Extension zu installieren. Und wenn man es dann halt doch tut, dann schreibt man in Configs, in die man eigentlich laut Apple nicht schreiben sollte. Und dann startet man das nächste Mal die GUI und dann schreibt die GUI die Configs sozusagen neu. Und dann ist eine Extension irgendwie wieder raus. Ja, also das Einzige, wofür ich Snowlapper Server tatsächlich einsetze, ist halt für dieses LDAP. Weil dafür ist die GUI extrem gut. Also wenn man halt so sowas hat, wie zum Beispiel eine Universität, irgendwie alles voller Macintosh-Computer-Stationäre und man will halt irgendwie zentral die User-Accounts verwalten und sagen, was die auf welchem Rechner, in welchem Raum können und wo sie Admin sind und wo nicht. Und so eine Geschichten, dafür ist das total toll. Wofür es auch noch toll ist, ist so File-Sharing-Shares. Also alles, was mit Benutzerrechten zu tun hat. Wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel für die ganze Uni oder für die ganze Firma bestimmte Shares freigeben will und sowas, da hat man eine ziemlich fein granulierte Kontrolle drüber. Und für sowas taugt das. Aber so Services hosten wie Web oder Datenbank oder Kalender oder sowas, nur sehr eingeschränkt. Also echt für so unbedarfte User. Wie gesagt, so Wiki, Kalender und was gibt es noch? Blogs. Das ist an sich echt total hübsch und schön gemacht, aber hat halt so total bekloppte Einschränkungen einfach.
Also ja, dieses Apple macht jedes Mal tolle Fortschritte von Version zu Version. Den Eindruck hatte ich auch immer. Aber es ist so ein bisschen so, als würden sie große Fortschritte machen bei dem Hinterherlaufen hinter einem Bus, der aber irgendwie mit höherer Geschwindigkeit losfährt. Und ich weiß immer nicht, ob sie wirklich in der Lage sind, nochmal zu einem System zu kommen, was eigentlich diesen Wunsch der flexiblen Konfiguration, aber auch der Benutzbarkeit davon, dass sie das irgendwie zusammenkriegen. Das, was du beschreibst, das habe ich von Anfang an immer gehabt. Ich meine, wäre schon glücklich. Also am Anfang war es halt auch so, dann ist man mal losgegangen und hat versucht, das irgendwie anzupassen. Und dann passte auf irgendwann auch alles nicht mehr zusammen. Also das, was du so gesehen hast, was es eigentlich tun sollte und das, was es tatsächlich tat, das war dann in so einem Disconnect, sodass dir über die Integrität dieses Systems auch irgendwie nicht mehr so im Klaren war.
Das fängt auch, also ein klassisches Beispiel, was jetzt wirklich bei allen Versionen bisher war und wo ich jedes Mal irgendwie bestimmt zwei Wochen gefrickelt habe, bis es dann wieder ging. Also ich hab einen X-Rate an einem X-Surf dran und ich wollte halt dem Eldab sagen, also dem Open Directory heißt das bei macOS dann oder wie, ne? Wollte ich halt sagen, pass mal auf, die Homes von den Usern pack mal aufs X-Rate. So, ganz einfach. Ich sag ihm, da dieser Ordner, der ist geshared, da kommen die Homes hin. Und das ist so unglaublich schwierig, irgendwie diesen Ordner auf dem anderen Volume in einen Zustand von Permissions und ACLs und sonstigen zu versetzen, dass ja auch wirklich, also dass das Admin-Tool sozusagen da auch wirklich Homes hinschreibt. Also du denkst, ja die Permissions sind doch ganz genau so. Und dann musst du irgendwie durch Apple Foren dich graben. Und ja, du musst aber vorher die ACL hier und dann musst du den Ordner so und so und hier und da. Und dann frekelst du dir das zusammen. Und am Ende, ja sonst halt einfach zwei Ordner. Und hast du dann Gui, also ne? Das sieht so einfach aus.
Also wenn man wirklich mit diesem Base-Set, so wie Apple sich das gedacht hat, wenn man damit gut klarkommt, dann ist man irgendwie echt im Himmel. Aber wenn man irgendwie Anpassungsbedarf hat, dann kann man jedem echt nur raten, das möglichst vorher zu testen, bevor man da irgendeine kritische Infrastruktur da dranhängt und wirklich davon ausgeht, dass das jetzt, ne?
Also ich hab halt ne Zeit lang den X-Surf so genutzt, dass ich halt eigentlich alles über Mac-Ports installiert hab und dann sozusagen Web-Server und so weiter alles aus Mac-Ports gefahren hab. Aber das ist halt auch nicht so richtig schön. Und von daher sitzt die Kiste jetzt eigentlich mehr oder weniger gelangweilt da und macht hauptsächlich halt so... Ja, LDAP und Shares für die User auf dem X-Rate und aber so Serviceless laufen da halt keine mehr drauf.
Das find ich eigentlich sehr schade.
Ja, ich auch. Also die benutzen ja eigentlich auch coole Technologie, also ihr Mailserver-Setup ist zum Beispiel auch genau das, was man haben will. Die benutzen jetzt DoveCut, Postfix und so und alles eigentlich total schick ans LDAP angebunden, wenn man genauso eigentlich haben. Aber in dem Moment, wo man dann wieder rangeht und sagt, ich will jetzt aber hier meinen eigenen Virenfilter oder ich will irgendwie nur noch die kleinste Anpassung daran haben, dann wird es schon sofort wieder so ein unmögliches Ding. Es ist echt schade und insofern würde ich sagen, so ein Mac Mini mit OS X Server lohnt sich halt. Also wüsste ich nicht, wofür sich das wirklich lohnt. Ja, aber du brauchst halt nicht dieses OS X Server da drauf. So ein bisschen wahrscheinlich, aber...
Na mal gucken, ich werde hier nächste Woche bei so einem Apple Event eingeladen. Da wird dieser Podcast Producer ausführlich vorgestellt.
Den habe ich noch nicht geprobiert, ja.
Ja, das gibt wohl wirklich Leute, die damit arbeiten und so. Ich habe mir das noch nie so genau angeschaut, deswegen dachte ich, klicke ich mir mal die Veranstaltung, ich werde dann berichten. Dafür könnte es halt auch eine Anwendung sein.
Aber ich glaube halt auch, also so richtig glauben tue ich nicht mehr daran, dass ihr Konzept von Betriebssystem und so weiter, dass das halt so für Server wirklich irgendwann nochmal richtig gut funktioniert.
Das müssen sie aber eigentlich reißen.
Also selbst so ein Open Solaris.
Ja, weil das ist einfach der fehlende Glow. Ich meine, wenn du eine Company hast, so eine kleine Bude und ich rede jetzt nicht von drei Etagen, fünf Abteilungen und weißt du, wo du dann auch noch für jede Etage noch eigene Zugangskarten brauchst. Nicht so was, sondern so eine vier, zehn Leute, die alle mehr oder weniger auch so am gleichen Kram arbeiten, alle unterschiedliche Aufgaben haben, aber wo man sich irgendwie noch duzt. Und da brauchst du halt auch so was Zentrales. Du willst die Homes da zentral haben und du willst da ein zentrales Backup haben und du willst das auch mit der Mail da irgendwie haben und du willst da auch ein Kalender haben. Und es muss einfach möglich sein, dass man so was aufsetzt. Und ich finde zwar diesen Mac Mini ein schönes Angebot, aber ich muss auch sagen, das ist mir dann wiederum zu klein zwischen diesem XServe, der gleich so dieses Monster-Teil ist.
Also der aktuelle XServe ist einer der schönsten Server, also nicht nur von der Bearbeitung her super edel, sondern auch wenn du den aufmachst, ist er einfach so super aufgeräumt und schön. Also im Vergleich zu allen Büchsen, die ich bisher so gesehen habe. Also die Suns sind zum Teil auch echt gut, oder wahrscheinlich auch die IBM Server, die habe ich lange nicht mehr gesehen. Aber alles, was die Leute von Thomas Crenn oder sonst wo kaufen, das ist so übler Kram mit scharfen Kanten, wo man sich dann irgendwie beim Aufschrauben gleich die halbe Hand aufschneidet und so. Bei Apple ist das so, die kommen auch gleich mit so schönen Teleskop-Schienen, die haben einfach sofort gepasst. Du kannst den rausziehen, zwei so Schnupsi-Schrauben auf und Deckel auf und du kommst dann alles ran. Also die Hardware ist echt super.
Aber es ist höllisch laut. Also wenn du kein irgendwie schallgedämmtes 19 Zoll Rack hast, kannst du das Ding halt nicht benutzen.
Der ist auch lang vor allen Dingen. Der passt halt auch nicht in so jedes Rack rein.
Der ist auch noch so super groß. Also du kannst den nicht einfach mal in irgendein normales Büroflur Rack reinschieben, weil da hast du einfach Alarm. Und der Mac Mini wiederum ist dann so ein kleines Puffelteil. Wo du dann irgendwie über Firewire da mit der externen Festplatte deiner Wahl da dir irgendwie was zusammenschlöpseln kannst. Da kommt man dann einmal kurz dagegen und dann war's das.
Vor allen Dingen hat der wenig Platz halt. Da passen ja zwei Platten zwar rein, aber das sind ja nur 2,5 Zoll und da kriegst du jetzt auch nicht viel speicher zusammen.
Genau, man braucht halt einfach mal auch ein paar Terabyte vielleicht an so einer Stelle. Du willst aber auch so Slot haben, aber du willst halt nicht so einen Monster-Teil haben. Und das ist genau das, was mir so fehlt. Gut, bei mir wär's eine Home-Appliance, aber ich würde eher sagen so ein Small-Company-Server, der irgendwie jetzt nicht so brutal durchlüftet und so riesig ist.
Aber dann kann man sich da nicht irgendwo einen Mac Pro schieben?
Ja, das wär's dann eigentlich Mac Pro. Aber das Problem ist eigentlich, von der Software-Seite...
Aber wird der Mac Pro mit... Gibt's in so einem Server-Bundle so nicht, ne? Der Mac Pro ist nicht als Server konzipiert. Klar, den kannst du natürlich als solches auch benutzen.
Und dass sie da so eine fette Grafikkarte finden. Genau, das lohnt mir gar nicht.
Aber was halt software-seitig einfach fehlt, ist so ein Package-Management, würde ich ja sagen. Zum Beispiel Open Solaris, was ich da gesehen hab. Die haben schon das extrem Schön gemacht mit der GUI, also für den Servo OS ist das echt gut gelungen. Das ist halt wie Panzerfahren, wie ja immer unsere befreundeten Nerds sagen, weil so auch, also das ist schon ganz schnell Klopper, so einfach an Komplexität und Wucht so.
Panzerfahren?
Na, Open Solaris ist oder Solaris ist Panzerfahren.
Das ist auch besser ein Panzerfahren, weil es auch nicht so wirklich so schnell ist.
Aber kommt überall durch. Genau, das ist einfach drüber und dann ist halt stable.
Sie haben halt schön ZFS integriert. Du hast ja dann sowas mit diesem... Das, was wir hier haben, hatten wir ja auch schon so.
Was wir hier mit unseren Amateurcomputern irgendwie auch in den nächsten fünf Jahren nicht haben dürfen.
Egal, aber das, was halt bei Open Solaris eben auch gut ist, ist eben der Package-Manager. Und dass du halt einfach so mit ein paar Klicks irgendwie Custom-Software-Pakete und so dir noch nachinstallieren kannst. Sowas hat Apple halt nicht. Und Mac Ports ist einfach nicht integriert genug, um irgendwie jetzt Klickleuten da eine Möglichkeit zu bieten, irgendwie Software nach zu installieren. Also das ist wirklich, meiner Meinung nach, eins der größten Mankos überhaupt.
Das ist auch etwas, wo sie wirklich auch für den Client auch für den Client noch eine ganze Menge Verbesserungen anbringen können und sollten und müssen eigentlich auch. Gut, schreiten wir mutig voran. Max, du warst so still die ganze Zeit. Der nicht anfangen kann, ist zu seufz. Du wolltest uns ja eigentlich geile Hardware vorstellen, aber hast es verpeilt.
Die hab ich vergessen. Das ist so dämlich. Ich hab mir von O'Toole, Palm...
Das sagt ja schon einiges. Oder dein iPhone hättest du nicht vergessen.
Du hast den Palmpray vergessen.
Ich hab mir von O'Toole, Palm zu schicken lassen.
Von wem?
Von O'Toole.
Achso, ich hab Otto verstanden.
Ja, ich auch. Von Otto, genau.
Bei Quelle noch rasch geschoppt.
Zum Testen hättet ihr ihn jetzt eigentlich schon ewig zurückschicken wollten. Wollt ihr jetzt extra noch nicht zurückschicken, damit ich ihn heute euch hier vorführen kann und zeigen kann, damit ihr auch mal drum drum drücken könnt.
Wir schicken dir nie wieder irgendwas.
Du musst gleich sehen, dass ich gleich dir das Ding erzähle.
Jetzt hast du überzogen und hast noch nicht mal dabei.
Ja, aber der ist echt geil. Ich bin echt begeistert von dem Ding. Also ich würde mir den immer wiederholen. Ich würde mir den nicht wiederholen? Nicht? Nein.
Also so doll nicht.
Er ist kein iPhone. Das gleich mal vorne weg. Aber es ist echt ein grandioses Gerät. Also was man ja am Anfang so sehr viel gehört hat, dass er unglaublich langsam sei. Er ist langsam. Er ist nicht sonderlich schnell. Aber er ist nicht so langsam, wie alle mal getan haben. Beziehungsweise, ich glaube, da hat Palme eine Menge getan. Der ist in den letzten Versionen doch deutlich schneller geworden. Mit diesem WebOS. Das ist echt... Damit kann man arbeiten. Was grandios ist, sind so Adressbuch-Sachen und so ein Zeug. Also du gibst halt deine Gmail-Adresse ein und hast das gesamte Adressbuch drauf. Okay, soweit kennen wir das auch von Android zum Beispiel. Aber du gibst auch deine Facebook-Adresse ein und er lädt sich da die ganzen Kontakte runter. Und die sind halt synchronisiert, sehen vernünftig aus. Dubletten löst er erstaunlich gut auf. Also das ist einfach. Ich hab natürlich Leute in meinem Google-Adressbuch, die ich auch bei Facebook kenne, und die erscheinen dann nicht doppelt, sondern die werden zu einem gemeinsamen Account zusammengeführt. Das ist extrem schick. Das Multitasking ist sehr intuitiv. Also so dieses berühmte, was so alle erzählen. Also es gab ja so Gerüchte, ja Multitasking ist schön und gut. Aber wenn es so langsam ist, dass ich auf dem iPhone in der Zeit Programme auch so gewechselt habe per Home-Button, dann bringt es das nicht. Es stimmt zum einen nicht, weil so langsam wechselt das nicht. Und zum zweiten ist es wesentlich bequemer. Also es ist halt, wenn du irgendwie meine Adresse hin und her kopieren willst oder sowas, dann wechselst du halt und gehst in das eine App, drückst den Home-Button kurz, wählst die andere Karte aus, gehst wieder zurück. Das ist ziemlich geil. Ja, und so Chat und sowas im Hintergrund offen zu haben, oder ein MP3-Player, das ist irgendwie besser gelöst als bei Apple. Also, dass es sich zum Beispiel auch durch diese Notifications, die es ja überall gibt. Also, davon haben wir auch schon eine Menge erzählt, oder?
Ja, ich höre dir einfach gespannt zu. Ich habe jetzt so den skeptischen Blick, weil ich irgendwie jetzt...
Jetzt geht's gegen Apple.
Nein!
Also, diese Notifications...
Ich habe versucht, mir diesen Palme Prix irgendwie im Laden, und ich bin immer noch nicht dazu gekommen, wenn das Ding mal in Ruhe anzuschauen. Ich dachte, heute hätte ich die Gelegenheit dazu. Aber im Laden befand sich das Ding in irgendeinem Modus und ich war nicht in der Lage, ihn aus diesem Modus herauszubringen. Also, es hat sich mir überhaupt nicht erschlossen, in was für einem Modus er überhaupt war und warum man ihn da nicht rauskriegte.
War das dieses Log-Screen oder sowas? Also es ist...
Keine Ahnung. Es hat auch nichts mir gesagt oder erklärt. Es war einfach nur nicht nutzbar.
Also, dieses Slide to Unlock hat sich Apple offensichtlich patentieren lassen. Diesen Schieberegler, den man beim Unlocken hat.
Beim Google Phone auch. Google hat das auch.
Nee, beim Google Phone ist das so ein Ding, was man drehen muss.
Nee, und bei den neuen haben sie doch so eine Matrix, wo man dann so Muster drauf gleitet.
Das ist auch bei den älteren, das ist so der Code quasi.
Also bei dem Nexus One war das auch nur so von links nach rechts. Vielleicht noch so einer leichten Kurve, aber...
Also bei den Zwein-Nullern war das, also mit Android 2.0 war da so ein Rädchen, das konnte man allerdings gleich in zwei Richtungen drehen. Das war eigentlich ganz cool. Also konnte man in eine Richtung drehen zum Unlocken, glaube ich, und in die andere Richtung drehen, dann hat man auf Stumm geschaltet.
Okay, naja.
Und bei Palm ist das so, da hat man einen kleinen Punkt, den man aus einem bestimmten Bereich rausziehen muss. Also der ist dann relativ beliebig, also man muss ihn aus einer Fläche rausziehen. Und die Bedienung ist eigentlich wirklich schick intuitiv. Also es ist ein bisschen was anderes als beim iPhone. Man hat eine Menüleiste oben, eine kleine, aber das macht einen extrem polischten Eindruck, dieses ganze Gerät. Man hat so an manchen Stellen das Gefühl, ja, da hatten sie nicht das Geld, das jetzt 100% fertig zu machen. Also es gibt so ein paar kleinere Ungereimtheiten, aber im Wesentlichen schon auf Apple-Niveau, sag ich jetzt mal, im Sinne von die Eigens sehen einfach geil aus. Die Menüführung ist zu Ende gedacht. Man ist nicht die ganze Zeit irgendwie am Rumfluchen oder sowas. Worüber man ein bisschen rumflucht, ist die Tastatur. Die ist ziemlich gewöhnungsbedürftig. Allerdings kam ich mit der nach kürzerem Tippenrei wesentlich besser klar, als ich am Anfang gedacht hätte. Man muss halt mit dem Fingernagel tippen und nicht so sehr mit der Fläche des Fingers. Dann geht das. Also das sind so kleine Pöppeltasten.
So für Mäusefinger einfach.
Ja, sowas im Wesentlichen.
Also ich glaub, für Leute mit großen Fingern irgendwie.
Das ist ein Frauen-Handy.
Ich hab ja nun keine extrem kleinen Hände.
Ja gut, aber wenn du schon deinen Fingernagel zum Einsatz bringen musst, um das Ding überhaupt benutzen zu müssen.
Ich glaub, das ist einfach bei solchen Tastaturen so.
Tastaturen?
Mit welcher Tastatur schreibst du denn mit dem Fingernagel?
Ach so, auf diesen kleinen Pöckel-Keyboard? Ich weiß nicht, wie man daraus anders tippen soll.
Und was machen so Leute wie Tim?
Ja, also wenn du nicht so rumläufst wie so ein Yogi-Typ.
Ach komm, es ist ja sowieso so, als ob ich acht Meter lange Fingernägel hätte und gerade durch die Decke durchgehe.
Wie auch immer, es gibt da unterschiedlichste Finger.
Ja, also am Anfang hab ich gedacht, oh mein Gott, das ist die Katastrophe, ich kann da noch mal weiter ziemlich gut mitklappen. Wollte ich nur gesagt haben. Was ganz geil ist, ist so diese Homebrew-Szene um das Ding herum. Also es gibt, ähnlich wie für alle anderen aktuellen Smartphones, gibt es auch für den Palm Pre einen einen sehr aktiven, einen Jailbreak und um diesen Jailbreak herum eine sehr aktive Homebrew-Szene. Und diesen Jailbreak hab ich mir nicht nehmen lassen, mal einzuspielen. Das war sehr, sehr leicht. Also man muss im Wesentlichen ein Restore-Image von seinem...
Warte mal, einen Jailbreak für den Pre?
Dann hat man danach einen eigenen Package-Manager drauf.
Ach so, weil das das gleiche Spiel ist, es gibt wieder den Shop und nur da gibt es irgendwie die Software.
Genau.
Und im Prinzip ist das das Upstore-Modell.
Im Wesentlichen ist das das Upstore-Modell. Aber sind denn da überhaupt irgendwelche Ups drin? Da waren extrem wenige zu dem Zeitpunkt. Das muss allerdings auch sagen, als ich das letzte Mal mir das so richtig angeguckt hab, war ein extrem ungünstiger Zeitpunkt, weil es gibt auch in Amerika, oder es gab auch vorher nicht viele in diesem Appstore, viele Programme, und genau da hat Palm sich entschieden, okay, jetzt machen wir es mal so. Nur Leute, jetzt führen wir eine Ländergrenze ein. Wenn die Leute gesagt haben, das Programm gibt es nur in Amerika, also irgendwo gab es die Checkbox dafür, dann gibt es das ab sofort nur noch in Amerika. Vorher gab es die einfach generell überall. Es gab nur einen Webshop für alle, ein Appstore. Und da hat das dann auch eine ganze Weile gedauert, offensichtlich bis die Programme von Leuten gesagt haben, Moment, bei mir ist das eigentlich, also ich hab da versehentlich nur USA angeklickt, wahrscheinlich war das auch irgendwann mal ein Default wert. Und ich möchte natürlich das auch in Europa und sonst wo verkaufen. Und die mussten einfach offensichtlich die Checkbox anklicken, dass das auch in den anderen verspügbar ist. Mit der Auswahl für Android oder erst recht fürs iPhone ist es aber nach wie vor nicht im Ansatz vergleichbar. Ein Teil davon wird von dieser Homebrew-Szene aufgefangen, wo es wirklich ein paar sehr, sehr geile Programme gibt. Also eins, was dir, glaube ich, ganz gut gefallen würde, ist ein Podcasting-Programm.
Warum sind die denn nicht in dem normalen Appstore?
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keinen Schimmer. Also an dem gibt es nichts auszusetzen, warum das nicht im Appstore drin sein sollte.
Welche anderen Programme hast du denn ausprobiert, die aus gutem Grund nicht in deren Appstore sind?
Es gibt so...
Gibt es da auch so Porno und so?
Nein, aber es gibt so viele... Es gibt Patches ohne Ende. Also ich nehme an dadurch, dass das Web-Interface in HTML und JavaScript geschrieben ist, ist das ja leicht durch einen Patch anpassbar. Und ich nehme an, dass die... Also es gibt so erstaunlich viele kleine Verbesserungen für den Webbrowser und so was, wo man dann sagen kann, wo irgendwie Gesten eingeführt werden, neue oder so was. Oder wirklich so ein Patch, der genau eine kleine Änderung in einem bestehenden Programm einfügt, die es unter Umständen extrem sinnvoll macht.
Was sagt denn das bitte über das Sicherheitsmodell des Pri aus?
Na, dass sobald du einen J-Break gemacht hast, du alles machen kannst. Genauso wie auf dem iPhone.
Weißt du, auf welcher Basis dieser J-Break funktioniert? Also ist das jetzt genauso so ein Aufriss wie auf dem iPhone, dass er richtig...
Also man muss dem Konami-Code eingeben auf der Tastatur, um in einen Developer-Modus zu kommen.
Konami-Code?
Na, dieses Up, Up, Down, Down, Left, Right, Left, Right, A, B, Start. War das denn richtig? Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Und wenn man den dann eingegeben hat, dann versetzt sich der Palm in einen USB-Modus, mit dem man ein zusätzliches Programm hat, also ein Developer-Modus, mit dem man ein zusätzliches Programm hat, über das man dann ein paar Features einschalten kann und da muss man dann einen speziellen USB-Modus einspielen und darüber wird dann eine aktualisierte Firmware eingespielt. Also ich nehme an, das ist schon vom Jailbreak-Verhalten her relativ ähnlich dem auf dem iPhone, bloß dass wahrscheinlich nicht ganz so viele Sicherheitsbarrieren zu überwinden waren. Dafür muss man auch eine Restore-Image der jeweiligen Firmware haben, also der Palm-Firmware, die man drauf spielen will. Und das Wichtige dabei ist, die muss auch für das entsprechende Gerät angepasst werden. Also ich brauchte für den entsprechenden Netzbetreiber eine Version für O2, mit der das dann ging. Dann hab ich diesen Jailbreak gemacht, das ging erstaunlich problemlos. Bringst du mir eine Mate mit? Wenn du hier schon probierst, unerfällig abzusauen? Es gibt ein paar schöne Programme dafür. Ein Haufen üblicher Müll, wie das so ist, was die Leute als erstes portieren. Haufenweise Kommando-Zeilen-Tools und so was, die man auf einem Telefon nicht unbedingt braucht.
Wenn du jetzt umsteigen würdest, wenn du jetzt dein iPhone würdest, würdest du jetzt weggeben und du müsstest jetzt nur noch den Palm-Pri haben. Was ist das Erste, was du vermissen würdest?
Ein richtig guter Twitter-Client und die Geschwindigkeit.
Ist es so sehr viel langsamer?
Es ist langsamer als ein iPhone 3G. Ach echt? Ja, ja. Also es ist... Also der Programmwechsel dauert schon. Oder wenn man viele Programme offen hat, das ist schon nicht schnell. Das ist schnell genug. Ich glaube, man kann sich mit abfinden. Aber man kann sich... Also es ist halt... Man muss sich mit abfinden. Es ist nicht so...
Wenn denn diese Programme auch irgendwie automatisch beendet? Also ich meine... Was ist denn, wenn das dann voll ist? Kommt dann irgendwie Auto auf Memory, Error, Intend oder?
Hätte ich ehrlich gesagt noch gar nicht. Es ist einfach... Solange du so eine Karte offen hast, ist die halt offen. Und so lange läuft das Programm. Und sobald du diese Karte rausschnippst, ist das Programm beendet. Was auf so einer Art total intuitiv ist. Ich glaube, er sagt dann einfach, dass man Karten wegwerfen soll, wenn er nicht genügend speichert. Also er weigert sich dann, das App zu starten. Und das ist auch beim MP3-Player so. Also bei Apple ist es ja, solange man Play im iPod offen hat, also Play gedrückt hat, kann man das Programm ja beenden, wie man will. Und es läuft trotzdem weiter. Beim Palmister ist das eigentlich dann fast konsequent. Wenn du einen MP3 spielst und du schmeißt die Karte vom MP3-Player dann weg, dann hört er auf zu spielen. Dann ist das Programm beendet und es kann auch keine Musik mehr abspielen. Aber was wirklich toll ist, sind diese Notifications. Die sehen auf dem Papier super aus. Die sind noch besser, wenn man sie in Realität auf dem Gerät hat. Das kennen wir alle oder viele von uns vom iPhone. Man tippt irgendwie rum, surft gerade im Netz, plötzlich kommt per SMS rein und man hat so einen Dialog über dem Ding kleben.
Oder mitten im Film.
Oder mitten im Film. Man muss das erstmal wegklicken und ist alles total nervig. Das ist ja wirklich so die schlechteste.
Dann weißt du nie so genau, wann er jetzt automatisch das Programm startet. Das tut er, wenn du im Homescreen bist, aber nicht, wenn du im anderen Programm bist. Das ist immer ein bisschen unklar.
Und die sich dann auch gegenseitig überdecken?
Ja, oder du machst dann einen Unlock und dann ist es irgendwie weg. Dann weißt du nicht, was da war.
Und wenn eine da war, dann kommt die nächste. Das ist wirklich hinreichend schlecht gelöst. Beim Palm ist das sehr gut gelöst. Und zwar wird quasi das Display ein bisschen kleiner. Das Display ist ganz hübsch abgerundet. Und das wird dann einfach ein bisschen kleiner. Und darunter erscheinen dann so kleinere Nachrichten. Und diese Nachrichten kann man erstmal wunderbar ignorieren. Also sobald man klickt, verkleinern die sich nochmal ein bisschen zu so einem Eiken, das dann wirklich nur noch ganz, ganz wenig Platz wegnimmt. Und wenn man die Nachricht einfach weg haben will, dann wippt man sie so mit dem Finger zur Seite und dann fliegt sie aus dem Bild raus und ist weg. Oder man tippt drauf und dann startet das Programm dafür. Das geht so weit, dass wenn man eben diesen Media Player an hat, den MP3 Player, dann erscheinen da kleine Play-Pause-Button für das jeweilige, was er gerade spielt drin. Das heißt, man kann da auch direkt drüber steuern über so winzig kleine Buttons. Da steht dann natürlich auch mal das Albumcover mit drin. Das ist wirklich schön gemacht. Da haben sich Leute echt viele Gedanken um die Details gemacht.
Also ich denke auch in diesem Bereich Notification müssen sich eigentlich was einfallen lassen. Was mich insofern beruhigt ist, dass es so wie es derzeit ist, es ist so dermaßen bare bones, dass es eigentlich...
Darauf hindeutet, dass sie noch nie Gedanken drum gemacht haben.
Na ja, wahrscheinlich haben sie sich darüber Gedanken gemacht, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, es ist ein bisschen wie mit dem Copy und Paste. Das war ja eigentlich auch meine Erwartung, dass das Copy und Paste, das wird kommen. Aber es dauert deshalb so lange, weil sie wirklich da lange drüber nachdenken, weil in dem Moment, wo sie es einmal einführen, muss es gut sein. Ja, und dann werden sie es ja auch nicht mehr los. Und dann muss es halt einfach ihren Anforderungen gelingen. Und ich finde, es ist gut geworden. Also wenn es ihnen gelingt, was Vergleichbares zu Copy und Paste im Bereich Notification zu bringen, also jetzt nicht, dass es genau so aussieht, hat ja nichts miteinander zu tun, aber du weißt, was ich meine, was für eine Ausgewogenheit, dass man sich danach einfach genauso wohlfühlt damit, wie sie es da gemacht haben. Ich meine, das ist ja eh ihr Vorteil, dass sie jetzt einfach so viel Atem haben, und keiner kommt ihnen auch nur ansatzweise.
Das merkt man ja tatsächlich den Palm ein bisschen an, um da jetzt nochmal so einen kleinen Kritikpunkt zu haben. Irgendwie hat man das Gefühl, das ist eine kleine Firma, die dahinter steckt. Die haben nicht die Manpower. Die Maps-Applikation ist rudimentär. Die kann auf den ersten Blick, die kann einem anzeigen, wo man ist, man kann Adressen eingeben und die kann Wege raussuchen. Aber so ganz billige Sachen, wie zum Beispiel, du hast eine Adresse eingegeben, er zeigt dir die Adresse an und dieses was, das hat Android, das hat das iPhone, zeig mir jetzt mal den Weg zu dieser Adresse, wie ich jetzt von hier nach da komme. Kann das einfach nicht. Geht nicht. Gibt es keine Möglichkeit für. Also das Maps-Programm ist wirklich unter aller Kanone.
Obwohl sie aber auch Google Maps benutzen oder nicht?
Sie benutzen im Wesentlichen glaube ich die Webversion von Google Maps. Ich glaube, sie haben wirklich einfach nur, es gibt ja, die läuft auch auf dem iPhone, so wenn man zum Beispiel Google Latitude verwendet, das ja keine native App ist auf dem iPhone, dann hat man ja die Webversion und dann sieht man manchmal so Layer, die drüber eingeblendet sind und das sind dann offensichtlich HTML Sachen. Die sehen auf dem iPhone, auf dem Palmpre genauso aus. Also ich glaube, die haben wirklich nicht viel mehr gemacht als Google Maps genommen aus der Webversion und das in einem, mit einem Alkan versehen.
Liegt ja auch nahe, bei so einem webbasierten Development-Modell, was soll dieser sonst machen?
Das zeigt ja auch ein Stück weit die Mächtigkeit dieses Modells, dass ich mir nach wie vor nicht 100% sicher bin, ob es wirklich so ist, beziehungsweise es nur an einigen kleinen Details überhaupt sehen konnte, aber ja.
Ich bin gespannt, wie viel Atem die überhaupt haben.
Ja, es gibt ja, irgendjemand hat hier vorgeschlagen, dass Nokia sie aufkaufen sollte und dann daraus...
Ja, oder Motorola hab ich auch schon.
Das wird dann natürlich der Untergang werden für die, aber das ist meine starke Vermutung, dass das dann...
Ich weiß nicht, so Motorola...
Also bei Nokia könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass er erst mal die nächsten drei Jahre damit beschäftigt sind, das Olympian kompatibel zu kriegen.
Aber Motorola macht doch mit dem Droid gerade und mit den Milestone hier in Europa, die sind da eigentlich gerade wieder ganz gut dabei, oder nicht?
Wollen wir ein bisschen über Android reden, oder? Ja, also beziehungsweise diese ganze Smartphone-Marktsituation. Mann, jetzt sind wir wieder, also mit Nokia...
Ey komm, er hat gesagt 2011 sind sie wieder voll dabei.
Er hat doch mal gesagt, es ist ein Gummistiefelmarkt, oder was?
Der Typ, er meint, sie sind jetzt wieder ein bisschen hinterher, aber sie sind gerade voll dabei, so und in 2011 sind sie irgendwie wieder... Ich weiß gar nicht, wie er das meint, hat er damit eigentlich schon zugegeben, dass es schon abwärts geht? Irgendso ein CEO hat sich doch da fett aus dem Fenster gehangen. Er meinte, sie werden da schon innovativmäßig irgendwie gerade ein bisschen nicht so bei der Sache, aber sie sind gerade voll am Schrauben machen und tun, und die Produkte kommen jetzt alle raus, und ab 2011 sind sie wieder voll am Start.
Ja, die geben jetzt alles Mögliche von sich, um noch den Eindruck zu erwecken, dass sie noch irgendwie wiederkommen würden. Ja, aber mein ursprünglicher Kritikpunkt an ihrer Situation, nämlich, dass sie eigentlich keinen Plan haben, mit welcher Plattform sie jetzt in die Zukunft marschieren wollen, das kriegt auch einfach monatlich neue Nahrung. Jetzt haben sie wieder vorgestellt für ihre nächste Version von Symbian, wie das da, das User-Interface aussehen soll, sozusagen alles ohne Touch, ja, und dann halt alles so voll dieser iPhone-Style mit transparenten Fenstern und hübsche Wettereikons und das Übliche halt so, was man mittlerweile einfach als gegeben hinnimmt. Nur ist halt kein Touch, sondern ist halt nach wie vor für ihre komischen Tastentelefone mit Hoch und Runter und Links und Rechts. Und was ist die Botschaft davon? Wir machen doch weiter mit Symbian. Ich glaube, dass sie sich damit ganz schön ins Knie geschossen haben mit dieser Klage, weil das, soweit ich das nachgelesen habe, könnte das Böse für sie enden. Aber da können wir gleich nochmal drauf eingehen. Aber jetzt reden sie wieder von Symbian, dann reden sie von Maemo, was sie jetzt ganz groß angekündigt haben. Und das Ding ist, Maemo ist ja, also das gibt es jetzt auf diesem Nokia 900 und hat jetzt so einen gewissen Reifezustand erreicht. Das Ding ist nur, das Maemo, was es heute gibt, ist halt das GTK-basierte Maemo. An dem sie jetzt schon seit Jahren rumfrickeln, angefangen mit diesen ersten, ja, wie soll man es nennen?
Nokia 700 war das ja.
Genau, diese mobilen Web-Browser, die halt einfach keine Telefone waren. Genau, Tablettafel, das Thema. Ja, wir werden noch auf das Tablet kommen. So, und jetzt haben sie ja groß angekündigt vor ein paar Monaten. Ja, hier Maemo The Future, genauso wie jetzt wieder Symbian 4.0 The Future. Nur das Entwicklerteam, was dieses Maemo jetzt zusammengeklöppelt hat, wurde jetzt Ende des Jahres aufgelöst. Da hab ich so First-Hand-Knowledge. Und das gibt es jetzt nicht mehr. Weil sie nämlich jetzt auf QT gehen, was sie ja gekauft haben vor einiger Zeit, Troll-Tech.
Das würde mich aber mal als frischer Nokia 900-Kunde, der sich auf eine Zukunft dieses Betriebssystems hofft, oder seines Telefons, seiner Investitionen, würde mich das einfach richtig schön ärgern, wenn das erste Gerät seit drei Minuten auf dem Markt ist, mit dem ernstzunehmenden Gerät, mit diesem Podcast.
Genau, und das erste, was sie machen, ist, dass sie das Entwicklerteam auslösen.
Okay, ich brauche jetzt nicht mehr, wir haben das Gerät.
Es ist wirklich alles ein bisschen absurd. Jetzt gibt es halt irgendwie so eine andere Bude, die da einspringt und jetzt quasi für dieses Maemo alles dann auf Qt macht mit C++ und halt dem, wie bei KDE mit dem Framework. Das ja durchaus kapabel ist und sagen wir mal, vom Feature-Set her schon das ist, was auch dem Coco da noch am nächsten kommt. Nur, dass ich da selbst jetzt mit C++, da sehe ich jetzt überhaupt gar keine Zukunft im Mobile-Development. Die Leute haben sich jetzt damit arrangiert, dass man halt auf dem iPhone wie auf dem Mac programmiert. So ja, Objective-C und geht schon, und der Markt ist groß, und wir lernen das jetzt alle. Und alle anderen machen eigentlich, gut, nein, stimmt nicht, dann gibt's Android mit Java.
Und noch mal, nativen SDK, hört man mich überhaupt noch gerade? Okay, ich mich gar nicht mehr.
Wie, du hörst dich nicht?
Das sagt ja auch nichts.
Für Android gibt's mittlerweile auch natives SDK.
Ich glaube, das heißt dann NDK.
Ja, sprich dich aus. Mit dem man, ich glaube, in C oder in C++ deutlich weiter unten programmieren kann als auf der Java-Virtual-Machine. Aber nichts Genaues weiß ich da auch nicht. Es gibt's schon eine ganze Weile, das ist dann wahrscheinlich für Spieleentwicklung gedacht und so ein Scheiß.
Auf dem Palm?
Auf dem Android.
Ja, aber das ist doch eh schon Low-Level da mit dem Java.
Aber offensichtlich nicht schnell genug. Ich krieg mal raus, was das NDK ist, bevor ich...
Ja, aber Java ist doch schnell. Der Palm hat jetzt noch so ein zusätzliches SDK rausgebracht. Genau. Sie wollen halt auch schnelle Spiele haben. Aber ich glaub nicht, dass irgendjemand was dafür entwickeln wird. Also es ist halt, das ist auch genau das, was ich meine. Also es ist einfach alles total durcheinander. Und keiner weiß eigentlich so richtig, was man davon so halten soll. Keiner weiß so richtig, was nun eigentlich die Plattform ist bei Nokia. Geschweige denn, welche Gerätegeneration irgendwie vorangeht. Geschweige denn, dass selbst wenn mal da zwei Geräte das gleiche Betriebssystem haben, was denn nun das Featureset ist. Hat es eine Tastatur, hat es einen Touchscreen, hat es Multitouch, hat es nicht. Ist es ein Druckbildschirm, ist es irgendwie ein richtiger Touchbildschirm, ist es irgendwie vertikal, ist es quer, ist es zum Aufklappen, ist es sonst irgendwas. Niemand weiß Bescheid. Geschweige denn, was die Bildschirmauflösung ist. Da ist es ja auch bei Android genauso. Jetzt hier mit diesem Nexus One, da müssen wir ja eh nochmal drauf zu sprechen kommen.
Nexus was?
Dann lässt du uns jetzt ein bisschen in den Stänkern lauern.
Ja, du hast ja gerne Stänkern. Ich hab das ja schon mal in der Hand gehabt. Auf dem Kongress. Und da hat mir leider so jemand in die Hand gedrückt. Also ich hatte wirklich zwei, fünf Minuten vor meinem Workshop hatte ich keine Zeit, das jetzt wirklich zu testen. Aber ich konnte feststellen, ja okay, das sieht jetzt erstmal ganz gut aus. Und es ist jetzt kein offensichtlicher Dreck. Und das mit dem Touch funktioniert da auch so, wie man das erstmal so erwartet. Und das Ding war auch irgendwie schnell. Und ja, und es hatte halt einen Trackball.
Das haben alle HTC-Geräte. Also mein Android hat das auch.
Wozu hat das Ding einen Trackball?
Zur Textauswahl. Die haben nicht diese Lupenfunktion, wie auf dem iPhone. Der einzige Grund, wofür ich tatsächlich benutze den Trackball, ist...
Achso, du meinst Text desektieren. Damit man richtig die Stände findet.
Dafür nutze ich es. Ansonsten nutze ich es tatsächlich gar nicht. Aber das ist tatsächlich ein einheitliches Bedienmodell. Die Tasten, die das Ding hat, die sind auf jedem HTC-Android genauso.
Das ist ja glaube ich auch eine Vorgabe von der Android-Plattform, dass jedes Phone, das das benutzen soll, diese vier Tasten und so einen Knubbel haben.
Nee, den Knubbel haben sie nicht andere. Aber diese vier Tasten haben so glaube ich so ziemlich alle.
Die dann jetzt wiederum in diesen Bildschirm mit integriert sind, sodass wenn du dann an der Unterkante deines Bildschirms noch irgendwelche Kontrolls hast, dass du dann auch schnell irgendwie da drauf kommst. Das habe ich jetzt selber so nicht, da bin ich nicht so reingelaufen, aber viele haben das berichtet.
Das ist auch... Das haben auch viele... Also ich habe das schon bei anderen Telefonen. Sony Ericsson hatte auch so Phones, die diese Softkeys sozusagen so touchempfindlich am Screen haben. Und sobald du da irgendwie nur in die Nähe kommst, lösen die schon aus und öffnen irgendwelche Menüs und so.
Na ich nehme mal an, also ich... Also bei Sony Ericsson kannte ich das auch. Bei Sony Ericsson war das Dämliche, dass die Softkeys waren das Einzige, was daran... Also du drückst unten auf irgendwelche virtuellen Tasten rum. Aber oben im Display kannst du da nichts mehr per Touch machen, wo man sich natürlich innerhalb von Sekunden fragt, wieso eigentlich nicht.
Das ist halt alles so inkonsistent und so unkonsequent. Und vor allem für Applikationsentwickler, die jetzt überlegen, mit Android zu arbeiten, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, was sollen die targeten? Also da gibt es irgendwie keinen einheitlichen Screen Size. Ja, dieses Nexus One hat jetzt wieder...
Das Nexus hat jetzt wieder eine neue. Es gibt 320 x 480. Das sind quasi die ersten Geräte mit Android. Und dann gibt es diese. Was haben die jetzt alle? 800 x 480? Das Nexus und das Milestone.
Das ist nämlich nicht so bei dem Nexus. Bei dem Nexus ist es nämlich noch mal anders.
Da gibt es so eins mit 480 x 856 oder sowas.
Aber es hat... Warte mal, hier steht jetzt 480 x 800. Ich dachte, es wäre 800 und irgendwas.
Ja, eins hatte 800 und irgendwas.
Aber die haben noch...
War das nicht das Nexus?
Die haben noch eher so ein anderes.
Das Nexus war ein Stück größer, das Nexus war mal 800, glaube ich.
Aber die haben noch so ein eher anderes Problem. Also zum Beispiel hier iPhone und so ist ja... Und iPotouch ist ja eben auch so voll die Spiele-Plattform. Was ja zum Beispiel bei den anderen gar nicht der Fall ist, weil die halt, so zu sagen, die ganzen Spieleentwickler ja von Performance und so weiter sich gar nicht auf irgendwas verlassen können. Die Androids benutzen ja auch, glaube ich, nicht mal Grafikbeschleunigung, sondern erinnern ja alles in Software. Was eben auch noch dazu beiträgt, dass da das Interface so ein bisschen sluggish wirkt. Und das alleine ist ja sozusagen schon so ein Punkt, wo ich als zum Beispiel Spieleentwickler jetzt gar keinen Bock drauf hätte.
Uwe, hat es uns das wieder? Da gab es doch diesen Spruch, dass man soll die Hardware zu seiner Software machen und andersrum, ne?
Ja, den Spruch gab es, aber ich glaube, der wird sich wieder mal nicht bewahrheiten.
Tatsache ist, iPhone-Killer gibt es nicht. Es gibt keinen iPhone-Killer.
Nee, es gibt keinen iPhone-Killer.
Aber hast du nicht mal gesehen? Also ich meine, das sagt ja auch schon ganz lange keiner mehr. Haben sie aufgegeben.
Ach klar, jetzt mit dem Nexus-Wanderkampf ist auch gleich erstmal wieder iPhone-Killer. Google stellt den iPhone-Killer vor.
Ja, aber die wollen ja gar nicht im Smartphone-Markt antreten. Die sind doch im Superphone-Bereich.
Was, wer hat das denn gesagt?
Sie haben das Ding vorgestellt als Superphone.
Weil sie wussten, gegen Smartphone haben sie keine Chance.
Nee, aber muss man mal sagen, natürlich ist das Nexus-Wanderkampf kein iPhone-Killer, weil wer sollte sich die Arbeit machen, das iPhone zu killen? Also was gibt es da zu killen? Die haben ganz okere Marktanteile, aber ich glaube, das wird mit dem iPhone so gehen, wie es damals dem Mac ging. Das iPhone wird ein...
Wie es damals dem Mac ging, das muss man zwar erklären.
Welches damals, meinst du jetzt?
Das ganz, ganz früher, als es angefangen hat. Weil es wird einfach mit Android wesentlich mehr Geräte geben. Die werden teilweise wesentlich billiger sein. Und...
Ach du meinst jetzt den Windows versus...
Genau, diesen Kampf.
Und da können wir... Da setzt sich die komplette Wagenladung, Club Marte, da geht das mal.
Also ich glaube, du schuldest noch einen Kasten, oder?
Won't happen, won't happen. Nee, das glaube ich nicht.
Also ich glaube, es gibt einfach mit diesem ein Gerät...
Ich meine, was ist denn bitte das schlagende Argument für Android? Dieser sogenannte Vorteil, in Anführungsstrichen, dass es ein OS gibt, was dann auf vielen Telefonen ist, führt ja nur zu einer Zersplitterung der technischen Basis, weil niemand mehr weiß, was diese Plattform eigentlich ist. Du hast das Problem, die Geräte haben alle nicht dieselbe Softwareversion. Die Anpassung, das wird immer schwieriger werden, das anzupassen. Das ist eher so wie dann später mit Windows, wo sie dann irgendwie...
Das ist ein Problem, dass jedes Gerät eine andere Version hat. Das müssen sie definitiv in den Griff kriegen. Das sehe ich ja genauso. Also wenn da irgendwie, wer war das irgendwie? So ein Kanadischer, einer von diesen kanadischen Telcos hat gesagt, oh ja, diese Android-Geräte mit 1.5, mit Android 1.5, nee, so ein 1.6er, das braucht man da nicht drauf. Das braucht ihr nicht auf eurem Telefon, geschweige denn 2.0. Bleibt mal schön bei 1.5. Klar, das geht auf keinen Fall. Da muss es irgendeine Lösung für geben. Aber, also erstmal, was sind schon jetzt die Vorteile von Google, von Android gegenüber einem iPhone, ist natürlich, es gibt einfach eine große Auswahl an Software, die es für Android gibt, die es auf dem iPhone nicht gibt.
Aber sicher auf allen Androids.
Nein, also was du auf jedem Android hast, ist eine vernünftige Synchronisation deines Adressbos. Können wir auf dem iPhone nach wie vor, also gibt es zwar dieses Google-Mobile-Sync mit über Exchange und so.
Also ich muss ja sagen, ich habe mein Adressbuch ausschließlich da in diesem Desktop-Adressbuch und der Sync funktioniert zum Beispiel.
Du kannst ja auch mit deinem Google-Account synchronisieren. Schickst du einfach in iTunes an, dann hast du das auch.
Ja, sobald ich dieses Kabel hier reinstecke und da reinstecke und iTunes da starte.
Du meinst, dass es over the air ist?
Natürlich.
Ja gut, ich meine, wenn das wirklich, wirklich wichtig ist, dann wird es Apple keine Mühe kosten, das einzubauen.
Aber auf dem anderen Gerät gibt es das.
Ja, aber das ist kein strategischer Vorteil, weil der strategische Vorteil vom iPhone gegenüber Android ist erheblich. Also das Ding gibt es auch ohne Telefon. Für das Ding gibt es Spiele in Massen. Da gibt es jetzt schon eine riesige Auswahl an Programmen. Und wenn du mir sagst, es gibt Programme auf Android, die gibt es nicht auf dem iPhone. Okay, dann das drehen wir doch mal schnell um. Wie viele Programme gibt es für das iPhone, die es nicht für Android gibt? Da kannst du 30 Plattformen mit füllen. Also das ist eigentlich überhaupt gar kein Argument. Das ist eine extreme Sichtweise aus dieser Android-Welt heraus. Und ich sehe ja auch noch andere Sachen als ein Problem an, die gar nicht so diskutiert werden. Nämlich zum Beispiel, was ist bitte das Business-Modell von Android? Wer verdient damit Geld? Wer hat ein Interesse daran, diese Plattform wirklich kraftvoll zu machen?
Na Google und die Hersteller der Geräte.
Die Hersteller der Geräte, die werden sich irgendwann noch mal schön umdrehen und sich fragen, warum sie eigentlich mit Google gehen sollen, wenn Google ihnen irgendwie alle Services, mit denen sie derzeit noch ihren Value-Edit-Klimbim machen, auch noch abzieht, inklusive Google Voice.
Die Hersteller, die verkaufen Geräte, die haben ein eindeutiges Geschäftsmodell, die stellen Telefone her und die verkaufen sie dann.
Das Geschäftsmodell ist ein bisschen überholt.
Entschuldigung, ich hab die Provaider gemeint.
Na Apple verdient nicht nur mit den Geräten, die verdienen ja dann danach auch noch.
Apple verdient aber nur, weil Apple auch noch mit anderen Dingen verdient, heißt das nicht, dass das Geschäftsmodell überholt ist.
Ja, aber du willst ja, dass sich einer noch um die Geräte kümmert, nachdem du sie gekauft hast.
Ja, das sollte Google tun.
Nee, lass uns mal über das reden.
Aber warum sollten wir das machen?
Weil Google damit mit Android Geld verdient und ein Interesse daran hat, dass du auf deinem Gerät immer die aktuelle Software-Version drauf hast.
Google verdient Geld mit Android?
Ja, ansonsten hätte sie es nicht gemacht.
Wo verdienen die damit Geld?
Auf langer Sicht, wie es bei Google so üblich ist, indem sie dann irgendwann, also ist meine Vermutung, indem sie glauben, dass... Weil sie für mich Sinn macht. Also Google muss ein Interesse daran haben. Google hat offensichtlich...
Die haben ein Interesse daran.
Irgendwann haben sie mal beschlossen, wir brauchen ein Handybetriebssystem. Warum haben sie das beschlossen?
Weil sie damit Geld verdienen wollen. Ja, aber wie?
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie mit Android selbst Geld verdienen, sondern eher durch die langfristige Wirkung von Android Geld verdienen.
Und weil die Algepo-Firmen ankommen, möglichst nicht viel selbst machen wollen und Google ein bisschen Android vor die Füße wirft und dafür dann aber andere Werbung verdienen.
Guck mal, worauf ich hinaus wollte, mit den Herstellern. Ich hab vorhin in der Antwort was verdreht. Mit den Services, das bezieht sich auf die Proviere. Ich lasse mich jetzt erstmal außen vor. Aber mit den Geräteherstellern ist es ja auch so, dass die Android-Geräte, die halt draußen sind, teilweise, nicht alle, auch mit eigenen User-Interface-Ampfassungen daherkommen. Das heißt, es gibt einen enormen Bedarf bei diesen Herstellern, ob das nun gerechtfertigt ist oder nicht, diese Modifikation zu machen, wie wir das ja schon immer kennen. Und teilweise vom Netz getrieben, wie wir das mit dem ganzen Vodafone-Brending usw. hatten, jetzt sind es halt die Gerätehersteller. Das heißt, ein Android ist nicht wie das andere. Und damit steht der Hersteller dieser Geräte auch wiederum im Konflikt mit Google, die natürlich eher ein Interesse daran haben, dass diese Plattform als solche sich verbreitet. Aber wenn halt einfach die ganze Ausstattung und das ganze User-Interface dann detailangepasst wird von Firmen, die davon eigentlich gar nichts verstehen, das kann doch nur als Desaster enden.
Im Augenblick, glaube ich, hoffen die Firmen, sich dadurch von anderen abheben zu können. Sie sind das so gewöhnt von Windows-Mobile, dass sie Windows-Mobile-Geräte ohne eigene User-Interfaces überhaupt nicht verkaufen, weil die keine Sau bedienen kann. Also klatschen sie da ihre eigenen User-Interfaces drauf. Und sie können sich dadurch ein bisschen von der Konkurrenz abheben. Und das probieren sie jetzt bei Android auch. Ich meine, klar, wenn auf beiden Geräten dasselbe Betriebssystem läuft und die Geräte ja im Wesentlichen genauso aussehen, die gleichen Buttons haben und die sehen sich ja schon relativ ähnlich, diese einzelnen Telefone. Und dann hast du noch Akkulaufzeit-Unterschiede und so eine Späße. Aber wie kannst du dich abheben vom anderen Gerät? Du bietest eine Software drauf an, die die anderen nicht haben. Und ich bin gespannt, ob das funktioniert. Ob die Leute auf Dauer sagen, ich lege Wert darauf, unveränderte Android-Geräte zu haben. Zum Beispiel das Milestone ist ja eins. Das Motorola, das ist ja quasi ein Out-of-the-Box-Android und ist vielleicht auch gerade darum so extrem erfolgreich.
Ist es erfolgreich?
Also ich kenne mittlerweile vier oder fünf Droid-Besitzer.
Ja, nur weil wir jetzt ein paar Leute kennen, die ein Telefon haben, heißt das noch nicht, dass ein Gerät...
Die alle ex-Obitab glücklich sind. Also die wirklich sagen, es ist erfolgreich. Ich glaube, das verkauft sich... Ich kenne jetzt die Verkaufszahlen nicht auswendig, aber ich glaube, das verkauft sich auch sehr gut.
Ich dachte, du hättest da irgendwas.
Nö, hab ich nicht. Aber ich glaube, dass sich Android machen wird. Und das wird das iPhone nicht töten. Ich glaube, darum geht es auch gar nicht. Ich glaube nicht, dass sich bei Google irgendjemand hinsetzt und sagt, wir müssen das iPhone vom Markt verdrängen.
Naja, ich meine, wir reden ja hier über nichts anderes als über die Zukunft des Computing. Der Mobile-Markt ist einfach der Markt, der für die nächsten zehn Jahre einfach der entscheidende Markt ist. Der Desktop-Markt wird sich nicht mehr groß ändern. Da wird sich das irgendwie ein bisschen verschieben. Und da kann ich mir auch vorstellen, dass Apple da nochmal das eine oder andere Prozent gut macht.
Na doch, da kommt jetzt ein Riesenumschwung.
Okay, es ist spannend, das zu hören gleich. Aber ich sehe da ehrlich gesagt nicht im Ansatz so viel Bewegung wie im Mobilbereich. Im Mobilbereich werden die Leute sich jetzt einfach das Internet in die Tasche stecken. Und jetzt können wir ja gleich nochmal irgendwie auch über das Tablett reden. Aber das ist das, wo jetzt alle sich neu aufstellen und wo die alten Regeln des Desktop-Markts nicht mehr gelten. Sieht man allerdings schon daran, dass Microsofts Anteil derzeit an diesem Markt ist, wie sagt man, verschwindet. Dwindling. Niemand nennt Windows Mobile als Player. Vielleicht haben sie ja was Tolles in der Hinterhand. Ich hab da echte Zweifel. Es macht sich halt derzeit einfach eher zwischen dem iPhone und Android und vielleicht auch noch so ein bisschen dem Palm und keine Ahnung, was sich generell im webbasierten da noch so entwickelt. Da wird derzeit halt einfach das Ganze neu ausgewürfelt.
Ich glaube, das Palm-Prägel zwischen dem iPhone und dem Android, da gehen die so ein bisschen beiunter.
Genau, aber ich glaube auch, dass Android einfach nicht genug Momentum entwickelt, um gegen das iPhone nennenswert anzustehen. Ich meine, die werden sich auch verkaufen und so weiter. Die werden einfach ein Teil dieses Marktes sein. Das ist vollkommen unbestritten. Ich sage nicht, die gehen unter oder so. Soweit wird es nicht kommen.
Ich glaube schon, dass die ganz schön gut durchreiten. Ja, aber in einem anderen Preissegment auch.
Ja, aber sie werden einfach dem iPhone nicht nennenswert irgendwas entgegensetzen können. Weil die Leute sehen das einfach gar nicht.
Doch, zum Beispiel schon ein Vertrag nicht bei T-Mobile.
Das ist alles, was Apple problemlos nachliefern kann, wenn das wirklich mal entscheidend ist.
Ja, das können sie nachliefern, aber im Augenblick, wenn du nicht zu T-Mobile willst, kannst du, und du legst Wert auf Support.
Gut, aber es gibt nur noch zwei Länder auf diesem Planeten, wo es nur ein Podcast gibt.
Und es ist davon eins.
Ja, genau. Und das wird wahrscheinlich dieses Jahr auch enden, sage ich schon aus.
Kannst du denn dein Android benutzen, ohne irgendeinen Service von Google zu benutzen? Kannst du dich denn von dem provided von?
Ja, das geht. Also man kann das Nexus One komplett ohne Google benutzen. Das ist ja dieses With Google Modell. Und jetzt haben sie das erste Mal halt auch noch ihren Brand auf dieses Gerät gesteckt, was aber auch nur ein normales HTC-Gerät ist und was auch noch...
Also auch so Kontakte, Sync und so weiter, das funktioniert auch ohne Google.
Ja, ja, es gibt... Also bei den allerersten, bei Android 1.0 oder so, war es tatsächlich so, du konntest, wenn du kein Google-Account hast, konntest du das Gerät quasi nicht mal einschalten. Jetzt legen sie es dir natürlich nahe, dass du einen Google-Account hast, aber es gibt... Also zum einen gibt es auch von HTC schon Geräte, die dieses ganze Google-Syncing gar nicht... Ich weiß nicht, ob sie das einfach nur nicht mitbringen oder...
Mit wem synken die denn, wenn nicht mit Google?
Mit Exchange zum Beispiel. Und man kann eben über Plugins, kann man das nach Belieben erweitern, also es gibt einen Facebook-Sync, es gibt Exchange-Sync, es gibt alles.
Wenn man überhaupt eine Chance hat, mit seiner Exchange-Infrastruktur zu kommunizieren, das ist ja übrigens auch noch ein Problem von dem Nexus-One. Hab ich ganz vergessen.
Ach, dass sie im Augenblick noch das CG-Probleme haben. Ein bisschen. Dass sie irgendwelche Netzprobleme mit UMTS haben in Amerika.
Nee, sie haben einfach keine Krypto auf dem Telefon. Wie das iPhone 3GS.
Ach so, diesen Kryptochip. Ah, okay.
Genau. Und das Exchange schreibt halt vor, wenn das mobile Gerät nicht wirklich Krypto hat, dann darf es sich eben auch nicht entsprechend melden. Und die Policy bei vielen Companies ist halt, wenn du nicht Krypto hast auf dem Gerät, dann darfst du eben mit uns gar nicht reden. Und deswegen haben ja viele Leute dann auch mit dem 3G keine Freude gehabt, obwohl die Software, die das iPhone Update ja Exchange-Fähigkeiten gebracht hat, konnten sie aber trotzdem nicht an ihre Firmeninfrastruktur andocken, weil eben die Policy so war. Klar, wenn du deine Firma dazu bringst zu sagen, ach du, ich hab jetzt hier kein Krypto, schaltet das doch mal ab.
Ich frage mich, wie viele Firmen das tatsächlich eingeschaltet haben.
Ich glaube, das ist schon nennenswert. Ist auf jeden Fall auch noch so ein Ding. Ach so, was ich auch noch so richtig geil finde und wo ich auch sagen muss, dieses Nexus One ist ja der totale Fail, zumindest derzeit. Hast du das mitbekommen mit dem Speicher?
Das ist wirklich fair.
Das Ding hat 190 Megabyte Platz für Programme.
Für die Systempartition wahrscheinlich, oder?
Das hat halt Bild in nicht so viel, du kannst da SD-Card machen, aber du kannst auf die SD-Card keine Programme installieren.
Das ist bei Android so ausgesprochen.
190 MB, da hab ich iPhone-Programme, die sind größer. Oder Spiel. Da kannst du noch so viele Programme in deinem Android-Market haben, du kriegst sie einfach nicht installiert auf diesem Gerät, weil bei 190 MB ist Schluss.
Das kann man aber fixen mit Software, oder?
Ja, das geht.
Das ist aber schon lange so.
Das ist auch bei den Motorola-Droids, die haben 250 MB und dann hab ich mal so nachgeguckt, ich hab 2,5 Gigabyte Apps drauf, halt Spiele und so, die sind ja immer groß.
Aber war nicht beim iPhone, da sind da auch zwei Partitionen, waren nicht am Anfang die Programme auch irgendwie in der falschen oder irgendwie so, die Musik in der anderen? Irgendwas war doch da.
Ich glaube, das war nur bei Jailbreak-Apps, dass die auf der falschen Partition installiert worden sind.
Aber das ist wirklich ganz schön, das versteht man überhaupt nicht.
Dann packen sie halt die Apps noch auf die SD-Card. Ich meine, das ist ja nun kein Weltuntergang.
Geht aber nicht.
Wieso soll das nicht gehen? Weiß ich doch nicht, warum das nicht geht.
Dann bieten sie das. Das geht seit Anfang an.
Weil es ja nicht die Notwendigkeit existiert.
Weil es keine Programme dafür gibt.
Weil man nur relativ wenig 190-Megabyte-Programme hat.
Was? Ich hab da mehrere.
Die Spiele sind alle größer als 190.
Ich komm mal kurz. Ich glaub, das ist so.
Der Jump ist voll klein.
Monkey Island ist größer. Hier Myst ist größer.
Es geht ja auch nicht nur um ein Programm. Also ich hab tatsächlich kein einziges, was größer ist, aber hier so Need for Speed oder Worms, die fressen halt mal 100 MB. Also die ganzen Games sind alle so 30 bis 90. So, und die kannst du dann halt einfach da nicht groß installieren. Klar, die kleinen Tools sind alle nicht so groß. Das sind immer nur so ein paar hundert Kilobyte.
Aber wie viele Apps hast du gerade belebt?
Wie meint du das?
Wie viel MB in deinem...
Das zeigt doch nicht an.
Du meinst, was ich konkret installiert habe?
Also mein Mobile Applications-Folder hier...
1,5 Gigabyte hab ich da.
Ich hab nämlich eigentlich auch so viel.
Wo steht das denn?
Wobei ich jetzt nicht unbedingt alle wirklich bräuchte, sondern installiert habe, weil... Aber das ist ja auch dieses, man will die Programme dann ja auch haben, damit, falls man dann wirklich mal in die Verlegenheit kommt, sie zu testen, dass man sie dann auch testet. Also zu wenig Speicher haben ist nicht gut. Ich bin sehr froh, dass ich jetzt 32 Gigabyte habe. Und naja. Nun, wollen wir dieses Smartphone-Markt-Drama jetzt hier mal verlassen, das Thema, und auf zu neuen Welten gehen?
Aber das finde ich jetzt gerade ein bisschen merkwürdiges Ende sozusagen, dass Android keine Chance gegen das iPhone hat, weil die System-Partition 190 Gigabyte groß ist.
Nein, das habe ich jetzt nicht gesagt. Es sind halt mehrere Sachen, die derzeit noch ein Problem darstellen. Ich bin überhaupt gar nicht gegen Android. Ich habe nichts Einzuwenden dagegen, dass dieses Betriebssystem existiert. Allein schon deshalb, weil Apple einfach nennenswerte Konkurrenz braucht. Das ist extrem wichtig. Wenn wir so eine Monokultur haben, wo nur noch Apple auf dem Markt ist, das wird, glaube ich, keinem Spaß machen. Es wäre echt angemessen, dass noch mehr gute Sachen da sind. Das ist insofern auch sehr erfreulich zu sehen, dass Google ja auch jetzt ein paar Sachen bringt, wo Apple sich warm anziehen muss. Wo wir noch gar nicht drüber geredet haben, dieses neue Navi-System zum Beispiel, was sie da bringen. Keine Ahnung, Sprache kennen und so weiter. Dem messe ich jetzt nicht so viel Bedeutung bei. Aber auch wenn es losgeht mit Google Voice und wirklich so dieses flexible Routing und Voice over IP, da traue ich Google im Menü zu.
In einigen Interviews, die ich gelesen habe, ist der wesentliche Punkt, auf Android umzusteigen vom iPhone, weil Google Voice da funktioniert. Und weil es einfach geht und du installierst das, ist es dann, als ob du telefonieren würdest über deine normalen TV.
Das könnte definitiv so eine Killer-Up sein. Bloß, was ich meinte ist, die Gesamtattraktivität des iPhone-Marktes sowohl für die Kunden als auch für die Entwickler, dem steht mit Android derzeit noch nichts Gleichwertiges entgegen. Da gibt es einfach zu viele Probleme im Detail. Die Aufsplitterung der Hardware, der unklare Weg, wohin diese ganzen vielen Hersteller letzten Endes diese Plattform treiben werden, das ganze Update-Management und dann eben auch noch die Einschränkungen der Geräte in Bezug auf Installation von Programmen. Und das alles insgesamt macht es halt nicht attraktiver als jetzt den iPhone-Markt, der halt Make Money Fast verspricht und das ja auch für manche auch hält.
Ja, aber ich glaube, dass wir uns da irgendwann mal um... Zum einen ist es, ja, Apple könnte einen Haufen Features nachbilden, die könnten Google Sync machen, die könnten kostenlose Navigation machen, die könnten all das anbieten, was Android bietet und in vielen Fällen ja kein Dritthersteller bieten kann, weil Adressbuch-Synchronisation ist halt nur, das hängt halt an Apple oder gar nicht. Und Apple ist, was so gut wie sie im Software- und Hardware-Bereich sein mögen, so unglaublich schlecht sind sie, sobald irgendwas aufs Web geht. Da sind sie ja einfach, also Web-Service ist ja wirklich ihre totale Schwäche.
Ja, das ist ihre Euchillesferse.
Das sehe ich zum einen als großes Problem, dass diese Web-Services innerhalb kürzester Zeit unglaublich interessant sein werden und dass Google da gut vorliegen wird. Also ich meine, so dieses Google, wie hieß es? Google Goggle? Habt ihr das mal ausprobiert?
Ausprobiert hab ich es nicht. Du meinst hier dieses, irgendwie ich Kamera auf Realität halten und der Google sagt einem dann, ja das ist scary.
Das ist, und wenn ihr das mit Street View machen und du fotografierst eine Kneipe und ihr sagt alle Informationen dazu, dann wird das schon eine spannende Sache sein, glaube ich. Und ich hab's mal getestet, also es funktioniert natürlich noch nicht ansatzweise so gut, wie man es gerne hätte, aber es funktioniert weitaus besser als jede andere Lösung, die ich mit der Hinsicht gesehen habe. Also ich hab da irgendwie, saß auf dem Klo rum und hab dann eine Katzenstreutüte fotografiert und dann hat er mir sofort die Information zu diesem Katzenstreu rausgesucht. Das war wirklich so, ja. Und da hat er es bei Amazon gefunden und weiß der Teufel was.
Das ist das, was ich meine. Also sie haben wirklich diese Verquickung von ihren Netzdiensten und vor allem ihrem absurden Datenindex und dem Kleinen betrifft da.
Vielleicht haben sie gar keine Notwendigkeit für 190 Megabyte Systemprogrammpartition zu haben.
Na gut, aber trotzdem. Ihr Kernmarkt ist nach wie vor, Google verdient sein Geld mit Werbung. Und deswegen ist ihre ganze Strategie darin aufgelegt. Und ob diese Strategie für die Telefonhersteller, die ihr Geld mit Telefonen und den Providern, die ihr Geld mit Airtime verdienen, ob die aufgeht, das werden wir sehen. Also das ist auf jeden Fall...
Also man muss sagen, für Telefonhersteller ist Android ein interessantes Feld, weil sie billig an Betriebssystemen kommen, beziehungsweise für fast Nullkosten. Und die Telefonhersteller können auf jeden Fall mit Android Geld verdienen und werden darum Interesse haben, das auf den Markt zu pushen. Telekommunikationsanbieter haben es auch, weil in Deutschland jeder, also weil du nicht mit Apple verhandeln musst, sondern mit irgendeinem der vielen Telefonhersteller, wenn du dann ein Gerät haben möchtest von ihnen und dementsprechend die Preise drücken kannst, also lohnt es sich auch für Telefonhersteller auf Android ein Stück weit zu setzen. Und klar, die wollen dann immer noch ihre eigenen Services drauf haben, und das wird auch kommen, das wird auch ganz, ganz furchtbare Sachen geben, aber ich glaube, dass so, wer jetzt ein iPhone hat, der wird wahrscheinlich nicht zu Android wechseln oder sowas. Insofern glaube ich tatsächlich nicht, dass es irgendwie das Android der iPhone-Killer wird, aber es wird einfach so sein, dass die Leute, die im Augenblick noch einen Sony Ericsson haben, wo irgendwie ein eigenes Betriebssystem drauf ist oder so Nokia S40 oder meinetwegen auch ein S60 und gar nicht wissen, dass es ein Smartphone ist, dass die in zwei, drei Jahren, wenn dann ihr Vertrag ausläuft, irgendwie sagen, guck mal, ich hab hier so ein Telefon, damit kann ich jetzt auch im Internet surfen. Und das geht ganz toll und das wird dann Android sein.
Ich denke auch, Android ist nämlich der Nokia- und Windows-Mobile-Killer. Und als solche funktionieren sie auch ganz wunderbar und da sehen sie auch so ähnlich aus.
Und irgendwann auch mal anfangen, den iPhone-Marktanthal ein bisschen zu deckeln. Nicht zu töten oder sowas, aber der wird einfach da seine natürliche Grenze erreichen.
Von 85% auf 83% begrenzt werden.
Ich schätze mal so, mit viel Glück im Zweifelspreis.
Wir müssen ja jetzt gleich noch über das Tablett reden. Aber bevor wir das tun, sollten wir vielleicht noch mal kurz bei... Sind wir jetzt durch? Ich denke, wir können diese nichts Neues hinzufügen.
China?
Wo wir jetzt bei Google sind?
Mit Google?
Ja, Google ist jetzt wieder cool. Lies man? Dennis hier. Wie war das? Google ist evil oder nicht? Jetzt auch noch? Warum?
Na ja, das erinnert ja nichts. Haben sie halt eingefunden, der noch mehr evil ist als die?
Was ist eure Erkenntnis, was eigentlich passiert ist? Also ich hab ja wirklich die obskursen Sachen gehört, aber hab relativ wenig Zeit gehabt, dem selber hinterher zu recherchieren.
Also, das muss schon wirklich sehr, ich find das ja extrem komisch, weil da muss ja wirklich so wenig zu holen sein für die, also weder über ihr Standard-Such-Werbeeinblendung-Sonstwas-Modell noch über irgendwas anderes.
Was für weniges ist was?
Für Google.
Was in China? Da ist wenig zu holen.
Offensichtlich, also die ziehen sich doch nicht zurück, jetzt nur wegen so ein paar Hacker-Angriffen. Das kann mir doch keiner erzählen.
Also ich glaube, wenn da wenig zu holen wäre, dann wären sie da nicht hingegangen. Und ich denke, dass in China eine Menge zu holen ist, weil das ist da einfach mal das Land, was das Geld hat.
Also entweder hat die Regierung denen verboten, dass sie so viel Daten sammeln dürfen, wie sie brauchen, oder die Regierung hat gesagt, ihr dürft Daten sammeln, wir wollen die aber auch haben. Und zwar gebt mal her eure Technik. Und da hatten die wahrscheinlich keinen Bock.
Also es muss schon echt irgendwas ganz Fundamentales sein, dass die da irgendwie freiwillig diesen Markt räumen.
Na klar ist das was Fundamentales. China zwingt Google dazu, Informationen zu zensieren.
Das ist nicht der Grund, glaube ich.
Na ja.
Also denen ist der Scheiß egal.
Ja gut, aber du weißt auch, was Googles Selbstverständnis ist. Ja, wir sind nicht evil.
Was muss einer sagen, der evil ist, damit die Leute noch glauben?
Ich nehme diesen Brin und wie heißt der andere Vogel noch gleich? Den nehm ich das ab. Ja, ich glaube ernsthaft wirklich, dass sie das glauben.
Die wollen die Welt verbessern und dabei unglaublich reich werden, klar, natürlich.
Du kannst die tollsten Vorsätze haben. In dem Moment, wo du so einen 50.000 Mitarbeiterstamm hast, der quer über den ganzen Planeten verteilt ist und seine Eigendynamik entwickelt, da deine Grundsätze gerade zu halten, das ist nochmal eine ganz andere Geschichte.
Mit dem Mitarbeiterstamm ist das glaube ich das eine, aber mit dem Aktionär am Arsch.
Also ich habe einen Quot gelesen, wonach die Diskussion im Wesentlichen so lief, dass Brynn dagegen war überhaupt in China anzutreten und der Schmidt, der CEO, war dafür. Und es ist halt diese Diskussion mit, spielen wir mit und sind Teil der Veränderung oder machen wir Fundamentale oppositionen und sagen, ihr riecht nach Lulu und seid scheiße und deswegen ihr seid euch uns nicht westlich genug, was auch immer. So und wie das erst mal am Anfang gelaufen ist, das ist ja bekannt, sie sind da halt angetreten und seit dem Tag müssen sie sich halt vorwerfen lassen, zu Recht, dass sie das eben mitspielen. Und das ist natürlich immer diese Argumentation. Ja, gehst du jetzt zu den Schmuddelkindern? Versuchst du ihnen deine, naja doch, was Meinungsfreiheit und persönliche Freiheit betrifft, aus einer westlichen Perspektive heraus sind die Chinesen unter Garantie Schmuddelkinder.
Ich würde sagen, egal, das ist jetzt nicht so wichtig.
Ich will jetzt nicht das ganze Faschina aufmachen, aber die sind nicht ganz klar im Kopf.
Ne, ne, das wollte ich gar nicht bestreiten. Also ich kann mit dem Begriff Schmuddelkinder nicht so klar werden.
Ja, was auch immer. Die sind auf jeden Fall, sind die da irgendwie doch teilweise ein bisschen scheiße drauf. Und was halt da läuft, ich meine, die sind auch echt frech. Mittlerweile gehört ihnen die USA so geldmäßig. Und alle, die dort halt Business machen, müssen das nach ihren Regeln machen, werden aber massiv ausspioniert. Und das ist ja nun eigentlich auch der Auslöser der ganzen Geschichte gewesen. Und wenn ich es richtig, also wenn ich Wikileaks-Quellen trauen darf, das weiß ich nicht, ob ich das darf. Aber aus der Ecke habe ich halt gehört, dass die den halt teilweise in ihr Source Code Netzwerk eingebrochen. Die sind in den Source Code gegangen und wollten da irgendwelche Bots und Backdoors und was, was ich nicht noch installieren.
Und zwar...
Ich kann mir echt vorstellen, und dann bin ich auch gleich fertig mit meinem Monolog, da ist denen einfach mal schlecht geworden. Das ist einfach so, nee, also in China Business machen, da können wir vielleicht auch gerade noch mit leben. Aber wenn ihr irgendwie auch noch in unserem Source Code rumschreibt, jetzt seid ihr einfach einen Schritt zu weit gegangen.
Aber das können sie dann trotzdem noch machen.
Was können sie machen?
Da haben wir ja Server in der ganzen Welt. Also ich meine, das hin, also nur weil jetzt Google offiziell sagt, wir gehen jetzt aus China raus, hindert es die Chinesen nicht weiter, nicht daran, weiter irgendwie an ihren, an Google-Servern rumzuspielen und so.
Ja, ich glaube aber, dass sie deutlich schlechtere Karten haben in China. Na wieso sind sie... Also außerhalb von China.
Ich weiß gar nicht, sind sie nicht in die amerikanische Server eingebrochen?
Ich hab da keine konkreten Erkenntnisse.
Also was ich...
Das ist alles Spekulieren hier.
Also ich bin, ich sehe zwei Möglichkeiten. Also entweder ist es der best gesponnt, gespinte Marktausstieg, den ich jemals erlebt habe. Also sozusagen zu sagen, ach, scheiß auf China, gehen wir raus aus dem Markt, kann man natürlich nicht so sagen, dass man da jetzt aufgibt, weil man nicht genug Marktanteile hat und das dann so zu drehen, dass man das als Kampf für die Freiheit macht, obwohl man eigentlich nur nicht genug Kohle macht.
Was heißt denn nicht genug Kohle macht? Ich meine, die haben 30 Prozent des Suchmarktes. Das ist einfach mal deutlich.
Ich weiß aber nicht, wie viele Werbeeinnahmen dazu erwarten sind und davon leben sie bekanntermaßen.
Werbeeinnahmen, die sie heute nicht haben, die haben sie in fünf Jahren. Gut, das ist doch langfristig.
Wie gesagt, es sind doch für mich zwei Denkweisen. Die andere Variante ist, dass tatsächlich, so ähnlich wie du das sagst, dass es selbstverständlich bei Google unterschiedliche Kräfte gibt, die mal in der Richtung überhand gewinnen und mal in der Richtung überhand gewinnen. Es kann jetzt sein, dass einfach durch diese Einbrüche in die Google Server jetzt das eine fast zum Überlaufen gebracht worden ist und dadurch eben gesagt wird, okay, jetzt wir haben keinen Punkt mehr. Entweder wir können hier mal vernünftig arbeiten und das ein bisschen zu unseren Konditionen oder wir haben genug Geld verdient.
Es ist natürlich eine Business-Entscheidung. Die Business-Entscheidung ist, was ist uns mehr wert? Im China-Markt mitzumachen oder den moralischen Elfenbeintwurm, in dem wir uns in der westlichen Welt bewegen, zu gefährden. Und bisher war halt die Abwägung, oh, wir machen da mal ein bisschen mit, das wird schon so schlimm nicht werden. Aber wir wissen auch, in welchem Feuer Google seitdem steht. Microsoft und Yahoo und so weiter, denen macht das natürlich nichts aus, weil, ja, bei mal ja gleich, ach naja Gott, die sind halt ein bisschen scheiße drauf, aber da machen wir natürlich trotzdem mit. Klar, aber für Google ist das ja sozusagen ihr Hauptfähnchen, was hier in den Wind hängen. So, erstmal, wir stellen euch die Informationen der Welt bereit. Das geht halt in China nicht. Und dann eben so dieses nicht böse sein.
Naja, aber es ist ja tatsächlich, das finde ich das eigentlich interessante, wie du richtig sagtest, Googles Geschäftsmodell ist, Informationen zur Verfügung zu stellen. Und vielleicht ist das tatsächlich der eigentliche Punkt. Die müssen sich einfach, um ihren Profit zu max... Also Transparenz ist ihre Profit-Maximierungsstrategie. Je mehr Informationen sie irgendwie zur Verfügung stellen, desto besser geht es ihnen. Und während andere Firmen sagen, ja ja, wir können auch in China gute Geschäfte machen, ohne Transparenz und ohne Meinungsfreiheit. Und ist das für Google eigentlich nicht möglich? Weil ihr Geschäftsmodell darauf basiert, Informationen zur Verfügung zu stellen. Und sobald sie daran gehindert werden, haben sie kein Geschäft. Also man kann es natürlich einschränken und weiß ja teufel was, aber jetzt einfach mal extrem in diverse Richtungen gedacht.
Dennis, was denkst du denn darüber? Interessiert das überhaupt nicht mit China oder was?
Ne, China ist auch evil. Hat man auch schon bei Jack Power gesehen vor zwei, drei Jahren.
Wir decken das hier alles mit Spielfilmrealität ab. Ja gut, da kommen wir hier wohl nicht weiter. Dann müssen wir irgendwie zu unserem heiligen Thema kommen, würde ich sagen.
Kann ich mal kurz über mein XBMC-Experiment erzählen? Ach so, ich probier's schnell unterzubringen. Weil irgendjemand, ich glaube das war in der letzten Sendung, da hab ich von diesem Western Digital-Dingsbums da, von so einer kleinen Box, mit der ich zu Hause Filme gucken kann, erzählt, die ich so per HDMI an meinem Fernseher anschließe und war damit eigentlich ganz so okay zufrieden. Und hab dann in der Sendung erwähnt, dass ich...
Also XBMC ist dieses...
Da komm ich gleich drauf. Und hab dann in der Sendung erwähnt, dass ich ja eigentlich XBMC viel besser finde. XBMC ist so ein Media Center, das ich noch von der Xbox kenne und das der heiße Scheiß ist. Und dass das ja leider nicht mit diesen ganzen Iron-Atom-Prozessoren funktionieren würde. Und da hat sich dann jemand in den Kommentaren gemeldet und gesagt, Moment mal Max, deine Informationen sind total veraltet. Natürlich funktioniert XBMC schon seit Langem auch mit Iron-Chip-Sätzen und hat volle 1080p-Beschleunigung. Und das hab ich mir so durchgelesen und hab gedacht, ja, klingt schon toll und hab mir dann zu Weihnachten, konnte ich dem Druck nicht mehr standhalten, und hab mir dann so ein Acer Aspire Revo, heißt das Ding, gekauft. Das ist ein kleiner Kleinst-PC für 300 Euro. In Amerika gibt es die Dinger für knapp 200 Dollar mit ein bisschen weniger Speicher und ohne Festplatte. Und stattdessen ein Flash-Ship drin, hätte ich natürlich viel lieber gehabt, aber egal. Und vor allem ohne Windows. Und hab da jetzt so ein XBMC Linux drauf installiert. Und das ist total geil. Das ist wirklich, ich hatte am Anfang ein bisschen ein Problem mit dem Sound. Die sind allerdings durch googeln, Acer Aspire Revo XBMC Sound, leicht zu lösen. Und er schafft tatsächlich 1080p sehr flüssig abzuspielen. Also es ist super, also ich hab da mir ein paar Filme angeguckt. Man hat eigentlich kein 1080p Material, ich jedenfalls nicht. Also hab ich mir mal diesen Big Bunny, weil es den heißt, darunter geladen, diesen Open Source Film und hab mir den darauf angeguckt. Das läuft großartig. Und es hat halt ohne Ende Features. Also man kann auf die ZDF Mediathek zugreifen, wenn man dann unbedingt will. Man kann, es kann automatisch Filminformationen runterladen.
Das läuft bei dir auf einem?
Auf einem Linux PC quasi. Also es ist XBMC, gibt es als Mac-Programm.
Aber auf was für einem Linux PC?
Das erzähl ich sofort. Für Windows, für Ubuntu und als eigene Out of the Box Variante. Also lädst du dir eine CD-Image runter, brennst das auf CD, schließt die an, bootest von der und dann installierst du ein komplett frisches Linux, was ein Ubuntu ist, mit XBMC vorinstalliert und du hast alles out of the box und genau das, was du brauchst. Und dann hab ich mir noch irgendwie so eine Media Center Remote dazu gekauft. Das sind so diese für Windows Media Center, die Fernbedienung, die es überall für ab so 12 Euro gibt. Ich hab mir dann eine für 15 Euro geleistet. Mit der kriegt man das dann mit ein bisschen Arbeit auch sehr gut zum Laufen und ja, kann ich jedem empfehlen. Das war's schon.
Kann ich noch ein kleines Ding wieder nachschieben, weil ich hab hier gerade Atomboard gehört. Ich hab da schon vorhin erzählt, dass ich mir so ein Intel Atomboard für 80 Euro geschoppt hab mit so einem Atom 330-Chip, der hier meinen FreeBSD macht. Der verbrauchte noch relativ viel Strom, also relativ viel. Die CPU hat keinen Lüfter mehr, aber der Chipset, was du jetzt hier als Aion kennst, aber da war das ein nativer Intel-Chip-Set drauf, braucht das Chipset noch einen Kühler und einen Lüfter. Also hat nicht viel geholfen. Aber war schon eigentlich ganz cool, 45 Watt oder so. Dauerbetrieb mit zwei Platten. So, und jetzt gibt's irgendwie nach einem Jahr den Nachfolger. D510 MO ist nochmal 10 Watt weniger. Und jetzt ist irgendwie die Grafik und der ganze Chipset, mehr oder weniger, ist jetzt auch mit in die CPU reingewandert. Verbraucht jetzt auch keinen Strom mehr. Das heißt, ist jetzt nur noch passiv gekühlt, gar kein Lüfter mehr. Und ich bin voll happy, der Austausch hat irgendwie 5 Minuten gedauert. Also alle Kabel ab, das Board getauscht, neue Spercher umgesteckt, alles wieder ran gemacht, eingeschaltet und ging.
Und du hast dieses Board rumliegen ohne Gehäuse, ohne alles. Das liegt einfach so.
Ja, liegt auf meinem Küchenschrank oben. Und das Folge, ich hab das so eingeschaltet, muss man ja so einen Kurzschluss an, so zwei Pins machen, weil Taster und so hab ich ja alles nicht. Und dann dachte ich, Scheiße, geht ja gar nicht an und so. Ich denke, Mist, das hab ich irgendwie falsch gemacht. Und dann auf einmal hör ich, wie die Platten hochgehen. Weil ist ja kein Lüftermaler, man hört ja nicht mehr, dass das Ding angeht.
Hatte nicht mal den Peer-to-Ship drin, der dann kurz piept oder so was?
Nee, so was hat das Ding nicht. Da ist so ein Anschluss für eine LED, die dann leuchtet, wäre alles sauber, hatte ich das noch nicht. Das hatte ich noch nicht dran. Aber ist voll toll. Stromsparen macht voll Spaß, Leute. Kauft euch ein Strommessgerät, weil Strom wird demnächst sowieso. Also nächstes Jahr könnt ihr jetzt schon sagen, Prognose und so voll schwer. Das wird nicht mehr besser.
Benzin auch.
Ja, und so ein Strommessgerät kann man überall mal anschließen. Da kann man sehen, wo noch Strom zu sparen ist. Und ich finde, Stromsparen macht voll Spaß. Und mein Rechner verbraucht jetzt mal noch viel weniger als vorher.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich so Stromsparen. Das kann schon so ein...
Kleiner Nerdsport sein.
Ja, das ist echt. Das kann durchaus Spaß machen.
Ich habe auch nur noch höchste Energieeffizienzklasse-Geräte in der Küche und so.
Und ich pimpe ja demnächst meinen Stromkasten im Flur, weil ich habe so einen Flurschalter, wo ich habe vier Schalter und egal welchen man drückt, geht dann das Licht an. Es ist kein Schalter, sondern es ist ein Taster. Die unterscheiden ja da. Und da kann man kaufen so eine Art Hausflurschalter, wie im Hausflur, dass du das Licht anmachst und nach einer Weile geht es von alleine aus. Und dann kannst du dir so kleine Dinger kaufen von so einer Bude. Dann kannst du einstellen, nach welcher Zeit die dann wieder ausgehen sollen. Dann kannst du einstellen, zwei Minuten bis zwei Stunden. Und du kannst sogar mit Doppelklick, kannst es dauernd machen, dass es nicht ausgeht. Also voll den Spielkram und so. Du kannst voll deine Stromschalter zu Hause pippen.
Ist das verletzt dann, das ganze Zeug?
Nee, kannst du bei der Bude aber auch kaufen. Das ist dann per Funk und so. Aber so weit wollte ich ja nicht gehen. Ich will ja nur, dass mein Lichtimpflur auch mal von alleine ausgehen kann. Und vor allem, dass es nicht mehr so ein dickes, fettes Relais, Wasser schaltet, das jedes Mal irgendwie, wenn ich meinen Taster benutze, dass mein Atmel bootet, weil der Strom so doll wackelt, dass mein Netzteil an Schwierigkeiten kommt. Das ist ein bisschen schlimm. Das ist ein mechanisches Relais, was dann auch so rumflattert. Und der neue ist halt so ein elektronisches, der schaltet genau Null Durchgang von der Stromwelle. Also wenn gerade sowieso nichts ist, genau in dem Augenblick schaltet er an oder aus, sodass es ganz entspannt ein- und ausgeschaltet wird. Und da gibt es so elektronische Stromstoß-Schalter.
Aber wenn so dieser ganze Lichtschalterbereich irgendwann und Lampenbereich irgendwann dann doch nochmal mit dem Internet verbunden wird, ich glaube, dann wären da so geile Sachen abgeben.
IEPV6 Das brauchen wir dann auf jeden Fall.
Zum einen natürlich weltweites Blinking-Light, aber...
Aber die haben schon so Funk. Per Funk haben die schon. Das ist eine Steckdose. Die klebst du eigentlich mehr oder weniger nur noch an die Wand, weil die braucht ja nichts mehr. Dann drückst du, den Strom generiert, also den, was du zum Funken brauchst, generiert du durch das Drücken an sich, auch so mit Pizokram oder so. Und dann schaltet sie dir deine Geräte ein.
Ich sehe schon, es wird es nur fürs Android geben, aber nicht für iPhone. Eine Heizung, die automatisch angeht, sobald du nicht näher deiner Wohnung kommst.
Warum soll es nicht fürs iPhone gehen?
Weil das iPhone nicht rauskriegen kann, weil du kein App im Hintergrund laufen kannst und darum das nicht weißt, wo es ist.
Aber bevor wir gleich aufs Tablet kommen, hab ich gerade gesehen, Apple fordert Importverbot von Nokia-Geräten. Also als Retourkutsche für ihren Verkaufsstopp.
Das wird auf jeden Fall ein großer Spaß.
Nokia wird das noch so bereuen, dass sie irgendwie die Keule rausgeholt haben. Hätten einfach das Maul halten sollen. Das war echt nicht klug.
Was sind immer eigentlich für Patente verletzt worden? Das würde mich mal interessieren.
Na, irgendwas mit GSM, so richtig Standardkram.
Also im Kern ging es... Also es ist ein bisschen absurd, was Nokia da macht. Sie haben halt Apple verklagt, weil sie irgendwie von denen extra Geld haben wollten.
Sie wollten von Apple extra Geld haben?
Ja, sie haben halt...
Das sind ihre Pool-Patente, die in diesem GSM-Kram mit drin sind, die Apple halt genauso lizenziert wie alle anderen auch.
Ach, und sie wollten jetzt von Apple ein bisschen mehr Geld haben?
Ja, genau so. Und da hauen sie jetzt halt irgendwie drauf rum. Und jetzt hat Apple halt... Ich meine, das Ding ist, Apple hat eine ganze Menge Patente rund um diese ganze Telefongeschichte, von denen sie aber bisher noch kein einziges aus dem Sack geholt haben. Weil sie das nämlich nicht benutzen, um einen Angriffskrieg zu führen, sondern um sich verteidigen zu können, wenn irgendein Düssel wieder angelaufen kommt und von ihnen extra Kohle haben will. Und das ist halt jetzt irgendwie Nokia. Und das macht natürlich sehr den Eindruck, dass es so wirklich so, wenn du ihnen auf dem Markt nicht begegnen kannst, dann verklag sie, mäßig ist. Aber echt extrem. Und jetzt hat halt Apple irgendwie Patente rausgeholt, die aber, verstehst du, nicht in irgendeinem Pool sind, wo es wirklich um originäre User-Interfaces und keine Ahnung, wie man ein USB-Gerät, wie das Telefon sich über USB verhält. Und so Patente, wo wir uns auch alle an den Kopf hauen, dass es sowas überhaupt gibt. Aber so ist nochmal die Welt.
Und dass man Silent-Button drücken kann.
Sie haben irgendwie so ein Patent auf diesen Silent-Schalter zum Beispiel. Ja, die haben sie noch hier.
Es gibt da halt jeden möglichen Scheiß. Wir finden das alles total absurd. Aber wir wissen, so ist halt die Waffenlage. Und dieses Arsenal hat halt Apple jetzt irgendwie gezückt und haut halt jetzt richtig drauf. Und mich würde überhaupt nicht wundern, ich hab keine Ahnung, ich kann das rechtlich alles nicht bewerten, wie das so läuft. Aber ich erwarte eigentlich nichts anderes.
Die werden sich plus, minus, null irgendwie einigen und da werden ein, zwei, drei Hundert Millionen in irgendeine Richtung fließen. Vielleicht in Richtung Nokia, vielleicht in Richtung Apple. Kommt ja auch immer drauf an, Richter, Anwälte, Zeug und so. Weißt schon, wie die Lage gerade so ist.
Die Kohle ist Apple, glaube ich, ziemlich egal.
Ja klar.
Aber wenn die irgendwie Nokia daran hindern können, noch irgendeine Innovation abzufeuern, was eigentlich Quatsch ist, weil das wird da eh nicht stattfinden. Aber das wird denen nicht guttun. Das wird denen nicht guttun. Es ist noch 10 Tage hin, Jungs. 11.
Und sie haben es noch nicht announced, ne?
Keiner weiß überhaupt nichts, überhaupt nichts. Und alle rätseln nur und reden dummes Zeug. So sieht es nämlich aus. Es ist doch noch nicht mal dieser Termin bestätigt worden, oder? Zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt. Also es ist noch nicht mal klar, ob dieser Termin überhaupt stattfinden wird. Worüber reden wir dann überhaupt?
Aber alle großen haben sich schon rausgewagt, ne?
Ja, alle. Als gäbe es kein Tomorrow, so.
Ne, das ist, das hat, das hat, das ist... Das ist ein bisschen wie bei, wie bei... Wie hieß der? Men in Black damals, wo es immer diese ganzen, diese ganzen Boulevard-Blättchen sich gekauft haben, um die Informationen über die Agents abzugreifen. So dieses, das ist damals so wie beim iPhone, wo ich mich so dunkel sage, so oh jetzt, jetzt kommen da massenhaft Gerüchte, da ist doch eh nichts dran. Und diese, diese, diese Gerüchtezunahme, dass das so extrem viel in letzter Zeit wird.
Ein Klimax sozusagen.
Genau. Das, das ist für mich so der Anhaltspunkt, ah, da könnte vielleicht doch was dran sein.
Ja, den Anderen glaub ich auch. Also es verdichtet sich jetzt in einer Art, wie ich das zuletzt nur kurz vor dem iPhone, wie ich es gesehen habe. Stellt sie einfach die Frage, wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass dieser Termin tatsächlich stattfindet und wenn es nun wirklich etwas ist, was, ähm, wie Gruber sagt, wenn sie was vorstellen, oder war das Gruber, ich weiß nicht, auf jeden Fall dieses, wenn sie was vorstellen, stellen sie was Neues vor. Es geht nicht um ein neues MacBook, es geht nicht um ein neues was auch immer, sondern es geht... Sie könnten ja auch einfach iPhone OS 4.0 ankündigen, nicht wahr? Sie könnten sogar schon im Prinzip das nächste Telefon, naja, weiß ich nicht, wie ist denn das mit diesen FCC-Anmeldungen und so weiter? Das war ja am Anfang ihrer Ausrede, warum sie das iPhone so früh vorgestellt haben. Ich freu mich, warum das eigentlich für die Nachfolgeräte nicht gilt.
Weil Apple-Ausreden immer nur genau einmal gebraucht werden.
Ja, gut, das kann auch sein, was ich nicht... Tatsache ist, äh, sie haben auch das iPhone 3.0 Software-Update vorher bekannt gegeben, ein paar Monate. Man wusste schon etwa, was auf einen zukommt. Das könnte ich mir auch durchaus vorstellen, dass sie das mit dem 4.0 auch machen, warum auch immer. Also was auch immer ihre Motivation für den zusammen ist. Es kann aber auch sein, dass das eben auch alles zusammenhängt. Dass eben wirklich ein neues Gerät kommt, das auf iPhone OS basiert. Das natürlich dann quasi auf iPhone OS 4.0 basiert. Und was erstmal nur für dieses Gerät zum Einsatz kommt, aber wo dann absehbar ist, dass das dann eben auch auf dem iPhone selbst in irgendeiner Form eine Rolle spielt. Jetzt halt die Frage, was für ein Gerät ist das? Habt ihr da eine Meinung zum?
Na auf jeden Fall kein E-Ink-Gerät. Ihr könnt auf jeden Fall sagen, was das alles nicht ist.
Das ist gar nicht so schlecht. Also das glaub ich auch nicht. Also das ist kein E-Ink.
Das ist auch kein iSlate. Warum nicht? So heißen.
Achso, vom Namen her. Warum?
Na weil, so bekloppten Namen nimmt Apple einfach nicht. Also dazu kennen wir echt lange genug.
Warum ist der jetzt so bekloppt?
Weil man den mit iSlate irgendwie eher umlesen kann.
Der hat keinen Sexappeal.
Habt ihr noch mitbekommen, wie er angeblich der iMac heißen sollte damals, als Steve Jobs zurückkam?
Da gab es noch so ein Story.
Ich meine so viel zum Thema Sexappeal.
Ja aber das haben sie ja nun nicht gemacht.
Ist das bestätigt?
So bestätigt, wie man Apple sowas hatte, ist.
Aber es wurde schnell angenommen, weil es sprichte schnell i gerade angesagt.
Kann ich jetzt so für englische Native Speakers nicht so richtig bewerten?
Die nennen den eher TeamMac.
Also ich fand ja eigentlich...
Auf gar keinen Fall heißt ein Gerät, was kein Mac ist, Mac. Das wird nicht stattfinden. Das wird nicht stattfinden. Und wenn es kein Phone ist, wird es auch nicht Phone heißen. Und wenn es kein iPod ist...
Dann heißt es einfach Tablet.
Das soll bei einer wegschützen. Ja, das soll bei einer wegschützen. Inklusive Apple.
Ich fand ja eigentlich ganz schön die Idee, dass sie das einfach iBook wieder nennen.
Ist ja nicht zum Klappen.
Das ist aber ein Argument. Weil es würde ja dann zu sehr in diese Ich bin ein Buchlesegerät gehen.
Newton Xtreme.
Das werden sie auf keinen Fall tun.
Was ich auf jeden Fall glauben werde, was mit iPhone S40 sowieso kommen wird, und insofern können sie das relativ gut in entweder einem Tablet verstecken oder einen neuen iPhone verstecken, ist eine höhere Auflösung. Wer schon mal so einen Milestone in der Hand hat und da Google Maps offen gehabt hat, der wird sagen, wow, was ist das für eine wesentlich bessere Kartendarstellung als beim iPhone zum Beispiel. Und das wird auch Apple über kurz oder lang brauchen.
Macht das wirklich so viel aus?
Ja, das ist wie gedruckt.
Also auf jeden Fall das Display finde ich ja bei diesen hochauflösenden Android-Phones schon auch echt der Knall.
Ich hab bisher noch nie so den Grund gesehen, warum man die Auflösung noch unbedingt hochtreiben muss, aber das Karten sich besser darstellen lassen, das ist ein echtes Argument.
Ja, und das ist auch eine Sache.
Ja gut, aber im Text bin ich unzufrieden.
Wenn du auch Sachen drehst und so, wenn du mehr Auflösung hast, dann hast du weniger Rippeleffekt und so ein Schnickschnack. Das sieht einfach weicher aus. Kannst du mit höherer Auflösung rangehen.
Du bist mit Text nicht unzufrieden, aber du wirst es sein, nachdem du Text vernünftig auf so einem Gerät gelesen hast.
Antialysing hat mehr Spielraum.
Das ist schon geil. Das wird auf jeden Fall kommen. Apple kann sich das nicht erlauben, da auch noch mit der nächsten Generation die Display-Auflösung des Vorjahres zu haben.
Darüber müssen wir nicht reden. Ich glaube, das Gerät wird mit jeder Auflösung überzeugen oder nicht überzeugen, in Abhängigkeit von all den anderen Features, die es hat oder nicht.
Aber das iPhone OS wird auflösungsunabhängig werden. Insofern auch unabhängig von einem Tablet.
Ja gut, aber das beantwortet nicht die Kernfrage. Nämlich, was soll dieses Gerät? Also wir gehen jetzt einfach mal davon aus, Apple stellt irgendwas vor, was kein iPhone ist, was kein iPod ist und was kein Mac vorstellt. Das nehmen wir jetzt einfach mal so an, weil wir wissen es nicht. Und wir hängen genauso am Tropf der Gerüchteküche wie alle anderen auch. Also es widerstrebt uns, uns irgendwas zu äußern, was irgendwie unklar ist.
Aber die Sache ist ja die. Dass sie jetzt nur so einen reinen Textreader machen, ist uns ja allen klar, dass sie das nicht wollen. Sondern sie wollen ja sozusagen das Format von so einem Textreader vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen größer.
Du weißt, dass die Hörer jetzt mitschreiben und jede Voraussage, die wir machen, wird danach.
Dass ihr Grund warum der Termin noch nicht bestätigt ist. Sie wussten nicht, ob wir noch mal eine Sendung machen.
Also in einem Blog war halt ganz schön, war so eine Fotoserie, war das von diesem Typen, von panic.com, wo er so eine Fotoserie gesammelt hat, von Leuten mit einem Laptop in Situationen, wo man selber auch weiß, diese Situation und so, das ist total ungemütlich mit einem Notebook. Zum Beispiel im Bett liegen mit einem Notebook so auf dem Schoß und dann klappt das Display mal so ein bisschen runter oder irgendwie so diverse Situationen, wo so ein Notebook einfach nicht so ergonomisch das Richtige ist. Und die Überschrift war irgendwie von dem Blogpost, wofür brauchen wir jetzt ein Tablet? Und dann eben diese Serie von diesen Fotos mit ungemütlichen Positionen und praktischen Geschichten.
Hat er dann auch gleich irgendwie gesagt, wie das dann mit einem Tablet anders wäre? Weil das Problem bei diesem Tablet, die Kernproblematik, die ich sehe, bei den Benutzern, gehen wir mal davon aus, dass es jetzt wirklich nur so ein flaches Teil ist. Ich meine, das ist ja das, was alle erwarten. Wie hältst du das?
Ja, aber wenn du zum Beispiel auf dem Sofa lümmelst und so, also wenn es leicht und flach und sowieso ist, dann ist auch...
Ja, aber im Bett zum Beispiel, das ist ja noch schwerer zu halten als ein Laptop. Ein Laptop klappt dann zumindest schon mal den Bildschirm hoch. Das Teil müsstest du ja die ganze Zeit festhalten.
Oder auf den Knien ablegen.
Wie meinst du das?
Auf den Knien?
Dein Laptop liegt so da und steht von alleine, aber du musst auch festhalten.
Ein Laptop hält den Bildschirm in einer Position und du kannst das auch noch verändern.
Ja, aber warte, du hältst doch dein Laptop fest oder nicht? Wie benutzt du denn dein Rechner im Bett?
Oder zum Beispiel, weißt du...
Abgesehen davon, dass ich das nicht mehr tue.
Weil es nicht so praktisch ist.
Ich benutze nur mein iPhone im Bett, wenn diese blöde Auto-Rotate nicht den Spaß...
Genau, das ist Punkt Nummer eins. Dein Notebook ist halt meistens immer so horizontal. Du kannst halt, wenn du deinen Kopf drehst und so weiter... Aber so ein Tablet hat halt schon irgendwie noch ein bisschen mehr Freiraum.
Also, ich sehe das Tablet ja irgendwie, dass ich nach Hause komme. Ich nehme das Ding, das liegt so auf dem Tisch. Ich nehme das so, klicke, das geht irgendwie an. Das ist auch kein Security-Device. Also, okay, hier kann man bestimmt auch noch drauf machen. Aber es ist so... Kein Security-Device? Nein, mein iPhone ist immer gelockt. So ein Ding ist halt, das liegt so da. Ich schnapp das so, gucke, klick auf irgendeinem TV-Bett. Was kommt denn gerade so? Zum Beispiel... Also, ich hab gar keinen... Doch, ich mein, ich hab noch ein Fernseher. Hab ich? Ich hab keinen. Jedenfalls, alle Leute klicken dann so, was am Fernsehen läuft, gucken und dann so, ach ja, nee, und schmeißen das Ding wieder auf die Couch. Weißt du, du machst da nicht so wirklich ernsthafte Sachen mit, aber schon so viel Kleinkram. Schnell mal twittern, schnell mal chatten, alles nur so schnell, schnell, schnell. Nichts arbeiten, nichts Profimäßiges.
Aber auch lesen, wer...
Twittern ist nicht ernsthaft, oder was? Twitterst du nicht ernsthaft? Du hast auch schon mal ernsthaft getwittert.
Ja, aber ich finde, das war schlecht.
Ich habe es gerade gefunden hier, diesen Blog-Post, das war ein Pathfinder-Blog. Ich halte es mal kurz rum. So, diese ganzen Situationen, wo sozusagen jetzt hier...
Brauchen wir den großen Bildschirm, ne?
Irgendwie dieses Ganze mal eben in der Hand, so wie ich jetzt hier auch gerade, wenn ich ein Tablet hätte, die könnte ich einfach so...
Stimmt, dann könnte man das einfach so hochhalten.
So, und dann halt hier so diese ganzen... oder hier, genau, das meine ich halt so mit im Bett oder auf dem Sofa, also das mit dem Notebook einfach immer...
Genau, genau, so, so.
Ja, aber wie willst du denn das mit dem Slate machen?
Dann legst du es einfach auf den Beinen ab oder so.
Ne, man legt sie ja, aber man hält sie mit einer Hand fest.
Oder hier irgendwie diese Position, wo dann halt immer so davor hockst und dann halt nicht irgendwie direkt...
Dann hat ja gar nichts an.
Aber wollen wir das Ganze mal von der anderen Seite aufziehen? Das mag ich nicht viel besser finden.
Na ja, du kannst das ja gleich machen, aber ich finde, das ist für mich die Hauptfrage, wie benutzt man das und wie stellt man das Ding auf? Weil wenn ich jetzt hier am Tisch sitze... Dann lässt du einfach vorne liegen. Na, und dann wenn ich ein bisschen zurückgehen will und mir einen Film angucken will, was mach ich dann? Guck ich dann die ganze Zeit auf... Ich brauch mich damit keinen Film an. Ich hab keinen Fernseher.
Nein, weil ich den geklaut hab.
Ich hab keinen Fernseher.
Ich hab einen Doc für, guck mal.
Du hast halt hier auch... Genau, du gibst einen Doc. Oder du hast hier auch einen Podest für dein Notebook sogar.
Oder ist es wie beim Bilderrahmen.
Ich hab einen Podest für mein Notebook, weil...
Weil? Weil es so unbequem ist, wenn du die ganze Zeit so da sitzt.
Weil es mir zu niedrig ist. Ja. Und das wäre bei dem Slate noch ein viel größeres Problem.
Das heißt nicht Slate.
Aber das sollst du ja auch nicht am Schreibtisch verwenden.
Willst du auch eine Kiste Marte wetten?
Was?
Worauf?
Auf Slate.
Auf den Namen?
Also ich denke, dass sie bei dem Namen irgendwie mehr das reinstecken, als was sie es gedacht haben, wie man es verwendet.
Ja, genau, das ist der Ansatz, den ich gerne mal haben würde.
Das ist der Telefon, der Pod ist dieser Ort, wo deine Daten drin sind. Ich will es ja nicht mateen.
Ich würde das Ganze mal ein bisschen umdrehen. Bei jedem Gerät, was Apple in den letzten Jahren rausgebracht hat, war es so, dass es eigentlich einen Markt dazu gab. Beim Ipod ist dann irgendwann dieser iTunes-Markt, wo man Musik kaufen konnte.
Bei Apple 3-Player gab es schon, und dann kam Apple mit dem Ipod. Genau, das hat dann noch ein bisschen gedacht. Dann kamen die iPhone zusätzlich rein.
Beim Iphone war genau das gleiche, kann das Iphone, da war der App Store die große Revolution. Also es war immer so, da bietet sich ein Markt an, und dann war das eigentlich das Gerät dazu.
Und die eigentliche Revolution war immer der Store.
Genau. Und ich glaube, dass das, was uns erwarten wird mit diesem entsprechenden Gerät, ist, dass der News-Industrie, also den Zeitungsindustrie, das bevorsteht, was die Musikindustrie damals mit dem iTunes-Store durchmachen musste. Und ich glaube, es wird ein Gerät sein, um Nachrichten zu lesen, um sich zu informieren.
Aber ich glaube gar nicht mal, dass es die Verlagsindustrie ist mit Büchern, sondern mehr so die News-Industrie.
Ja, genau, Zeitungsverlagsindustrie. Also ich weiß nicht, ob man Bücher unbedingt darauf lesen wird. Das wird vielleicht...
Aber ich könnte es mir vorstellen, weil ich finde halt diese ganzen E-Ink-Reader total unbrauchbar. Also das geht halt nicht, da drauf was zu lesen.
Also ich habe noch nie was probiert, darauf zu lesen, aber einfach nur so, ich glaube, da ist der Markt auch einfach nicht groß genug. Aber Nachrichten lesen, Zeitungen lesen, das machen doch nach wie vor extrem viele Leute und es ist ein Markt...
Der Markt ist da. Also die Amazon-Jungs verkaufen ja von ihrem Kindle gar nicht schlecht. Und irgendwie, ich will auch...
Woher weißt du das?
Es gibt keine Zahlen. Gut, okay, dann verlassen wir diese Spekulation direkt wieder. Aber ich persönlich, also eigentlich will jeder das digitale Buch haben, nur gibt es halt, also die Reader, die es gibt, die sind halt scheiße. Man will ja nicht dieses beim Seite umblättern erst mal drei Sekunden warten, dass an der Bildschirme zweimal flackert. Dann siehst du immer noch Schatten von der alten Seite, alles in schwarz-weiß und zu kleine Screens, dass du auf einer Seite auch noch scrollen müsstest, die Auflösung ist zu schlecht und was nicht noch alles.
Ein Haufen Macen, die das erste Apple-Gerät in der Richtung auch haben wird.
Das glaube ich eben nicht. Ich glaube, dass wenn sie da in diesem Bereich irgendwie das besser machen wollen, dass sie das auch hinkriegen.
Ich glaube, dass das eher so sein wird, dass sie sich das Konzept, wie präsentiert man Nachrichten oder Informationen, dass sie das ein bisschen überdenken werden. Also dass es nicht so darum geht, wirklich Romane auf dem Teil zu lesen, sondern dass es, wie kann man das Konzept Zeitung im digitalen Zeitalter weiterentwickeln? Nämlich, klar, man wird daraus Filme gucken können, aber eben nicht zwei Stunden lange Spielfilme, sondern eher so 20-Sekunden-Clips, die so reingeschnitten werden. Es wird natürlich unglaublich attraktiv für die Werbeindustrie sein, weil sie animierte Werbeschale reinpacken. Es wird selbstverständlich keinen Flash haben, sondern stattdessen irgendwas mit SVG oder ähnlichen Vorgehen oder mit QuickTime. Und es wird ein Gerät sein, mit dem ich perfekt meine Nachrichten konsumieren kann.
Das ist alles das, was man schnell immer am Rechner machen will, aber eigentlich gar keine Tastatur für braucht?
Ja, also ich glaube, das ist schon ein Teil auf jeden Fall. So dieses News, RSS, Twitter, Fuba, Facebook, was nicht noch alles, so dein Social Network Media Aggregation Terminal. Aber Bücher lesen dann bestimmt auch und dann warum nicht auch Spielfilme da drauf gucken, wenn du das wie Dennis hast so in Stock pfrumpfst und dann aus dem iTunes Store mal eben eine neue Lost-Folge ziehst und so. Warum sollst du nicht da drauf gucken? Brauchst auch keine Tastatur für.
Ja, also ich denke, ich denke auch, es ist eigentlich das, was du mit deinem Computer machst, abzüglich des Creations. Also das Erzeugen ist eigentlich so das wesentliche Merkmal des richtigen Computers, wozu du ein iMac machst. Wenn du viele Texte schreibst, wenn du Bilder machst, wenn du Musik machst, wenn du irgendwelche Dinge erzeugst und den Computern.
Productivity Work ist irgendwie nicht mehr zum Tablet.
Genau. Aber alles andere, was so dieses Brausen, Konsumieren, Lesen, Chatten, Kommunizieren, Facebook, Twitter, in Verbindungen bleiben, Medienkonsum, aber auch ganz klar Musik, vor allem natürlich dann auch Filme, dafür hätte ich auch gerne was transportableres. Ich hatte ja, als wir schon über das Tablet vor Wochen und Monaten geredet haben, war ja immer auch so meine Kernfrage, wo steht dieses Ding zwischen dem Computer und dem Telefon? Weil in dem Moment, wo ich das iPhone hatte und angefangen habe, regelmäßig zu benutzen, fiel mir auf, dass ich meinen Laptop nicht mehr mitnehme. Früher, also vor drei, vier Jahren, war das vollkommen undenkbarer Zustand, dass du mich irgendwo auf der Straße antrifft und ich habe keinen Rechner dabei. Das wäre einfach keine Ahnung, das ist seit sehr langer Zeit schon so und das hat so vor drei Jahren so langsam versiegt und mit dem iPhone war dann das Ende irgendwie erreicht. Und das, obwohl die Connectivity viel besser war und irgendwie UMTS und Pipapo und so weiter und Internet wurde auf einmal bezahlbar. Aber der Bedarf nur für diesen Mobilkonsum, der nämlich im Wesentlichen Lesen und Kommunizieren ist, dafür den ganzen Rechner mitzunehmen, das fiel dann irgendwie weg. Das hat das iPhone irgendwie ersetzt. Trotzdem ist es so, manchmal ist mir dieses iPhone dann eben auch nicht genug. Wenn ich zum Beispiel Webseiten wirklich lesen will, da wäre es schon mal besser, wenn da mehr Platz ist. Also irgendwie für Twitter zum Beispiel finde ich es perfekt. Also Twitter mit dem iPhone, keine Fragen. Also da ist der Mac...
In Geschichtsbüchern wird stehen, dass Twitter erfunden wurde, um auf dem iPhone zu funktionieren.
Und jetzt stellt sich einfach die Frage, ist das ein Markt? Ist das der Markt der Leute, die eigentlich mit dem Computer überhaupt nichts erzeugen wollen und nicht so die Schreiber sind und nicht mit Office arbeiten wollen, sondern die eigentlich an dem Internet spielerisch, konsumierend, aber nicht unbedingt passiv teilnehmen, sondern schon auch aktiv drin sind, aber eben aktiv in der Kommunikation stecken, aktiv in so einem Flow...
Das wäre zum Beispiel ein Gerät, was ich meiner Oma auch schenken würde.
Genau, da wird es nämlich interessant. Leute, die sich keinen Mac kaufen würden, die aber das, was sie tun wollen, eigentlich mit dem Telefon nicht tun können. Das könnte dieser neue Markt sein, den sie dort adressieren. Und das würde dann aber auch ein Preispunkt, der diskutiert wird um die 1000 Dollar. Ja, was ja nicht wenig ist. Ja gut, aber die Frage ist, wenn jemand noch gar keinen Computer hat.
Also wenn alles...
Keinen hat oder einen hat, aber den nicht richtig benutzt, weil der eben nicht mobil genug ist. Weil auch ein Laptop dann nicht mobil genug ist. Weil das einfach zu viel ist. Zu viel, das steckt man sich nicht mal eben noch in die Tasche.
Aber Leute, die noch gar keinen Computer haben, ich glaube, die interessieren sich auch für so ein Gerät nicht. Also wer heutzutage noch keinen Computer hat...
Also meine Oma würde ich so ein Ding einfach aufdrücken, egal, ob sie den will oder nicht.
Alle werden irgendwann einen Computer benutzen. Die Frage ist, sind die Geräte schon so weit, dass sie auch wirklich gewollt werden? Und das wäre halt eine interessante Lücke, die dort geschlossen wird, weil die Leute wollen ja kommunizieren.
Aber ich glaube, es ist für Apple erstmal wesentlich einfacher, den schon bestehenden Markt der Apple Fanboys abzugrasen, als Leute, die noch nicht mal wissen, dass Apple überhaupt existiert.
So viel Fanboys gibt's nicht.
Naja, ich meinte jetzt auch nicht uns fünf hier in dieser Runde, sondern ich meinte...
Uns fünf?
Naja, so als Apple Fanboys jetzt mal so bezeichnet.
Das sind aber vier, oder?
Du hast recht. Oh Gott, ich hätte heute Nacht nicht mehr schlafen sollen. Sondern dass es darum geht... Leute, die sich ein iPhone kaufen, kaufen sich das auch nicht in erster Linie, weil sie kein Computer haben, oder weil sie vorher kein Handy haben, sondern weil sie dachten, wow, das ist ein geiles Gerät, das will ich haben. Ich glaube nicht, dass das iPhone sich ein Gerät ist, was für Leute...
Du kannst dein iPhone gar nicht kaufen, wenn du kein Computer hast, weil du das dann nicht befüllen und konfigurieren und in Betrieb nehmen kannst.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es viele Leute gab, die vorher gesagt haben, wow, bisher hatte ich kein Telefon, weil ich keinen Bedarf zum Telefonieren hatte, aber jetzt, wo das Gerät auch das und das kann, da nutze ich das dann plötzlich. Ich glaube, so ähnlich wäre es denn mit so einem Tablet auch. Dass es sich eher an Leute wendet, die wie wir schon einen MacBook haben oder eben irgendeinen anderen PC oder Laptop, die schon selbstverständlich ein eigentlich ziemlich gutes Telefon haben, aber eben so ein bisschen diese Lücke dazu sind.
Aber guck mal hier, beim Phone wirst du natürlich irgendwie einen Computer brauchen, um deine Kontakte und sonst was zu sünden, aber prinzipiell, wenn du jetzt ein Konsumenten-Gerät hast, einen Music-Store, einen Videostore, einen App-Store und so, den hast du ja hier drauf. Also dafür brauchst du jetzt ja sozusagen deinen Mac nicht. Und wenn du sozusagen auf deinem Tablet dann auch einen angepassten Store hast, um noch einfacher, noch schöner und noch mehr deine ganzen Magazine, Bücher, Musikfiles, Filme und sonst was da zu klicken, brauchst du, also wofür brauchst du da einen?
Ich sage nicht, dass du einen brauchst. Ich glaube, es verändert sich einfach an eine Zügegruppe, die trotzdem einen Computer haben.
Ja, das auf jeden Fall.
Weil noch genug abfällt.
Und hier eben, wie gesagt, ich würde halt diese E-Ink-Fraktion gar nicht unterschätzen. Ich meine, so viele Geräte, wie da rauskommen und so viele Leute, die auch zum Beispiel für die, also es gibt ja, ich sehe da schon eine größere Nachfrage, bloß ich sehe halt noch keine Geräte, die wirklich das Problem gut gelöst haben, so Bücher oder Sachen digital zu lesen. Ich hab das schon mehrfach probiert. Auf dem Rechner finde ich es total ätzend, so mit einem Notebook unterwegs mal irgendein Buch oder sowas zu lesen und diese E-Ink-Reader, wie gesagt, finde ich halt auch alle total suboptimal. Und wenn sie das dann auch sozusagen noch mit einbauen und dieses E-Pop-Format und so, also weißt du, wenn sie sozusagen einen eigenen Viewer für diese E-Pop oder wie heißt das Format? Heißt auch so, oder? Ja, E-Pop. Und so mit einbauen und liefern und eben auch sagen, hier, ihr alle, die da so heiß auf digital Bücher seid, ihr könnt jetzt dieses Tablet dann auch noch gleich mit benutzen, dann holen sie da, glaube ich, auch schon eine ganze Menge Leute ab. Weil, weiß nicht, also wie gesagt, so diese... Das ist halt, also da würde ich auf jeden Fall eine Chance sehen, dass Apple da nochmal richtig punkten kann, indem sie das, was jetzt so alle anderen so versucht haben, einfach mal mit ein bisschen nachdenken, vielleicht ein bisschen innovativer Ansatz nochmal schöner lösen und...
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob diese Zeitungsgerichte wirklich originär was mit dem Tablett zu tun haben. Oder ob das nicht einfach nur so eine Geschichte ist, die mit iTunes zusammenhängt. Dass das einfach ein Content ist, den sie da auch noch in wohl definierten Formaten reinbringen. Wohl wissen, dass diese Formate wie E-Pop und so weiter alle extrem beschränkt sind.
Sie werden ein Gerät haben wollen, auf dem du es abspielen kannst?
Ja, das kannst du aber dann auf dem MacBook auch abspielen. Das ist jetzt nicht das Ding, dass es nicht geht.
Das heißt ja nicht, dass man die Musik aus dem iTunes-Store nicht auch auf dem MacBook abspielen kann. Aber es gibt ein Gerät, was dafür gemacht ist, um diese Musik abzuspielen. Das war der iPod.
Aber ich sag nur, es muss nicht zwingend damit zu tun haben. Es könnte auch sein, dass dieses Tablett nie kommt und dass sie trotzdem anfangen, Print-Content über iTunes zu verkaufen.
Ich glaube eher, dass der Weg tendenziell umgekehrt sein wird, dass zuerst das Gerät kommt und danach überhaupt erst der Markt.
Ich glaube einfach nicht, dass diese Zeitungen da so eine große Rolle spielen. Ich glaube, dieses Gerät muss einfach interessant sein für Leute, die das tun, was sie jetzt auch schon tun. Da kommt nicht was komplett Neues, sondern wollen sie dieses Gerät kaufen. Es ist ein Angebot für die Leute, die jetzt schon das Internet benutzen wollen und es sind im Wesentlichen diese Facebook- und Twitter-Generationen. Leute, die kommunizieren wollen. Das sind, wie wir alle wissen, sehr, sehr viele. Und es sind auch ganz Ordinary People, die da irgendwie im Facebook rummarschieren. Und die wollen ein Gerät haben, was sie immer mitnehmen können. Wir sind ja auch nur Männer, jetzt denken wir ein bisschen über Frauen nach. Du musst das noch mal ein bisschen über Frauen nachdenken. Weder sie jetzt großer Fan von Hosentaschen, wir stecken ja unser iPhone immer gleich in die Hosentasche und so.
Dann setze ich mich ja drauf, das ist kaputt. Wer war das? Warst du das nicht?
Ich war das.
Wer siehst du?
Du steckst so was in deine Handtasche.
Hier an der Seite oder hier oben?
Ja gut, aber du hast so Taschen. Das ist bei Frauen gar nicht angesagt. Da hat die Hose keine Taschen. Oder noch nicht mal das. Sondern das Ding ist wo? Wo ist das Telefon? In der Handtasche. Genau.
Aber auch nicht bei jeder Frau.
Ich weiß, das ist jetzt ein ganz schwieriges Pflaster. Aber du weißt, worauf ich hinausfälle. Es gibt Leute, die tragen diese Devices auch anders mit sich herum. Da gibt es aber dieses Modell Handtasche. Das heißt, während das iPhone, wo hat Steve Jobs das rausgezogen? Aus der Jeans-Gesichtasse. Das war sozusagen das Ding.
Ich freue mich schon drauf, wenn Steve Jobs mit der Handtasche auf die Bühne kommt.
Ich habe euch was mitgebracht. Ja gut, kann ja sein.
Nehme ich Kargohose.
Gehen wir noch mal von dieser Portabilität aus. Derzeit denken wir, mobil Computer mitnehmen, was ist das? Da gehst du hier irgendwie Axio und kaufst ja irgendwie dicke, fette Rechner-Tasche mit noch mal doppelsoften Cushion-Umwandlungen. Und so, wenn das Ding dann irgendwie runterfällt oder vom Motorrad fällst, dass dein Teil überlebt. Das machen einfach die meisten Leute nicht, sondern die haben halt ein Taschen dabei. Handtaschen gibt es in allen Formen und Farben. Aber was ist jetzt gerade im Gespräch? 10 Zoll. Wie groß ist das? 10 Zoll ist 25 Zentimeter Diagonale. Ich ziehe hier immer meinen Dings raus, nehme meine Wireless-Tastatur. Ich habe hier diese Wireless-Tastatur. Das ist 10 Zoll.
Von einer Ecke zu anderen, ja?
Also es wird ja ein bisschen breiter sein.
Also 10 Zoll sind 25. 4, das ist sozusagen...
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass es so groß ist.
Da ist noch ein bisschen Rand drum herum. Aber nur mal jetzt so von der Größenordnung. Das heißt, so wie diese Wireless-Tastatur ist, so wäre so 10 Zoll. Das ist schon relativ viel.
Naja, aber wenn das ein bisschen...
Aber das könnte schon noch in mehr Taschen reinpassen als andere. Ich könnte mir auch noch ein bisschen kleiner das vorstellen.
Aber ich will nicht so klein, ich will groß.
Aber das ist im Vergleich zum iPhone.
Ja, aber...
Ist das groß?
Aber hast du diesen Texte schon mal in der Hand gehabt?
Den E-Book-Reader? Ja, den hab ich in der Hand gehabt.
Und war der dir von der Größe angenehm? Also ich fand den zum Beispiel viel zu klein.
Um was damit zu tun? Um zu lesen?
Ja, da musst du ja dauernd scrollen.
Ja, finde ich auch. Ich bin auch überhaupt kein Freund von diesen E-Books. Ich glaube nicht, dass das was wird. Ich glaube einfach, dass der Markt dafür zu klein ist. Der Trend geht hin in generic devices und das iPhone zeigt eigentlich auf, was es ist. Die Leute wollen einfach kommunizieren. Große Frage bei diesem Tablett ist für mich auch, was für Kommunikationselemente sind da drin? Ich meine, das wird sicherlich Bluetooth haben. Das ist vielleicht die einzige Technik, die ich als Gesetz sehen möchte und WLAN auch noch. Die Frage ist, hat es auch Ethernet, UMTS?
Also ich glaube, dass es eher UMTS haben wird als Bluetooth. Es wird einen USB-Anschluss haben. Vielleicht sogar nur, wahrscheinlich sogar den hier. So ein Dock-Connector zum Sinken. Bestimmt. Es wird WLAN haben und darüber hinaus vielleicht noch UMTS. Doch, Bluetooth.
Aber wer es UMTS hat? Heißt das, dass es dann so verkauft wird wie ein iPhone? Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Nein. Nein, nein, nein.
Apple ja nicht so richtig heiß drauf, irgendwie in andere Geräte, so GSM und so Zeug einzubringen.
Ja, aber dass sie ein Gerät mit SIM-Kartenslot verkaufen, ohne einem die SIM-Karte dazu zu verkaufen, das passt irgendwie auch nicht. Andererseits hat dieses Gerät überhaupt den Wert, den man haben will. Setzen sie dann voll auf Tethering, was es derzeit noch nicht mal in den USA gibt, trotz Ankündigung, kann ich mir auch nicht vorstellen.
Oder sie verzichten auf den UMTS-Slot und sagen einfach, das ist ein Gerät für zu Hause. Weil das ist eh viel zu groß, um es mit sich herumzuschleppen.
Ja, aber zu Hause kann ich dann aber auch einen Laptop auf den Tisch stellen. Der hält dann wenigstens den Bildschirm automatisch.
Und das ist jetzt auch mehr so ein Gerät, es ist egal, wer es benutzt.
Das ist ja auch ein Sofaschmeißen.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Haushaltsgerät, das für den gesamten Haushalt da ist. Es hat nicht jeder so einen eigenen. Wo ist denn gerade der...
Na ja, das ist so, wie früher die Fernbedienung in der Sofaritze gesucht wurde.
Ja, genau. Das Ice-Late wird die neue Fernbedienung sein. Genau das seh ich auch so.
Aber es war sich auch noch...
Man kauft sich doch keine Fernbedienung für 800 Euro.
Erst mal hast du gesehen, was diese Logitech-Harmony-Fernbedienung kostet. Na ja, die sind so 150 Euro. Die können wirklich nur eine Fernbedienung sein.
150 Euro?
150 Euro, ja, das ist absurd. Aber ein Gerät um nebenbei... Ich komme nach einem harten Arbeitstag nach Hause. Dann esse ich was und gucke mir ein bisschen irgendwelche Serien an oder so was. Dann setze ich mich auf die Couch oder leg mich auf die Couch, gucke mir das ganze Zeug an und kann mir vorstellen, nebenbei noch ein bisschen rum zu surfen. Das mache ich öfters auch mit meinem MacBook.
Der Mensch ist zu faul, zum Klicken, zum Maus benutzen zu machen. Der will, wir wollen Touch.
Das müsste irgendwie easy sein. Aber das könnte ruhig ein bisschen...
Was macht man, wenn man kaputt nach Hause kommt, man schaltet den Rechner nicht mehr ein? Aber was macht man, weil man ja doch voll abhängig und süchtig ist? Man zölft doch noch ein bisschen auf dem iPhone. Man will nicht mehr... Man hat keinen Bock mehr, irgendwie was Großes zu starten oder so.
Man will nicht mehr den Arbeitsframe haben, sondern möchte den Rest haben. Das iPhone ist dafür zu langsam und hat ein zu kleines Display und kann keine Taps machen.
Aber das iPhone kannst du mit einer Hand halten. Und dieses iSlate... Wie soll ich es denn sonst nennen?
Wie nennst du iSlate jetzt?
iView wurde vorgeschlagen.
Wie auch immer, dieses Teil...
Bisher fällt mir ehrlich gesagt iSlate noch am besten.
Das heißt das iFoo, weil wir sich selber auch auf nichts einigen können.
Vielleicht heißt es ja auch iSteaf.
Okay, jetzt ist es durch.
Ich wollte ja mal sagen, jetzt habe ich schon wieder was vergessen.
Ich glaube doch, dass es komplett anders sein wird, als wir überhaupt die ganze Zeit gerade bereden. So komplett anders. Ich glaube, wir gucken komplett in die falsche Richtung.
Also ich bin bei einer Sache, bin ich immer noch unter dieser Prämisse. Es kommt ein Gerät, was nicht eins ist, wie wir es bisher hatten. Was ist es dann? Dann kann das doch eigentlich nur zwischen mobil und stationär liegen.
Das ist schon mehr als portable.
Aber wenn es nur WLAN hat, wo willst du es dann hintragen? Es gibt einfach keine nennenswerte WLAN.
Das bleibt innerhalb der Wohnung. Also ich hätte auch...
Ins Bett zum Beispiel. Auf die Couch.
Ich hätte das auch gern mit uns.
Was machst du denn da in der Küche? Was machst du denn da in der Küche?
Rezepte nachschlagen. Was willst du, wenn meine Eltern kochen?
Würde ich auch schon machen.
Die nehmen ihr MacBook und nehmen das in die Küche und stellen dir die Rezepte hin.
Ja, mach ich auch. Tatsache.
Ich druck mir die aus.
Du bist aber auch mal...
Ich hab keinen Drucker.
Das haben wir 1999 oder so. Das haben meine Eltern 1999 oder so gemacht.
Das ist auch der Druckeresatz. Vielleicht heißt es auch Eye Print.
Eye Paper.
So ein Multipurpose Home Device für...
Ich will da aber schon... Ich will das doch unterwegs haben. Ich will das aus irgendwie in meinem Rucksack, der dann sehr viel leichter sein wird, einfach rausziehen, mal kurz Google Maps starten und mal kurz nachgucken, wo ich hin muss und so.
Ja, aber mit dem Tethering, das ist dann einfach mal...
Das wird die Lösung für... Zu teuer, zu kompliziert.
Du musst ja auch noch ein iPhone dazukaufen.
Ich glaube nicht, ich glaube nicht, ich glaube, dass es... Also es wird vielleicht irgendwann eine Variante mit UMTS geben, die dann, wie du richtig sagst, schon sich an irgendeinen Provider gebunden ist oder ähnliches. Ich kann mir aber auch sehr gut vorstellen, dass das wie so ein iPod Touch in erster Linie dafür gedacht ist, das hat eben nur WLAN und das braucht auch nicht mehr. Und dann wird es natürlich irgendwelche Hack-Lösungen geben, mit denen man es dann doch wieder aufkriegt und doch wieder Tethering hinkriegt und sowas. Aber das wird nicht der generische Anwendungsfall sein, sondern der wird sagen, Leute sitzen zu Hause, die haben irgendwo ihren PC in einer Ecke stehen am besten noch oder ihren Laptop, den wollen sie nicht jedes Mal aus der Tasche holen.
Das klingt so nach einer Microsoft-Werbung gerade irgendwie so. Hier, kennst du diese? Egal. Aber so Leute sitzen zu Hause.
Übelst voll Featured.
Die alten Power-Mac-Werbungen mit Dave Stewart und so.
Also ich kann mir nur vorstellen, sie müssen meiner Meinung nach ein Problem für dieses Hinstellen finden. Das ist das Teil einfach nur, weil ich einfach keinen Bock habe.
Wieviel gibt es noch irgendwie?
Ja, ein Ständer. Ja gut, das wäre eine Lösung. Ich sag ja nur, sie brauchen einen. Ja, aber wie ist das dann so, dass es nicht kaputt geht und so weiter?
Nee, wofür brauchst du einen Ständer?
Wofür ich einen Ständer brauche? Zum Hinstellen, Mann.
Damit er steht.
Jetzt wird das ja nicht jugendfrei hier, Leute. Nein, einfach so, ich will es halt auf den Tisch stellen und ich möchte, dass es genauso mich anschaut wie ein MacBook-Bildschirm auch.
Ja, dann kannst du es doch nicht bedienen.
Wieso?
Ich will es in dem Moment auch nicht bedienen.
Was willst du denn damit machen?
Film gucken.
Warum nimmst du zum Film gucken nicht das, was dafür erfunden wurde? Ein Fernseher. Ein 27 Zoll iMac. Was ist denn daran auszusetzen?
Weil ich unterwegs bin, weil ich irgendwo bin, weil ich im Zug sitze. Im Zug?
Im Zug kannst du auch in Zukunft deinen Laptop aufschauen.
Da gucken die meisten Leute mit ihren Laptops Filme. Bist du mal durch den Zug gelaufen? Wie viele Leute da einen Laptop offen haben?
Tim, ich will dieses Gerät auch nicht zum Film gucken nutzen. Ich sage, das wird nicht...
Du bist nicht die fucking Zielgruppe.
Ja, du auch nicht.
Doch, doch, doch, doch.
Im Zug hat man eh...
Ich brate eh meinen Einstieg aus der Computertechnologie vor. Das wäre optimal, um mit dem Absprung zu...
Ich glaube, das Gerät, für das du die zielgruppe, die originäre Zielgruppe bist, das musst du noch erfunden werden.
Das iPhone?
Hat mich voll erwischt.
Ich geb's zu, das iPhone, ich bin die fucking Zielgruppe. Weil du kein T-R-R-Ring hast.
Das ist richtig. Ich sag nur, ich bin die Zielgruppe. Ich sag nicht, dass es mich hundertprozentig schon erreicht hat.
Ich glaube, das wird kein Gerät zum Filmegucken sein, weil Filmegucken im Zug kann man mit dem Laptop auch ziemlich gut. Das ist schwer. Aber du bist eh im Zug, da ist eh ein Laptop dabei.
Nein, das ist doch genau der Punkt. Ich habe keinen Laptop dabei, weil ich keinen...
Was machst du an dem Ort, an dem du ankommst?
Vielleicht mal einfach amüsieren.
Was ich mache, wenn ich ankomme? Leute treffen, Gespräche...
Genau, mit denen nimmst du zum Beispiel Podcasts auf. Da hast du dein Laptop dabei.
Ja, Tim, aber nicht der Otto-Normal-Hoschi.
Doch, natürlich.
Ich will nicht überall mein Laptop mitstellen.
Wie viele Leute in Deutschland fahren mit dem Rechner durch die Gegend irgendwie mit dem Zug, um dann Podcasts aufzunehmen?
Die Leute haben Gründe, ich sag ja daraus, dass man daraus keinen Massmark abbleiben kann. Die Leute haben Gründe, ihren Laptop mitzunehmen, wenn sie im ICE fahren. Das werden sie auch in Zukunft machen. Das werden sie nicht durch ein Ice-Lead ersetzen, weil sie wollen da irgendwas machen, da wo sie sind. Sie wollen da auch mal ein paar Mails schreiben, und so weiter und so fort.
Die Zahl der Leute ohne Laptop ist größer als mit... Ja, das sind die, die sie haben wollen.
Nein, gibt's noch News eigentlich?
Aber du hast ja auf dem Tablet...
Aber Tim, wenn jetzt, wenn das Gerät vorgestellt wird...
Ich mach Max einfach mal lachen.
Wenn das Gerät vorgestellt wird und kein Ständer dran hat, dann sagst du, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, sie haben den Markt vorbei entwickelt oder wie?
Nein, das sag ich nicht. Ich werde mir das mit großem Interesse anschauen. Und alles, was ich jetzt sage, ist zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo das vorgestellt wird, wahrscheinlich unverständlich. Wir haben natürlich einfach viele Informationen nicht. Die Apple einfach hat. Die wissen, wovon sie was verkaufen und die wissen, wovon sie nicht so viel verkaufen. Die wissen wahrscheinlich aus ihren Usability-Tests, haben die einfach Erkenntnisse und was weiß ich, an welcher neue Basistechnologie sie ihre Hände gerade dran haben. Ich meine, ich hätte auch vor dem iPhone vielleicht gesagt, ach, Touch, weiß ich nicht, ob das funktioniert, weil es einfach diesen Touchscreen, den sie da verwendet haben, mit dieser hohen Präzision so nicht gab. Deswegen fällt es mir da sehr schwer, da ein abschließendes Urteil zu finden, was jetzt irgendwie taugen wird oder nicht. Ich denke eben mehr darüber nach, was ist die eigentliche Botschaft? Denn Jobs geht immer auf die Bühne und hat auch ein Nutzerverhalten, was er sozusagen mitbringt. Das war bei dem iPod so, das ist auch generell so. Und deswegen muss man sich einfach über Leute Gedanken machen, die eben derzeit irgendwas noch nicht kaufen. Nämlich zum Beispiel einen Laptop. Obwohl sie an sich schon auch ein Interesse daran hätten, das Netz zu nutzen. Aber sie würden sich nicht so was mit Tasten kaufen.
Es ist kein Laptop-Ersatz. Es wendet sich an Leute, die schon einen Laptop haben.
Es ist kein Ersatz.
Also meine Oma wäre das genau das Richtige.
Das ist etwas für Leute, die keinen haben wollen oder damit nicht glücklich geworden sind.
Nein, es ist auch nicht mit der Komplexität eines Betriebssystems da so auseinandersetzen wollen.
Ja, auch dieses Mac OS X, das kann man doch keinem zumuten. Nein, das kann man mir ja nur in Ausnahmenfällen überhaupt zumuten.
Du würdest doch nicht ernsthaft deiner Oma so ein Eislate hinter setzen.
Natürlich, ich will, dass die Internet benutzen, ich will, dass die irgendwie ihre E-Mails lesen, ich will, dass die in der Wikipedia rauskommen.
Und dann sagst du ihr, jetzt braucht ihr noch einen DSL-Anschluss dazu?
Meine Eltern wollen jetzt auch Internet haben, da graust es mir schon davor.
Die haben noch kein Internet?
Also wenn da UMTS drin wäre, wäre das ja perfekt.
Weil es langsam ist, irgendwie.
Die könnten sich aber auch schon jetzt ein Netbook machen.
Aber Netbook ist scheiße. Wir kommen nicht vorwärts.
Ich denke, wir können jetzt auch nicht...
Also ich glaube nicht, dass Steve Jobs auf die Bühne kommt und sagt, wir wollen ein Gerät machen für Leute, die keine Laptops wollen.
Da wäre ich jetzt mal ganz vorsichtig, dass du nicht mit genau dieser Aussage voll gegen die Wand fährst und er genau das sagt. Das sagt er auf keinen Fall.
Darauf setze ich 10 Kästen Mate.
Dann ist zumindest hier die Mateversorgung gesichert. Leute, wir kommen hier nicht vorwärts. Wir haben jetzt auch schon gut eine Stunde geredet, glaube ich, über dieses Tablet. Dennis hat Hunger. Und Yorke will nach Hause. Genau. Da bleibt uns doch jetzt eigentlich nur zu sagen. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Das war mobileMacs. Wir haben jetzt erstmal ein bisschen Themen nachgeholt. Und ich hoffe, dass wir in diesem Jahr, 2010, da nochmal ein paar Innovationen hier reinbringen in unser kleines Format. Ideen dafür gibt es. Und wir müssen dann auch mal wieder ein bisschen uns mehr an der Nachrichtenlage, die nicht schon seit zwei Monaten rumliegt, orientieren. Aber wir hatten etwas Schwierigkeiten, hier immer gemeinsame Termine zu finden. Ich hoffe, das wird sich ein bisschen lösen, das Problem. Haben wir sonst noch irgendwelche Botschaften, die wir unbedingt hinterlassen möchten?
Alle IPv6 benutzen jetzt.
Genau.
Ihr könnt zumindest mal ausprobieren, ihr werdet Schwierigkeiten haben, aber es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall das ganze Mal zu.
Schade ist, die Geschichte mit meinem Neverending Telekom hat geändert. Ich habe jetzt einen DSL-Anschluss. Ich erzähl mal ein nächstes Mal von meinem DSL-Anschluss. Das wird lustig.
Das ist gut. Ich hab jetzt hier auch DSL.
Dann erzählen wir mal DSL traurige Geschichten.
Genau, wir können mal wieder traurige DSL-Geschichten erzählen. Kommt drauf an.
Was so rauskommt demnächst. Wann ist die Vorstellung vor oder nach unserem nächsten Termin?
Wenn dieser Termin gehalten wird, dann sind wir so ein paar Tage danach. Und wenn wir unseren Termin halten vor allem.
Ich hab damit keine Probleme.
Noch nie gehabt.
Das steht jetzt im Internet. Dann sagen wir alle mal ganz schön ordentlich brav Tschüss.
Tschüss.
Ich wünsche dir das große Stück Kuchen.
Bis bald!